A DISK CLEANUP SOME
HOUSEKEEPING HERE- LET ME- CALL
THE LABOR PUBLICLY RETIREMENT
THE MEETING TO ORDER. AT TODAY-
I AM SATURDAY CORTEZ HE'S
CHERRY COMMITTEE AND- JOINED
BY. A MALE BODIES CHURRO
TROUBLED AND IT APPEARS THAT.
WE HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE'LL GET
TO THAT. IN JUST A MOMENT- YOU
MAY THE COR NINETEEN INTERPRET
THE PUBLIC LEADERS AND
EMPLOYEES. YOU MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS ENDED
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING THE
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS AS
SOON AS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC TENANTS HAVE ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS. TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME
TO BE DETERMINED BY THE CHAIR-
THAT WOULD BE ME AS I JUST SAID
AND WE WILL HAVE TIME LIMITS
TODAY- IN I WILL NOW SO'S
SHORTLY. ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES- SO I WILL REMIND
ABOUT THAT BUT THOSE
COMMUNITIES TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE TO SPEAK- SHOULD LIMIT.
THEMSELVES TO NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION OPPOSE OR SUPPORT
AS THE CASE MAY BE- TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF PUBLIC TO
TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS. HELLO FOLKS WILL
BE IN THOSE ROOMS AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE REFER
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WITH
TESTIFIED TODAY. PROHIBITIONS
WHICH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COME
THE PART TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. BUT I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SIX FIVE FOUR TWO
EIGHT NINE SEVEN. AGAIN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SIX FIVE FOUR
TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TOLL CONVERT SYSTEM WORKS.
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. PURPOSES ONLY ONE
TIME IN PLEASE WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO SIGN YOU'LL
FIND NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL YOU MY NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL BE A MUTED AND
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST. REPEAT
MUST. MUTE THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. PLEASE DO NOT HAVE TWO
DEVICES OPEN AT THE SAME TIME
WE'VE HAD THAT HAPPEN IN A FEW
COMMITTEES AND I CAN DELAY
EVERYONE. AS MUCH AS FIFTEEN
MINUTES. IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN AN INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE FOR HEATHER CONNECTIONS
MUTED. FOR EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HIRING PROCESS AND CONDUCT A
HEARING TO IN S. CLOSE. TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE JUST
SEEMS. TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
INCLUDING YOUR CHAIR. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL. IMPATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD
WE DO HAVE TEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA WE HAVE ONE GO ON
CONSENT SB SIX THIRTY FOUR OUR
COMMITTEE CLEANUP BILL- IF
THERE'S NO OBJECTION FROM THE
COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
UP THE BILL FIRST. THAT WE HAVE
FOR EVERYONE HERE IT APPEARS
BEFORE YOU GO TO THAT- LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM IN THE HOUSE
FOR THE ROLL CALL TO BE CALLED.
SENATOR CORTEZ C. SENATOR- CHAU
BOKE HERE. SENATOR DORADO.
SENATOR LAYERED HERE SENATOR
NEWMAN HERE. WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU. FOR MORE THAN HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED AND WE GO TO-
SB SIX THIRTY FOR THE- PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT CLEAN UP
ITEM THAT IS ON CONSENT WE CAN.
UNDERSTAND IT TAKE UP EMOTIONAL
CONSENT MOTION BY A DRAWS SO
ANY FURTHER COMMENT. QUESTIONS
ALL IN FAVOR. SIGNIFY BY HI THE
APPROPRIATE OR WE PICK AND ROLL
CALL VOTE THROUGH THE
CONSULTANTS AND YOU DO THAT I'M
SORRY. HELLO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE RE REFER TO
THE COMMISSION COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SENATOR CORTEZ HE- BY.
SENATOR OCHO BOKE SENATOR- CHAU
BOAKYE SENATOR DRAWS UP SENATOR
DORADO I'D CENTER LAYERED-
LAYERED I SENATOR NEWMAN ALL
RIGHT CENTER NEWMAN AYE WE HAVE
FIVE VOTES. THANK YOU THAT THE
TOOLS OUT- I UNDERSTAND THAT
BERMAN HEARD FROM SENATOR
BRADFORD. THAT HE WAS HAVING.
FOR TODAY'S HEARING AT THIS
TIME IN MY UNDERSTAND IS
CENTERED ACROSS A WILL BE
PRESENTING ON. SB. SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. THE ROSA YOU'RE WELCOME
TO STAY UP HERE IF YOU LIKE- IS
YOUR- YOUR DECISION I KNOW YOU
HAVE A NUMBER OF BILLS AND IF
YOU PREFER TO PRESENT DOWN HERE
IN SEQUENCE YOUR- AVAILABLE.
MORE WORK FOR YOU GUYS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- MEMBERS
ON BEHALF OF UP SENATOR
BRADFORD I'M PRESENTING SB
SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT WHICH
EXPLICITLY PROHIBITS WORKERS
COMPENSATION BENEFITS FROM
BEING REDUCED BECAUSE OF
IMMUTABLE FACTORS LIKE RACE
GENDER OR GENETIC MAKE UP. THIS
BILL DIRECTLY ADDRESSES A
RECENT COURT DECISION THAT
RESULTED IN A 49% REDUCTION OF
AN INJURED WORKER'S PERMANENT
DISABILITY BENEFITS SOLELY
BECAUSE OF A PRE EXISTING
GENETIC DISPOSITION IN OTHER
WORDS THIS INDIVIDUAL HAD HIS
BENEFITS CUT IN HALF BECAUSE OF
HIS DNA. THE COURT DECISIONS
THAT THE PRESIDENT PRESIDENT
FOR THE CONSIDERATION OF OTHER
FACTORS BEING USED AS A BASIS
FOR REDUCING BENEFITS INCLUDING
RACE WHICH WOULD
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
WORKERS OF COLOR SB SEVEN EIGHT
EIGHT CORRECT THIS INJUSTICE BY
PROHIBITING THE CONSIDERATION
OF SUCHFACTORS. WHEN MAKING A
DETERMINATION ARE WORKERS
DISABILITY CLAIMS THIS BILL
WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL WORKERS
ARE TREATED EQUALLY AND FAIRLY
IT WOULD MAKE CERTAIN THAT WE
ARE NOT MAGNIFYING THE
DISCRIMINATION MANY OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE WORKERS CURRENTLY
USE FACE I RESPECTFULLY ACTS
BROWN AYE VOTE- THERE ARE TWO
WITNESSES PRESENT ON THE SHOULD
BE PRESENT ON THE PHONE TODAY.
KRISTI BOWMAN WITH A CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
ALBERTO TO RECALL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA APPLICANTS ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION- WE MAY HAVE
ANOTHER PERSON. FOR TECHNICAL
OR LEGAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER. THE THIRTY THANK YOU
SENATOR OF WILL MOVE TO. THE
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS SO AND AS
I UNDERSTAND IT'S CHRISTY BALMA.
MODERATOR SHE'S NOT ONLINE THIS
OVER TO RECALL AVAILABLE. YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN I AM ON THE
LINE BUT- THEM THE SATIRICAL
PLEASE PROCEED A WILL BUTCHER
YOUR TESTIMONY THIS TIME. HAPPY
TO THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN ALBERTO
TRICKLE ME ON THE CALIFORNIA UP
CAN ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION ONE
THANK YOU MR CHILLIN BAKER
STUFF FOR THE ANALYSIS AND-
GOOD WILL AND WOOD WORKING ON
THIS MEASURE- THANK OF COURSE
CENTER PREFERENCES IN THE
MEASURE AND- SENATOR RAJA
PRESENTING TODAY. I DON'T
REALLY HAVE MUCH TO ADD OTHER
THAN- YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS A
LONG HISTORY OF. ANTI
DISCRIMINATION STATUTES
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO
THE WORKPLACE THIS BILL SIMPLY
BOOKS TO BRING WORKERS COMP IN
LINE WITH THOSE. AND WE'VE
LISTED IN THE BILL A NUMBER OF
PROTECTED CLASSIFICATIONS THAT
SHOULD BE PROHIBITED FROM BEING
USED TO CUT WORKERS
COMPENSATION BENEFITS AS WAS
THE CASE IN THE AS WELL AS
HAPPEN IN THE RICE CASE.
DESCRIBERS CENTER DRAWS OF. AS
I SAY THIS. WILL BRING HELP IN
LINE WITH OTHER ANTI
DISCRIMINATION STATUTES
PROJECTS IN THE WORKPLACE. AND
I ALSO HAVE JASON MARKETS ON
THE LINE ABOUT THIRTY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS COME UP FOR ME THE
MEMBERS- RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NOVEL MEASUREMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER TO RECALL LET
ME JUST ASK ONE MORE TIME IF
CHRISTY BOWMAN IS AVAILABLE.
YOU CARE I AM I APOLOGIZE SIR.
THAT'S OKAY YOU MAY PROCEED
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHRISTY
BELMONT. I'M HERE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF MORE THAN THIRTY
THOUSAND FIREFIGHTERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE PLEASED
TO BE CO SPONSORS. OF THE
MEASURE. FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY
LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH AT RISK
EVERY DAY. THEIR COMMUNITIES
BATTLING WILDFIRES RESPONDING
TO DEVASTATING DISASTERS AND
PROVIDING EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES. THEY HAVE ALL THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION STATION
SYSTEMS NOT A MATTER OF IF BUT
WHEN. TODAY SYSTEM REMAINS A
CHALLENGE FOR ANY INJURED
WORKER HOPING TO GET CARE AND
COMPENSATION FOR INJURIES
SUFFERED ON THE JOB AND IT'S NO
DIFFERENT FOR FIREFIGHTERS.
THAT THE AFTER STUDY
DEMONSTRATE THE FIREFIGHTERS
THAT WORKED SO HIS ON THE JOB
THAT LEAD TO DEADLY CANCERS.
REMARKABLY IN SOME CASES THE
SYSTEM IN THE BREAST CANCER
CONTRACTED BY A FEMALE
FIREFIGHTERS DIFFERENTLY THAN.
TESTICULAR CANCER CONTRACTED BY
THEIR MALE COUNTERPARTS. FIVE
FIRE SIDE BY SIDE IN THE OR THE
SAME TOXINS INTO THEIR BODIES
BUT THEY'RE NOT TREATED THE
SAME WHEN IT COMES TO
COMPENSATION FOR THOSE
INJURIES. FIFTY SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT WE'RE GOING TO STOP TO
THAT IT'S ABOUT TIME FOR THESE
REASONS WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. THANK I. YOU
THANK YOU HIS BONA- YES WAS
SIR- THE LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS OR WITNESSES. C. NINE-
LET ME ANNOUNCE HERE LET ME
KNOW TO THISTIME I INDICATED
THE EARLIER THAT WE WILL HAVE A
TIME LIMIT SO BE A MAXIMUM. A
TIME LIMIT. OF FIVE MINUTES PER
LEAD. TESTIMONY HI A HAND. WE
WILL HAVE A MAXIMUM OF FIFTEEN
MINUTES FOR A TELECONFERENCE
OPPOSITION IN SUPPORT
REGARDLESS OF THE NUMBER OF
SPEAKERS ARE WITH US FROM OUR
STAFF FOR OUR CONSULTANTS TO
LET ME KNOW OR THE MODERATOR TO
LET ME KNOW- WHEN THAT FIFTEEN
MINUTES. HAS ARRIVED AGAIN
REGARDLESS OF THE NUMBER OF
SPEAKERS AT WHATEVER POINT NAY
TRUST MODERATOR WILL DO THAT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME- THANK
YOU- LET US EARN NOW- FOR THAT
AND- COME BACK. TO- THE SENATE
BILL SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT HERE
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S SOME
ANYONE HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY. ON
THIS BILL C. NONE HELLO WE WILL
LOOK TO THIS BILL OVER ROOM AND
TWENTY FORTY TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE THERE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN THIS BILL SEEN NONE WE WILL
GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE IN LESS THE MODERATOR.
IT IS OR ANYONE QUEUED UP TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT AT THIS TIME.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE
GATHER THE LINE NUMBERS. WE DO
HAVE TWO PARTIES IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. AND WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR THEIR NUMBERS TO BE
STATED. YOU DO HAVE YOUR LEAD
OPPOSITION JASON SCHMELZER AND
FIFTH LARGEST. ON THE LINE
WAITING TO TESTIFY AS WELL.
LET'S LET'S GO BACK I'M SORRY
MISUNDERSTOOD I DIDN'T REALIZE
THAT WE HAD THE LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- IN ATTENDANCE- WE
WILL GO TO THEM. SO FOR ME TO.
PICTURE JERAD MEMBERS STATE
BORDERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY HERE TODAY
WITH AN IN BETWEEN POSITION AT
THE PORT OF AMENDED LET ME
BEGIN BY SAYING THAT WE ARE
UNEQUIVOCALLY RENOUNCING RACISM
AND DISCRIMINATION AND ANY FORM
WE'VE PROVIDED AMENDMENTS THAT
FURTHER CLARIFY EXISTING LAW
WHICH PROHIBITS DISCRIMINATION
IN PROVIDING WORKERS
COMPENSATION BENEFITS. UNDER
EXISTING LAW EVERY TIME A
DOCTOR PREPARED A REPORT ON IF
THE CLAIM TO WORKPLACE INJURY
AS PERMANENTLY DISABLING THE
PHYSICIAN MUST DETERMINE
CAUSATION AND WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF THE INJURIES DUE TO NON
OCCUPATIONAL ISSUES INCLUDING
PRIOR WORKPLACE INJURY IN. THIS
PROCESS PORTION MEANT BASED ON
THE PHYSICIAN'S REPORT AN
INJURED WORKER'S PERMANENT
DISABILITY OR EXPEDIA WARD AT
THE JACKET APPROPRIATELY SO
THAT THE EMPLOYERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DISABILITY
THAT CAUSED. BY INDUSTRIAL
INJURY. ONLY A PHYSICIAN TO IF
REPORT AND- ANSWER WHAT DEGREE.
NOT EMPLOYER. NOT LAWYERS WHO
HAVE THE IN AT THE APPLICATION
ATTORNEYS ARE STILL WE
COMPENSATED BASED ON A
PERCENTAGE OF THE GDP AWARD. I
REQUESTED AMENDMENT WOULD
ENSURE THAT ANY APPORTIONMENT
IT'S NOT DONE ON THE BASIS
CONSIDERING WHAT SOMEONE MAY
HAVE IDENTIFIED CHARACTERISTICS
BUT RATHER UNSPECIFIC
DIAGNOSABLE PATH OLOGY OR
FACTORS THAT THEY ACTUALLY HAD.
ONE FINAL NOTE ON APPORTIONMENT
THE APPORTIONING OF ACADIA WAR
IT HAS NO IMPACT ON AND ABILITY
OF AN INJURED WORKER TO RECEIVE
MEDICAL CARE EVEN IN THE EVENT
THAT A PD AWARD AT THE PORTION
2% THE WORKER HAS THE RIGHT TO
MEDICAL CARE IF THE INJURY
ARISES OR OCCURS IN THE COURSE
OF EMPLOYMENT. AND MEDICAL CARE
IS DETERMINED BY EVALUATING OR
TREATING PHYSICIAN. MEDICAL
CARE ITS EMPLOYER FUNDED
THROUGH THEIR WORKERS
COMPENSATION COVERAGE WE REMAIN
COMMITTED TO THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION. OF OUR REQUEST
FOR COMMENT AND THANK YOU. YES
TO THE HARPER CAN FOR. IF I MAY
IN THE MODERATOR- WE ARE NOW
HEARINGFROM. TELECONFERENCE.
IN SUPPORT NO. WE SHOULD HAVE
DONE NEED TO SUPPORT FOR THOSE
THAT ARE QUEUED UP OR THE
SPEAKER. WE SHOULD DO OF THE
NEED TO SUFFER FOR SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT UNDERSTOOD THE WAR CUED
UP AND THAT'S WHY WE WENT TO A
TO GET THE OPPOSITION IN WEBER
WAITING FOR ABSOLUTELY FOR THE
SUPPORT TO BE QUEUED UP AND NOW
WE'LL GO BACK TO SUPPORT NOW
THAT THEIR QUEUE TO. REMIND
EVERYONE. UNDER SUPPORT YOU'RE
LIMITED TO NAME AFFILIATION.
HOME IN YOUR POSITION SUPPORTER
OPPOSED. AND NINE SEVENTY SIX
OF MINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN IMMERSION
DUSTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. SEVEN NINE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FOR BECKY GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. WHAT MOMENT WE DO HAVE
ONE THE LION KING. YEAH. THE
MODERATOR- WE'RE NOT HEARING
THE MODERATOR OR ANY FURTHER
TESTIMONY IS OR ANYONE Q.
ANYONE ELSE QUEUED UP TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. ONE MOMENT WE DO
HAVE LINE EIGHTY ONE. POINT
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD TO
MAYBE ON MUTE. MURRAY WE'RE
GOING TO ASSUME THAT THE
THERE'S A TECHNICAL PROBLEM AND
MOVE ON- ILL LET US KNOW IF FOR
THAT GETS CLEARED UP AT SOME
POINT BEFORE WE CONCLUDE THE
PROCEEDINGS ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. NOW WE'VE ALREADY HEARD
FROM THE LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS WE ASK IF THERE'S ANY.
ADDITIONAL LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES HAVEN'T SPOKEN. YES
MR CAROLINE MY MOM ON THE LINE-
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE HI MY NAME'S
JASON SCHULTZ- I'M HERE TODAY
BUT THE CALIFORNIA COALITION ON
WORKERS COMPENSATION AND THE
SIMILAR OUT SUPPORTERS AMENDED
POSITION EXPECTED JAVA. WE
WANNA GO AHEAD MR JANET
OURSELVES WITH THOSE COMMENTS
AFTER A FEW ADDITIONAL
PERSPECTIVES- ONE I JUST WANNA
BE CLEAR I THINK THAT WE
BELIEVE BASED. IT ALLOWED A TO
A RISK FACTOR AS OPPOSED TO
ACTUAL DISABILITY- IS NOT
ALLOWED- THAT BEING SAID. EVEN
THOUGH THE STATUTE IS WHAT IT
IS THAT'S WHAT IT SAYS WE
UNDERSTAND THE NEED I THINK TO
PROTECT AGAINST CERTAIN- BAD
OUTCOMES AND WE CAN BE
COMFORTABLE GETTING TO SOME
COMPROMISE LANGUAGE AS HAS BEEN
INDICATED. WOULD YOU WANT TO BE
CAREFUL THE WAY THAT THAT THAT
THE WORD AND- APPORTIONMENT OF
THE CRITICAL PIECE OF THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM-
FROM AN EMPLOYER PERSPECTIVE
BECAUSE IT PROTECTS EMPLOYERS
FOR PAYING FOR DISABILITY BUT
SIMPLY WAS NOT CAUSED BY THE
WORKPLACE. AND THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM SO WE'RE
CRAFTING SOMETHING WE NEED TO
BE CAREFUL THAT IT DOESN'T
COMPLETELY UNDERMINE ABORTION
BUT- WHICH HAS BEEN PROPOSED IN
THE PAST THAT WITH THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY REACHING
AGREEMENT ON THE BILL AND-
SUPPORTING IT ABOUT WHAT. THANK
YOU. THANK GREAT THANK FOR
BEING- ARE THERE WE'RE GONNA ON.
ARE THERE ANY WITH IN ROOM TO.
OH TWO FORTY IN I'M SO IN ROOM
FOR TWO THREE THIS COMMITTEE
ROOM WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. C. NONE MOVED TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SPILLOVER
ROOM A C. NINE. WELCOME BACK TO
THE TELECONFERENCE- SERVICE AND
ASK IF THERE ARE ANY- SPEAKERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION YOU A
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW.
FOR AN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. WE
DO HAVE TO IN Q. OUR FIRST LINE
COMES FROM ONE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOUR MEMBERS
DILLON GIBBONS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION- MICHAEL ALIGNED MY
COMMENTS WITH THAT- THE
CALIFORNIA- COLLISION ON ON
WORKERS COMP AND COULD
JEOPARDIZE WITH THE SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT FINAL COME
FROM LINE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS YOUR
MEMBERS YOUR MEMORIES ABOUT THE
AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURANCE SITUATION ALSO ALIGN
OURSELVES- OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION WORKERS COMP AND
COULD YOU HAPPEN TO SUPPORT OF
COMMENDED CONDITION. THANK YOU
AND AS A REMINDER FOR
OPPOSITION THAT ONE AND THEN.
ZERO YOUR CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION THING KILL
THE THIRTY WILL RETURN WILL
THEN COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ON THE BILL. CENTER LAYERED-
ONE QUICK COMMENT AND THEN.
ANNETTE IS WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. THERE WERE A HUNDRED
AND FORTY FOUR
NONDISCRIMINATION CODE SECTIONS
THAT WERE WOEFULLY OUT OF WHACK-
MANY OF THEM DIDN'T HAVE WOMEN
SOME SAID OLDER THINGS SUCH AS
HANDICAPPED- SOME SAID DEFERRED
THANKS FOR ETHNICITY. AND I DID
A SERIES OF BILLS THAT INDEXED
THE FIRM APPOINTMENT HOUSING
ACT CATEGORIES WITH THE
NONDISCRIMINATION CODE SECTIONS
AND THERE WERE ABOUT TEN I
COULDN'T GET DONE BECAUSE THEY
WERE TO ORDER THEY WERE TOO
COMPLICATED. THIS IS ONE AND SO
I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
AUTHOR FOR PLUNGING IN AND
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS THE
SITUATION I THINK IS HEADED IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THE
MOTION. FOR SUPPORTING IT
WHENEVER YOU WANT TO MOTION I
WILL MAKE A MOTION. THANK YOU
SENATOR WHERE WE'RE DOING ANY
OTHER. DISCUSSION OF FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
MEMBERS SURE I HAVE A QUESTION-
IS FOR THE AUTHOR NOT SURE IF-
CENTER A- DRESS WILL BE ABLE TO
ANSWER BUT I WAS JUST WONDERING
I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS BILL.
WAS IN A SIMILAR FASHION AS-
THE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
PAN BILL THAT RECEIVED-
ABSOLUTELY- BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IS THERE ANY POSSIBILITY THAT
IT COULD BE AMENDED TO REFLECT
SENATOR PAN'S BILL- I PREFER
ONE OF THE EXPERT WITNESSES
WOULD RESPOND TO THAT. MISTER
RICHARDS THIS IS ALBERTO TO
RECRUIT AND I APOLOGIZE IF I
COULD RESPOND TO THE CHAIR
MATTITUCK YES PLEASE DO- MY
BUDGET PRESENTED THE QUESTION
IN THE COMMON ATENCO WE ARE.
WE'RE WE'RE STARTING TO ANALYZE
SUBURBS ADOPTION ATTORNEYS
EARLIER WE'RE STARTING ANALYZE
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS FROM
THE OPPOSITION AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
HOPEFULLY WE CAN REACH SOME
KIND OF A CONSENSUS WITH THE
BUDGET OF COURSE HAPPY TO
PURSUE THAT AND- AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE. WE'RE WE'RE VERY CLOSE IS
EXPECTED GIVEN THE FACT THAT
THE SUPPORT. LIST AMEND ITS
IMMINENT POSITION SO I'M
OPTIMISTIC BUT WE'RE CERTAINLY
HOW DOES THE COUSINS AND HAVE A
PRODUCT FOR YOU- SOON I HOPE.
THANK YOU YOUR MEMBERSHIP. ALL
RIGHTS TO THE SENIOR FROM
COMMITTEE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE CENTER DRAWS A I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
THANK YOU BACK TO SONORA WOULD
MOVE THE BILL. THE MOVE DONE.
BY SENATOR LAYERED- WILL CALL
THE ROLL CALL PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR CORTEZ.
HI UNDER CORTEZ THE AYE
SENATOR- CHOKE. SENATOR CHOKO
COULD NOT VOTE IN THE SENATOR
ALSO. HI SENATOR ALSO I SENATOR
LAYERED HI SENATOR LAYERED I
SENATOR NEWMAN SENATOR NEWMAN I.
AT THE BILL HAS IS FOUR TO ONE.
BILLS ARE CONSIDERED- ALSO DID
YOU WANT TO PROCEED I HAVE NO
OBJECTION TO. THE TAKING SORRY
QUICK CORRECTION FOUR ZERO.
THANK YOU FOR THE CORRECTION I
HAVE NO OBJECTION TO- TAKING BY
TAKING YOU OUT OF ORDER BECAUSE
I'M THE NEXT PRESENTER
OTHERWISE ON THE AGENDA AND
YOUR- ALREADY OKAY. LET ME GET
MY- TAKE YOUR TIME IN ITS IT
AGAIN IT'S YOUR PREROGATIVE.
YOU'RE WELCOME TO STAY ON THE
DAIS AS I UNDERSTAND IT UNDER
COLD PROTOCOLS. GIVEN THE- THE
AMOUNT OF PRESENTATION YOU HAVE
TODAY HAVE MIGHT BE MORE
COMFORTABLE FOR. OKAY. YES
MISTER CHAIRS- SO JUST FOLLOW
THE- FIGGIS. GIVE ME DIRECTION.
YES WE ARE PREPARED THEN TO-
SENATOR RAZA TO HEAR YOU ON
SENATE BILL. SIXTY TWO. THE DAY
BEFORE. BUT YES PLEASE SEE
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES- OF
MEN- MANY MEN AND WOMEN WHO DO
ESSENTIAL WORK FOR ECONOMY AW%
HAVE ACTUALLY BECOME MORE
VISIBLE- FOR EXAMPLE GARMENT
WORKERS ARE ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE IN THIS HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC CRISIS. BECAUSE OF THE
WIDESPREAD EXPLOITATION AND
TRUE LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
EVEN NOW THESE VERY HIGHLY
SKILLED PROFESSIONALS ARE
PRODUCING PROTECTIVE MASKS
SOMETIMES FOR AS LITTLE AS FIVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR. DISRUPTIONS TO
THE GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAIN FROM
THIS PANDEMIC HAVE ALSO
MOTIVATED COMPANIES TO SET UP
SHOP IN LOS ANGELES. BECAUSE
THEY BENEFIT FROM THE SKILLED
CALIFORNIA'S FALLING BEHIND THE
REST OF THE WORLD IN
PROTECTIONS FOR THESE WORKERS.
LOS ANGELES HAS THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATION OF GARMENT
INDUSTRY WORKERS IN THE
COUNTRY. WITH SOME TWO THOUSAND
GARMENT MANUFACTURERS WHO
EMPLOY ABOUT FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE. MOSTLY
IMMIGRANT WOMEN WHO SPEND UP TO
TEN TO TWELVE HOURS A DAY
CUTTING SEWING AND DYING
CLOTHING. FROM DESIGNER JEANS
TO FAST FASHION RUNWAY TO FACE
MASKS AND OTHER PP. SB SIXTY
TWO MAKES CLEAR THAT A BUSINESS
CONTRACTING TO HAVE. GARMENTS
MADE IS LIABLE FOR UNPAID
MINIMUM WAGE AND OVERTIME TO
THE WORKERS WHO MANUFACTURE
THOSE GARMENTS THAT'S WHAT IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE REGARDLESS OF
HOW MANY LAYERS OF CONTRACTING.
THAT COMPANY MAY USE THIS BILL
WILL END THE MINIMUM WAGE CAR
ABOUT IN THE GARMENT INDUSTRY
WHICH ALLOWS MANUFACTURERS. TO
PAY WORKERS BY THE PIECE OR
PIECE RATE. NOT ONLY DOES THE
PIECE RATE SYSTEM ENABLE AND
EVEN JUSTIFY SUB MINIMUM WAGE
IT ALSO CREATES UNSAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS AS GARMENT WORKERS
ARE CONSTANTLY RACING AGAINST
THE CLOCK. TO COMPLETE AS MANY
ITEMS AS POSSIBLE.
MANUFACTURERS HAVE NO INCENTIVE
TO ENSURE SAFE CONDITIONS OR
THE PROPER MINIMUM WAGE AND
OVERTIME PAYMENTS. FOR THE
WORKERS PRODUCING THE GARMENTS
UNLESS THEY FACE LIABILITY.
COLLEAGUES ARE BACK TO THE DAYS
OF THE TRIANGLE SHIRTWAIST FIRE
CONDITIONS IN NEW YORK IN
NINETEEN ELEVEN IT HAS TO BE
FIXED. THESE WORKPLACE
VIOLATIONS DEEPLY AFFECT BALL
NOBLE WORKERS AND FRANKLY. MORE
DEEPLY AFFECT THE RESILIENCE OF
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AS THE
LARGEST INDUSTRY OF ITS KIND IN
THE U. S. THE APPAREL
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY IN L. A.
COUNTY PRODUCES. ALMOST FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL ANNUAL
OUTPUT. SO THESE WORKERS ARE
TRULY THE END ENGINE THAT KEEPS
THE FASHION INDUSTRY MOVING UP
WE'VE ALL HEARD IN THE SENATE
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE. LAST
MONTH WAGE THEFT IS SO
ENTRENCHED IN THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY THAT THE STATE
RESTITUTION FUND HAS BEEN ON
THE BRINK OF INSOLVENCY SINCE
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. BECAUSE
THE PROVEN CLAIMS FOR STOLEN
WAGES WERE MORE THAN THE
ACCOUNT COULD KEEP UP KEEP UP
WITH MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
PEOPLE ARE ON THIS FUNDS WAIT
LIST. FOR COMPENSATION FOR
UNPAID WAGES TOTALING MORE THAN
TEN MILLION DOLLARS. THE
RESTITUTION FUND IS SUPPOSED TO
BE A PAYER OF LAST RESORT. NOT
THE ONLY WAY FOR THESE HIGHLY
SKILLED WORKERS TO GET LEGAL
WAGES. WE NEED TO END THE
LOOPHOLES AND STOPPED STOP THE
BAD ACTOR MANUFACTURERS FROM
AVOIDING LIABILITY. THESE
LOOPHOLES ALSO HAVE MADE THE
INDUSTRY HOSTILE TO ETHICAL
GARMENT COMPANIES WHO ARE
TRYING TO ELIMINATE SWEATSHOPS
THEY'RE TRYING TO BUILD A MORE
INCLUSIVE AND FAIR GARMENT
INDUSTRY ECONOMY. AND ENSURE
THAT WHEN WE SAY MADE IN THE
USA IT REPRESENTS QUALITY AND
JUSTICE THAT IS WHY. ALMOST ONE
HUNDRED FASHION ORGANIZATIONS
AND BUSINESSES. HAVE JOINED OUR
EFFORTS THIS YEAR WITH SB SIXTY
TWO AND IT IS ALSO THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PRIORITY BILL. TODAY WE HAVE-
ALL OF THE TWO WITNESSES ON THE
LINE. GARMENT WORKER MY THE
OTHER GOVERNMENT AND NON THIS
AS WELL AS JENNA JENNA MERA
FROM BIDS ATTIC TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SENATE ROTH
THROUGH WE WILL CALL UPON YOUR
FIRST SUPPORT WITNESS AT THIS
TIME- ME US A WITNESS TO PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND PROCEED.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALEX SENSES
I'M INTERPRETING FOR MARIANA.
GOVERNMENT HERNANDEZ. YOUR
MONEY HERE. WHEN I THOUGHT OF
IT. AND I WILL GO DANTE
INCOMPATIBLE ALISON ABILITY THE
MAN NADIA THEY'VE HAVE LANDED
IT IS A HOLLOW OF MONICA. YOU
FOR EVERY THREE WHY SIGNAL I'M
NOT COMFORTABLE THE ERA
DELIVERY MULLIN SIXTY AT
WITHOUT LADY YEAH I THINK BY
THEM FOR IS NOT IN THAT WILL BE
GETTING. PROBABLY AT THE LETTER
MEDICAL BUCKET BAG BY WILL
NEARLY THAT ENOUGH I WILL GO TO
BE A. YEAH REFLECT ON IT REASON.
DIEGO LONG PLAYED IN ADAM LAST.
OKAY YOU THAT MONICA BY THEN
MORE PEOPLE. WE WERE THE PEACE
AND ONLY A COUPLE SENSE WE WANT
BRANDS TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
SO LET ME JUST. REPEAT OF
TWENTY DEVELOPMENT A PIECE RATE
EMPLOYEES COS AND HE CANNOT PAY
OFF MORE. BECAUSE THEY ARE PAID
TOO LITTLE BY THE BRAND'S. YEAH
I'M NOT FAVORITE OF COMBAT
BOCANEGRA EXPERIENCE AND LOCAL
FULLER DELAYED BUT I'LL HAVE
UNLIMITED THANK BANYULS. IN THE
STATE YEAH. I'M IN BECOME OF
THE WHAT I AND TELL BUT AGAIN
NO FIVE YEAR I DON'T MAKING
ENOUGH THING OUR THE LIGHT OF
THE WRONG. A GALLUP TRACKING.
MONDAY POLL THAT HAVE HE HAD.
HE. WHAT THE RECORD. I
PERSONALLY TO SHARE A LITTLE
MAKES AND GOVERNMENT AND I HAVE
WORK FOR THIRTY YEARS THE
GARMENT STARTING AS TREMOR I AM
ORE BECAUSE THAT YOU KNOW HOW
TO UP A MACHINE I ALSO HAD NO
ORDERS THEN AND SO AT THE PLUS
YOU THERE WERE HAD REFUGE IN A
COULD SEE THERE FROM FOR TO
FIVE HOUR. TO GET. ON THE
PODIUM. ADAM WITH A LOCAL. B.
M. POR. I DON'T. BUT BASS FOR
THE- THAT CONNECTED. HILEMON
SEVEN MENTAL BUT THAT. TERM AND
THEN YOU GO A FEW. HE SOMEONE
THE FOLLOWING A LOT MADE. BE
GETTING. AND IS A LONG AND-
TRAVEL BUT I FOR. ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL BY THE- IN THE
COMBINED. ONLY AND. NO NO
FEDERAL. NOW HOW DO YOU A PLACE
TO SHOP I WHAT MAKES OF THAT
WOULD BE TOWELS DURING MY
UNFORTUNATELY EMPLOY YOU MIGHT
AND ONLY ME TWENTY TWO FIVE
DOLLAR A WEEK WHICH WAS ONLY
ENOUGH TO BUY COUPLE BEING MY
COWORKERS TELL ME THEY I WAS
BEING EXPLOITED BECAUSE THEY
ARE MAKING THE- A HUNDRED
TWENTY A WE I SPOKE TO MY
EMPLOYER LAST RECALL ME HE PAID
ME EVERY DAY ON MONDAY. FINALLY
GOT TO WORK ON MONDAY. HE HAD A
CO DOWN IN BEEN IN PAIN. YEAH.
HELLO THIS GAME BUT I'M HAVE A
COUPLE AND IT'S BACK IN MY
APOLOGIES I GOING TO HAVE KNOW
THAT. THE PLACE THE REASONABLE
SALARY AND I WOULD CALL THE
NINETEENTH WE ARE EXPOSED TO
INFECTION MANY COWORKERS RENDON
CHICKEN SOME HAVE EVEN DIED.
NOT A PROBLEM AND HOW LONG ALAS.
AND SAFE UP YOU CAN GO IN A FOR
MORE COLOR ONLY P. ALEX WITH
PRIVATE EXAM MOSCOW EDS THE BUT
I WILL THE DALLAS HE OCTOBER OF
NOTHING OF THE FAMILY BEFORE
THE END. WE DO NOT PROVIDE I'M
SO PROUD. EITHER OR EVEN CLOSE
PAPER WE ARE. WORKERS MAY MASK
HOSPITAL ROBES. WE DON'T EVEN
HAVE SOCIAL THIS. THE LEVEL.
THE MORE. WHAT FOR YOUR BUT I
KEPT WEARING AND I IN AND BY.
WHICH HAS BEEN ASKING. THANK
YOU THE NONPROFIT LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
REPRESENTED HUNDREDS OF GARMENT
WORKERS OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS AND WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR SB SIXTY TWO. IN OUR
WORK WE HAVE SEEN OVER AND OVER
AGAIN WHAT MR NANDO'S DESCRIBED
SO POWERFULLY AND ETHICAL
BUSINESSES HAVE UNIT TO WHICH
IS WHY SO MANY GARMENT INDUSTRY
BUSINESSES SUPPORT FAILED TO
PROTECT WORKERS ELIMINATE
WEBSHOP AND LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD. AS ACADEMIC RESEARCH AND
GOVERNMENT BODIES MAKE CLEAR
ABUSE OF THE P. THREE IS ONE OF
THE ROOT CAUSES OF THE
WIDESPREAD WAGE THEFT THAT
PLAGUED THE INDUSTRY. IN
ADDITION OF CHAIN COMPANIES
THAT USE SUBCONTRACTING TO HAVE
THEIR CLOTHING MADE IT UNLAWFUL
CONDITIONS ARE NOT HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. HOLDING BRANDS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE WORLD A
PLAY IN THE PRODUCTION CHAIN
MORE INCENTIVIZE THEM TO PAY
FOR GOODS AT PRICES
COMMENSURATE WITH WORKERS
EARNING THE MINIMUM WAGE AND
THE USED BATTERIES THAT COMPLY
WITH THE LAW. AS LONG AS THE
CURRENT LOOPHOLES EXACT
ENFORCEMENT IS NOT SUFFICIENT
TO COMBAT THE ENTRENCHED
PATTERN OF WIDESPREAD REGION
OUR VIOLATION. THE BUREAU FIELD
ENFORCEMENT CANNOT CURRENTLY
QUITE A CHAIN COMPANY AND WERE
WHITE GARMENT THAT. SCHNATTER
DORADO THE GUY WORKER FUNDED IN
THE RED WHICH FORCES PACKED
THAT THAT THE IN BAD ACTORS
GENERAL FUND OUR. THE CRIME HAS
COME TO FULLY RE THE- OF AB
THIRTY THREE THANK THESE
LOOPHOLES THE KARMA INDUSTRY
HAS OF ALL TO A EXPLOIT. THESE
REASONS WE ARE ARE YOUR I. VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO THE
WITH SO WILL NOW- CALL ON ANY.
HE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHICH
IS TESTIFY IN SOME. OF S. SIX
TWO SEEN WILL. LOOK TO- ROOM TO
FOUR. FOUR WHO WISHES TO TEST
FINDS. OF THIS PIECE TWO. SEE
NOT LOCAL TOLL. ORVIS MASTER
MODEL. HEAD INDICATE- IF WE
HAVE. HI SPEED IN SUPPORT CUTER
AND IF HOW MAY. THANK YOU A FEW
AREN'T THE YOU PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO YOUR IN
SUPPORT. ONE MOMENT. WE HAVE
TWENTY FIVE IN Q. WE WILL GO TO
OUR FIRST LINE OF SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- COUNTY BANDEL AND
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU THE NEXT LINE
WILL GO TO FIND THE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOVERNOR
MESENTERIC SCIENCE OF
POLYTECHNIC ELECTIONS AND POWER.
THE PRODUCT ACOSTA HERE READ
MORE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANNEX
OF THE LINE OF ONE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED
MEMBERS JACQUI GRAHAM IF YOU
HAVE TO W. AFTER CAPE TOWN AND
DRAW SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. EXCELLENT A ONE A ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
KEVIN INFO FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF YOU SHOULD
TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS DANIELLE CANDLE
KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT ON THE LINE A ONE OLD FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAISY ONE
SALAS AND I AM ON THE CALL
WITH- YOU GARMENT WORKERS WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE A COMMENT ON START
WITH THE BAD NOT A NOT. AN
EVENT IN NUMBER. WHEN THE
THOUGHT OF A ANOTHER.
CHARACTERS NUMBER BUT I'M NOT
LISTED NOT. USUALLY PROBLEM
LOOKED. CITY OKAY. FOR ALL OF
MY IT OR POLITICALLY OKAY. I
MAKE. YEAH BUT YOU KNOW I
LEARNED. THE MODERATOR OF
TERRORISM LOT OF THE NUMBER OF
THE LOCAL. NUMBER OF BILLS AND
OTHER COSTS WILL. I FULLY- YEAH
MY LEFT FOOT YOU DON'T LOCKED
UP OR- C. L. LA ESTIMATED BEEN
BASED. AND THAT'S WHAT PLACE- A
MOST BEFITTING UNITED I WILL A
FEAR- YOU DUMP OUT THAT IF
PROBABLY A LOT OF MY- YEAH.
MODERATOR TRAINER LANDAY.
WATERY WE CAN- WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT OF IT FINAL. NUMBER
SEPARATING IT ON THIS. PRODUCT
LARA FABIAN ROBINSON PUBLIC BUT
FOLDER DOES. PUBLIC BUT I CAN'T
FOR YOUR. HEY IT'S A
RESTRICTION THOSE. BUT ALMOST
WITH THIS IN YOUR- BODY UP IN A
MONITOR DAY NOT- A MASS OF LOS
OF PERCENT THE SENATE AND IN-
AN APPLE YOU KNOW THE S. BASS
AND BY THOSE DIFFERENT AND I'M
THAT. ON THE DAY. A HANDSHAKE
IS GONNA PRESS THAT IS SUPPOSE
TO SEE ON THEIR- YOU. SEE AND
THEY IS THE MOM THE GRASS. IF
YOU CAN SEE CALL. GOOD
AFTERNOON CANACCORD GENUITY TO
PUT I'M A MEMBER ON THE LAND
BOULDERS IN THERE ARE WHAT ARE
HAVING PEOPLE LIVE OUT MEANS
FOR OVER MANY MANY YEARS AND
I'M CALLING TO YOU. TO YOU IF
YOU COULD DO TO TODAY. WE
APOLOGIZE FOR ANY
MISUNDERSTANDING. THANK YOU AND
WE'RE GONNA FIND A ONE SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE
SIXTEEN. SORRY MAX OVER LINE OF
NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- THIS IS
MICHELLE GAYLE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEKOGA LINE OF
ONE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE FIFTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS JILL THOMPSON I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE WOMEN AND
GIRLS RIGHTS PROJECT AT PUBLIC
COUNCIL- PUBLIC COUNCIL AND
STRONGLY SUPPORTS SB SIXTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF NINETY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CRAFTING THEIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JUST BECAUSE TENURE
ON BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES AND THE STRONGER
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK IN
STRONG SUPPORTER IF YOU. THANK
YOU AN EXTRA LINE OF FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK ONE
WITH A C. ARE YOU CALIFORNIA'S
DRUNK OF COURSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LOCAL LINE OF A
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS REBECCA GONZALEZ
FOR THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KATIE
WATER SPENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WORK AND FAMILY COALITION AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU. AND
MEXICO LINE OF FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS ABHAY
MAINTAIN WITH VOICES FOR
PROGRESS CALLING IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIX DIGIT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANNEX OF A LINE
OF FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS
THIS CAN LAND ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OR JUNIOR STRONG
SUPPORTER SB. SIXTY TWO. THANK
YOU. IN MEXICO LINE A ONE OH
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS LINDA
WATER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY TWO. THANK
YOU. AND MEXICO LINE OF SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM
TOO MY NAME IS CHELSEA HERE'S
NUMBER PREVENTING TWENTY CLASS
ENJOYED FOR CALIFORNIA FASHION
BUSINESS CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY Q. I URGE
THE SENATE TO VOTE IN SUPPORT
AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE NEXT OVER THE LINE OF
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS FOR BOTH THE CZECHO
REPRESENTING REFORMATION A
CALIFORNIA FASHION BUSINESS
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT SB
SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU. AN EXTRA
LINE OF ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE ONE THREE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE CHECK
YOUR MUTE BUTTON. OKAY WE'LL GO
ON TO THE NEXT LINE OF ONE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE WILL BORDERLINE THIRTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE END
OF THE END WITH THE ADDRESS ON
BEHALF OF LEGAL AID AT WORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXAVAR LINE OF NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY QUESTION
IS- REPRESENTING SEND THE TEMP
OF FASHION A CALIFORNIA FASHION
BUSINESS CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIXTY TWO SIXTY TWO AND I
URGE THE CLEANERS TO CLEAN I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
MEXICO LINE OF NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS MADE IN OUR CHIEF I'M
WITH THE THAT GUY AND ALSO THE
LA WORKERS CENTER NETWORK IN
THE LABOR AND DOMESTIC WORKERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
TWO. THANK YOU NEXAVAR LINE OF
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS A LEASE CONTRACT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS CALLING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANNEX OF THE LINE A ONE FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE RICHARD
SENIOR POLICY ADVISER FOR THE
COALITION TO ABOLISH SLAVERY
AND TRAFFICKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. TO PROVIDE LABOR
TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. ANNEX OF THE LINE A
ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
ERIN O'NEILL MULLIN BURKE ON
BEHALF OF FORGET BUDDY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY TWO.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT OF A LINE
OF FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE TRUCKS THANKS TO GOAL LINE
A ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS NICHOLAS BROWN
CALLING IN FROM LOS ANGELES ON
BEHALF OF FASHION REVOLUTION
USA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTY TWO WHEN I HEARD THAT
SENATORS TO VOTE I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WELL I DON'T ONE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL
I DON'T FORTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DROPPED HELLO LINE OF
NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI AND A GOOD MAN IS FACING A
CALL RIGHT I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY
WOULD WORK THERE AND YOU WANTED
TO ALSO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB SIXTY TWO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEKOGA LINE A
ONE OH TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL
YEAH BERMAN WITH LEGAL AID AT
WORK AND- SO WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY TWO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXAVAR LINE A
ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
KIND OF BEEN AGAIN WILLING TO
THE CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION STANDING IN
SOLIDARITY WITH GOOD GOVERNMENT
WORKERS NOW THAT. ATTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANKS LEVINE A
ONE SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS LOUIS BENEDICT
REPRESENTING THE WOMEN'S
FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO BORDER LINE OF ONE
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON ERIN PACK FROM THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF THAT B. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT TO
THE LINE A ONE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT MELODY SHEA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WHICH IS A CROWD CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND NEXT TO
GOAL LINE OF ONE SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CALDERON LAST ONE IN Q. WHICH
IS FROM ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO. AND
THERE ARE NO FURTHER US SUPPORT
IN CUBA MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
I'M HAVING HEARD FROM ALL OF-
THE SUPPORT TESTIMONY WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION UP WITH
FURTHER IDENTIFIED OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- WE WILL HEAR FROM
THEM NEXT. PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND PROCEED WE CAN
HEAR FROM. BUT WILL LEAD
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ASHLEY
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB SIXTY TWO AS A JOB KILLER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FROM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY AND I DO WANT TO
THANK SENATOR DORADO AND HER
STAFF FOR MEETING WITH US AND
THE OTHER GARMENT INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVES IN OPPOSITION
TO THE FAILED TO ADDRESS SOME
OF OUR CONCERNS. THE CONTENT OF
THIS BILL SEEKS TO PREVENT SUCH
AS THE FAILURE TO PAY MINIMUM
WAGE FOR PEACE FRAMEWORK AND
UNSAFE WORKING CONDITIONS IS
ALREADY ILLEGAL INSTEAD OF
TAKING ACTION AGAINST HIS
GARMENT MANUFACTURERS THAT ARE
VIOLATING THE LAW THE BILL HAS
A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT REGARDING
JOINT LIABILITY AND ALLOW
COMPANIES TO CONTINUE TO ACT
UNLAWFULLY BY PASSING THEIR
LIABILITY FOR WAGE CLAIMS THE
COMPANIES THAT HAVE NO CONTROL
OVER GARMENT WORKERS. THEIR
WAGES OR WORKING CONDITIONS AND
DID NOT DIRECTLY CONTRACTED THE
COMPANY UNITED VIOLATING THE
LAW EXEMPLIFIES THAT WOULD
BRING A NEW CATEGORY OF
COMPANIES THAT ARE LIABLE FOR
GARMENT WORKER WAGE CLAIMS CALL
BRAND GUARANTORS RAIN HERE IN
GEORGIA BROADLY DEFINED AND
INCLUDES COMPANIES IN THE
SUPPLY CHAIN INVOLVED THE
LICENSING MAKING TRYING
EVERYTHING- ABLE TO OR
OTHERWISE ALTERING A GARMENT IN
ANY WAY IN CALIFORNIA. NOT ONLY
DOES THE BILL EXPAND MY ABILITY
BUT IT ALSO PUT FRANK
GUARANTORS DISAPPEAR
DISADVANTAGE OF A CLAIM IS
FILED THE BILL CHANGES EXISTING
EVIDENTIARY STANDARDS FOR
GARMENT WORKERS WAGE CLAIM BY
SABOTAGING THE PRESUMPTION THAT
ONE THE RESPONDENT IS A BRAND
GUARANTOR UNDER THE BILL INTO
THAT THE WORKERS CLAIM AND THE
AMOUNT CLEAN ALL VALID AND
ACCURATE. A BRING YOUR TOWARDS
LIABILITY IS NOT LIMITED TO THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THE WORKERS
SPENT ON A PIECE OF CLOTHING
RELATED TO THAT COMPANY ANY
WORKER COULD WALK IN WITH A
SHORT CONTINUAL. SAY THEY DIED
IN ALTERNATE I THINK THE LABEL
TO WEAR OR MADE IT AND ON THE
COMPANY'S LOGO IT IS NOW
PRESUMED TO BE 1100% LIABLE FOR
ALL OF THE EMPLOYEES WAGE AT IT
DOES NOT MATTER IF THE WORKER
ONLY SPENT 1% OF THEIR TIME
WORKING ON THAT PIECE OF
CLOTHING. OR ANY OTHER CLOTHING
WITH THE COMPANY'S LOGO ON. THE
BILL ALSO LIMITS EVIDENCE CAN
BE YOU TO DEFEND AGAINST WAGE
CLAIM. FOR EXAMPLE THE BILL X.
FOR THAT HE- THE OF WEIGHT AS-
THE BRAIN HERE AND FOR. BY PAY
WERE RECORDS RECORD OF OUR
WORKED BY THAT IN. ALL OF WHICH
BELONG SOME OTHER COMPANY.
BRAND GEARED TOWARD THAT NO CAN
OVER. ACCESS TO ANY THAT IN.
WILL HAVE BILL TO PROVIDE THESE
BACK. NOR SHOULD THEY BE. TO
MAINTAIN PAYROLL OR KEEPING OR-
FOR COME. WITH WHICH THEY HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO INTERACTION YOU
KNOW CONTROL. IN SOME THIS BILL
DOES NOT ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF
COMPANIES FLOUTING ALREADY
ESTABLISHED LAW. INSTEAD IT
ALLOWS COMPANIES TO CONTINUE ON
AS USUAL AND ALTERNATELY THE
TURKISH. FROM HAVING CLOTHING
MADE IN THE. STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. USER
ANOTHER OPPOSITION WITNESS TO
HEAR FROM. HEARING NONE WILL
MOVE ON FINNEY WITNESSES HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM THAT ARE
HERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION-
BEYOND- WILL. GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY FOUR ANY OPPOSITION
SPEAKER SEE NONE WELCOME BACK
TO THE KILLED TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE. THE MODERATOR AGAIN A
REMINDER THAT WE HAVE A FIFTEEN
MINUTE MAXIMUM. AND WILL WE
WILL. ASK YOU TO QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION SPEAKERS AT THIS
TIME LET US KNOW HOW MANY THERE
ARE. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE TO
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GET THEIR
THEIR NEW LINE NUMBERS ONE
MOMENT. NAZARIAN MINDER AT ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS THIS
IS WRANGLING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND AS A
REMINDER IT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR ANY OPPOSITION. AND THE
LAST ONE IN Q. WILL GO TO LINE
OF. NINE FIFTY EIGHT. ONE
MOMENT. PINE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES THE MARKET
QUE NOVIA CALIFORNIA BACK USING
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION- WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB SIXTY
TWO. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MOTOR THANK
YOU TO ALL THE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FORCES WITNESSES IT
WILL NOT BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE CENTER NEWMAN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. CENTER RUNS RIGHT
I COMMEND YOU. FOR TAKING UP
THIS ISSUE- IN DEFENSE AND
PROTECTION OF GARMENT WORKERS
CALIFORNIA NO CALIFORNIA
WORKERS SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO
EXPLOITATION. AND AT THIS
MOMENT THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
EXCUSE FOR A WORKER IN OUR
STATE NOT BE PAID AT LEAST
MINIMUM WAGE. I DO HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS- AND I THINK THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ACTUALLY TOUCHED ON EACH. ONE
IT'S REGARDING EXISTING LAW SO
THE ASSERTION WAS MADE THAT THE
EXISTING LAWS RESULT OF
RELATIVELY RECENT PRIOR CHANGES
TO THE ROME STATUTE. SHOULD
HAVE EQUIPPED THE LABOR
COMMISSION WITH TOOLS
SUFFICIENT TO PUNISH AND DETER
BAD ACTORS IN THE GARMENT
SPACE. SO AT LEAST FOR THE
RECORD I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
ON THE LOGIC OF YOUR BILL THIS
IS CLEARLY NOT THE CASE WOULD
YOU MIND ELABORATING- ABOVE MY-
SURE WHICH- BILL YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT- SIR NEWMAN.
THERE WAS A BILL- IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN- THE LEóN SB FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT IT WAS NOT A
GARMENT INDUSTRY SPECIFIC BILL-
AND IT DOES IT WAS MEANT TO
HELP IN THE IN THE COLLECTION
BUT- THAT'S DIFFERENT FROM WHAT
WE'RE ARE TRYING TO DO HERE
TODAY- SO UNLESS THERE'S A
DIFFERENT BILL I GUESS IN IN
VERY GENERAL TERMS THE I GUESS
THE PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE THIS IS YOUR- SENSES THAT
THERE SIMPLY AREN'T TOOLS. IN
PLACE RIGHT NOW TO PROTECT
GARMENT WORKERS AGAINST PEACE
WORK- AND BY D'EXPLOITATION.
WELL THE WE HAD OF A OF A BILL
SEVERAL YEARS AGO THAT WE
THOUGHT WAS GOING TO TAKE CARE
OF THE PROBLEM AND IT DID FOR A
FEW YEARS UNTIL- EMPLOYERS
BEGAN TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
LOOPHOLES AND WE STARTED BACK
DOWN THE ROAD OF A VOID IN
THIS- IT IS NOT A MATTER OF
JUST- ENFORCING THE LAW WE HAVE
TO GIVE THE TOOLS FOR THE LABOR
AGENCY TO BE ABLE TO ENFORCE
THE LAW WITH A LOT MORE TEETH
TO IT- AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS THAT
UPSTREAM THE LIABILITY. ONE
ALSO MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR THESE
WORKERS TO BE ABLE TO WORK AND
ACTUALLY EARN THE MINIMUM WAGE
WITHOUT BEING TOLD HERE'S A
PIECE RATE AND THAT'S WHAT YOU
SHOULD FOLLOW UP BUT PRIMARILY
IT'S ABOUT FIGHTING FINDING-
GETTING LIABILITY FROM THE
UPSTREAM- COMPANIES- WHICH
AGAIN JUST YOU KNOW. TURN TO
TURN THEIR HEAD AND REFUSED TO
TAKE ANY RESPONSIBILITY FOR
WHAT IS GOING ON FOR THE
WORKERS THAT ARE PRODUCING-
THE- THE PRODUCTS THAT THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR AND IT'S JUST
SHOULDN'T BE THAT WAY SO WE'RE
TRYING TO MORE LIABILITY
UPSTREAM GIVE THE WORKERS- THE
ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
PROVIDING THE EVIDENCE. YOU
KNOW THERE'S NOBODY LIMIT IS
ELIMINATING ANY DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS IT JUST CLARIFIES-
THESE- THE EVIDENCE EVIDENTIARY
PRESUMPTIONS I THINK IT'S VERY
CHOI SO I GUESS IT'S LIKE I'VE
SPOKEN TO A BUNCH OF FOLKS. WHO
THEIR DATE THEY HAVE. NOT A
PROBLEM WITH BRAND CONSCIOUS IS
DEFINED GUESS USE COMMITTEE.
TERMINOLOGY THE OTHER QUESTIONS
HOW FAR UPSTREAM MAY HELP FOR
EXTREME IS USEFUL. AND IT YOU
KNOW DOES IT SHOULD APPLY
EQUALLY TO LICENSE SHORES AND
LICENSEES RIGHT SO DO YOU KNOW
IF A COMPANY THAT LICENSES A
BRAND. I SHOULD ABSOLUTELY BE
HELD RESPONSIBLE BUT THE
ARGUMENT IS IF I'M A LICENSE OR
YOU KNOW LET LET'S SAY THAT
PEPPA PIG ENTERTAIN BUT HERE'S
WHAT TYPE OF TAKE WHICH IS A
FIVE YEAR OLD DAUGHTER. YOU'LL
HAVE TO WATCH ALL ONE THOUSAND
EPISODES BUT YOU KNOW VERY
SUCCESSFUL BRANDS AND LICENSED
TO A FARE THEE WELL. BY THAT
LICENSURE HAS A VERY LIMITED.
AMOUNT OF INSIDER LEVERAGE ON
LICENSEES WHO SIMPLY. YOU KNOW
LICENSE THE BRAND AND THEN YOU
KNOW PROCEED TO CONTRACT OUT.
FOR THE PROTECTION OF PRICE AND
SELL THEM IN THE MARKET PLACE.
AND SO. YOU KNOW IT IT IS NOT
UNLIKELY. SAID A LICENSE OR
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LIABILITY
CREATED BY THIS PROVISION.
WHICH SHOULD BE LICENSE THEIR
PRODUCTS TO NON CALIFORNIA
FIRMS. MADE THAT THAT WOULD BE
I THINK THE NATURAL RESPONSE-
GIVEN THE LIABILITY CREATED SO.
IT YOU KNOW IS THERE ANY
THINKING TO TIGHTEN UP THE
DEFINITION OR GIVE SOME
CONSIDERATION THAT FACT. OUT OF
OUT OF DEFERENCE TO THAT
POSSIBILITY- SIR NEWMAN WE'D BE
GLAD TO THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
THAT ANYBODY'S REACHED- RAISE
THIS ISSUE- LAST YEAR THE BILL.
CAME CLOSE WE WERE AT WE HIT
THE DEADLINE THE TIMING OF IT
OR I'M SURE IT WOULD'VE IT
WOULD'VE GONE ALL THE WAY- SO.
YOU KNOW AT YOUR REQUEST TO BE
GLAD TO LOOK AT IT BUT I JUST
WANT TO REMIND US THAT. WE
DON'T WANT TO CUT BY FIXING
THAT. IN THE EYES OF SOME
COMPANIES WE DON'T WANT TO THEN
CREATE ANOTHER LEGAL LOOPHOLE
WHICH COULD BE USED- BY OTHERS
AND IT. YOU KNOW MY ONLY
CONCERN IS CREATING A WHOLE NEW
LAYER. OF CONTRACTING OUT- SO
THAT'S ONE AND ALSO THERE ARE.
COMPANIES WHO HAVE. WHO WOULD
DO. A FUNCTION AS A LICENSE OR-
THEY ALSO CAN TAKE A WE'RE NOT
INCLUDING THAT HERE BUT- THEY
CAN TAKE THEIR OWN ACTIONS. OF
THE COULD CONTRACT WITH YOU
KNOW ETHICAL GARMENT
MANUFACTURERS THEY COULD ENTER
INTO INDEMNITY CLAUSES- IN
CASE. YOU KNOW THAT THEY DON'T
PAY- THE PROPER WAGES AND WAGE
AND HOUR. OF A REQUIREMENTS SO
I THINK THERE ARE THINGS THAT
CAN BE DONE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TO REQUIRE. THE PROBLEM IS IF
WE HAVE TO STEP IN EVERY SINGLE
TIME THERE'S A NEW LOOPHOLE
CREATED OR THEY TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF CREATE A NEW LOOPHOLE. SO
I'LL BE GLAD TO. GET BACK WITH
RIGHT I APPRECIATE ON FURTHER
ON FURTHER- THOUGHT ON OUR PART
I DO APPRECIATE SO UNITS OF THE
ARMY HERE IS THAT. IT IS WE THE
LEGISLATION THEY'RE THEY'RE
CREATING THIS NEW CONCEPT BY
THE DEFINITION ABOUT BRAND
LICENSED. BRAND GUARANTOR. SO
IMPROV WORTH CONSIDERING THE
INPUT FOR THE ON A TEN
CONSEQUENCE SO I. IT WILL BE
SUPPORTED TO. THANK YOU. EIGHTY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OF COMMON
FROM THE COMMITTEE MMHM NUMBER
I SURE. SO I HAVE TO SAY THE
BOTH MY GROW. THAT WERE AT. I
GUESS YOU COULD SAY THE BABY
CLOTHING THEY SELL CLOTHING FOR
A WHILE MY FAQ I'M JUST MEASURE
LITTLE PERSONAL STORY MY
GRANDMOTHER USED TO SO THE
CLOTHING AND MY GRANDFATHER
WOULD TAKE IT INTO THE CITY TO
SELL IT IN MEXICO SO- AND I
WORKED AS A IN A TAILOR SHOP
WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL SO.
I'M REALLY DISAPPOINTED TO HEAR
THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT BEING PAID THEIR WAGES-
THAT IS JUST A HORRIBLE THING
ESPECIALLY HERE IN CALIFORNIA-
BUT I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
CONCERNS BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
CURRENTLY. MINIMUM WAGE-
REQUIREMENTS OR MANDATES IN IN
THE STATE. AND- WOULD IT BE AND
THIS IS JUST I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IN
MY IN MY VIEW MY PERSPECTIVE
THIS IS AN ENFORCEMENT ISSUE
BECAUSE- OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE
BAD ACTORS RIGHT THERE WHO ARE
NOT FOLLOWING THE LAW. AM I
CORRECT. YES OKAY SO. AND HELP
AND HELP EDUCATE ME ON THIS AND
WHO IS SUPPOSED TO BE ENFORCING
THESE MINIMUM WAGE LAWS SO THAT
PEOPLE GET PAID WELL THERE'S AN
LABOR AGENCY- WHERE YOU CAN GO
AND FILE A COMPLAINT- WHAT WE
HAVE FOUND IS AND YOU HEARD-
MUCH F THE OF THE TESTIMONY
ONE WOMAN WHO COMPLAINED FIRST
TO HER EMPLOYER BROUGHT IT TO
THE ATTENTION TO IMPORTANT SO
YOU'RE NOT PAYING ME MINIMUM
WAGE- AND HE PROMISES TO. PAY
THE MINIMUM WAGE PAY HER
ACCURATELY AND THEN SHE COMES
IN TO WORK THE FOLLOWING WEEK
AND THEY CLOSE DOWN SO THIS
INDUSTRY IS FULL OF THESE VERY
VERY SMALL AND- COMPANIES THEY
CAN JUST CLOSE DOWN AND THEN
THE FOLLOWING WEEK SHOW UP YOU
KNOW NEXT DOOR UNDER A NEW NAME
AND SO THIS WEB OF CONTRACTORS-
IS THE FIRST YOU KNOW HUGE
PROBLEM AND THE SECOND IS THAT
YOU GO UP UPSTREAM WITH THESE
COMPANIES WHO ORDER OR WHO ARE
CONNECTED WITH THE PRODUCT THAT
THEY'RE MAKING. AND THEY'RE NOT
TAKING ANY RESPONSIBILITY AND
THEY'D KNOWN MANY TIMES THAT
THEY'RE NOT PAYING. THE ADDED.
TO THAT COMPANY. TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE A PROFIT AND THEN PAY
THEIR WORKERS BUT WHAT THEY
GIVE TO THAT THOSE CONTRACTORS
IS SO LOW. THAT THAT CONTRACTOR
COULD NEVER REALLY. GET A
PROFIT WITHOUT- CHEATING THE
WORKERS FROM THEIR MINIMUM
WAGE. SIR MANY WAYS IN WHICH
THIS UP THE SYSTEM HAS LED TO
THESE WORKERS NOT BEING ABLE TO
GET THE WAGES THAT THEY
DESERVE. SO WE HAVE TO COME IN
AND CLOSE THE LOOPHOLES SO THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ALL THESE WORKERS
CHEATED OUT OF THEIR WAGES. I
WAS ON SUBCOMMITTEE THE REASON
I GOT INVOLVED IN THIS AS I WAS
ON THE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE.
THAT PHAM OVERSAW THIS A
RESTITUTION FUND AND I WAS JUST
SHOCKED THAT THERE WAS WORKER
AFTER WORKER AFTER WORKER AT
THAT TIME WHO WOULD SHOW UP-
AND SAYING- I GOT MY COMPLAIN
MY CASE WAS ADJUDICATED. AND I
HAVEN'T STILL HAVEN'T BEEN PAID
FOR ONE TWO OR THREE YEARS. SO
IT'S NOT FOR LACK OF TRYING.
EITHER FROM THE WORKERS OR FROM
THE LABOR AGENCY IT'S JUST THAT
IT'S SO RAMPANT AND THEY NEED
TO HOLD. SOMEBODY HIGHER UP ON
THE CHAIN RESPONSIBLE OR ELSE
WE'RE JUST GOING TO BE CHASING
OUR TAILS AND NOT REALLY
SOLVING THE PROBLEM. SO WOULD
YOU TAKE THAT LOGIC IN GO ONE
FURTHER STEP UP AND SAY THAT
THE CONSUMERS AND THE STORES.
SHOULD BE PENALIZED WELL. HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AS A PENALIZED
ACCOUNTABLE NO BECAUSE NOPE I
DON'T THINK SO BECAUSE THEY'RE
THE ONES BUYING THE PRODUCT
THEY'RE NOT HAVING IN. ASKING
FOR THE PRODUCT TO BE MADE.
OKAY- MY CONCERN HERE IS THAT
WE'RE- THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO ENFORCE WHAT YOUR
INTENT IS IF WE CAN'T ENFORCE
THE MINIMUM WAGE. REQUIREMENT
IN CALIFORNIA WITH THESE PEOPLE
WITH THESE COMPANIES THESE-
WOULD YOU CALL IT UNETHICAL
EMPLOYERS- I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW YOU'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT IN THIS WITH
THIS BILL. WHAT WE AGAIN WE
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT EVEN IF
YOU'RE HIGHER UP IN THE CHAIN
THAT YOU ARE RESPONSIBLE- AND
SECOND IS WE HAVE TO SUPPORT
THE BUSINESSES THAT ARE. PAYING
THE WAGES THAT ARE PAYING THE
OF ARE FOLLOWING THE LAW AND
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AS WELL
BECAUSE IF WE KEEP LETTING
THESE OTHER BUSINESSES GET AWAY
WITH CHEATING. THAT MAKES IT
HARDER FOR THESE ETHICAL
BUSINESSES TO COME TO COMPETE
AND THAT'S EXCITING AND I YOU
KNOW I APPLAUD ALL OF THE
BUSINESSES THAT CALLED IN AND
SUPPORT THAT PART OF THIS
COALITION. AND IS SAYING WE
WANT TO DO THE RIGHT THING BUT
WE HAVE TO THE REASON THEY'RE
SUPPORTING SB SIXTY TWO IS
BECAUSE- THEY ALSO SEE. THE
LOOPHOLES THEY'RE NOT TRYING TO
USE LOOPHOLES THESE OTHER
COMPANIES ARE USING THE
LOOPHOLES AND TRYING TO EVADE
RESPONSIBILITY SO WE'RE DOING
THAT NOT ONLY FOR THE- MEN AND
WOMEN WHO WORK. WE'RE ALSO
DOING IT FOR THE BUSINESSES
THAT ARE DOING THE RIGHT THING
BEING RESPONSIBLE AND DON'T
WANT- YOU KNOW DON'T WANT TO BE
PUT IN THE SITUATION THEY'RE
NOT TRYING TO CHEAT THE WORKERS.
I'M JUST A LITTLE CONCERNED
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
PENALIZING PEOPLE WHO DO FOLLOW
THE LAW. FOR THE PEOPLE THAT DO
NOT THAT'S THE ONLY CONCERN
THAT I HAVE ON WITH THIS BILL.
BUT BELIEVE ME WE'RE NOT TRYING
TO PUNISH ANYBODY WHO FOLLOWS
THE LAW. THESE WORKERS ONLY
ONE. TO GET THEIR MONEY AT THE
END OF THE DAY BUT THE WORK SO
HARD FOR THE UPSTREAM MINES I
MEAN ON THAT AND IT'S JUST THAT
I JUST CAN'T BELIEVE I AM IN
ALL. HONESTY I MEAN ALL THAT IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT
CAN GET AWAY WITH THIS AND SHE
PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR MINIMUM
WAGE- AND THAT'S NOT TO SAY
THAT. HIS IT BY A- PER GARMENT-
THREE PIECE RATE IF YOU COULD
HAVE THAT I MEAN YOU COULD HAVE
THAT IF THEY WERE PAYING
MINIMUM WAGE RIGHT YES OKAY
YES- WE- SIMPLY SAY THAT IT
SHOULDBE A BONUS ON OP OF
WHATEVER THE MINIMUM WAGES.
THEY COULD PROVIDE BONUS WHICH
OF COURSE IS A- YOU KNOW THAT'S
A FINE THING TO DO THAT'S A
GOOD THING TO DO IN THE
WORKERS. WOULD WOULD LIKE THAT
BUT NOT NOT SOMETHING THAT
PENALIZES THEM. YEAH I'M JUST
I'M JUST CONCERNED HONESTLY
SENATE ROTH I'M JUST REALLY
CONCERNED THE FACT THAT. I'M
NOT SURE THAT THIS IS. TRULY
GOING TO. IMPACT PEOPLE WHO
ALREADY ARE GETTING AWAY WITH
IT- IN THIS SCENARIO- BUT I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING HOW WE
SUPPORTED AT THIS TIME- I'M
GONNA STEAM BUT I AM LOOK
FORWARD TO SEE HOW. YOU'RE ABLE
TO INCORPORATE THE ENFORCEMENT
OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE TRULY NOT%
FOLLOWING- OUR LAWS- RATING
CURRENTLY IN PLACE AND WHY WE
AS YOU KNOW AS THE LEGISLATURE
IN IN PEOPLE IN OUR ENTITIES OR
AGENCIES WHO ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE ARE NOT ABLE TO ENFORCE
WHAT'S ALREADY IN ON OR UNDER
LAWCENTER BOOKS. THANK YOU
RINPOCHE WHICH A CLOSE AND GROW.
I RESPECT ON BEHALF OF ALL
THOSE HARD WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS THANK YOU. WE CAN
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. ON THE
ITEMS THE MOVE- BY NEWMAN WILL
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY CENTER
COURTESY. FIVE FENDER CORTEZ
III SENATOR- CHOKE. SENATOR
CHAU POKE NOT VOTING THE
SENATOR ALSO HI. SENATOR DORADO
HI SENATOR LAYERED HI SENATOR
LAYERED I SENATOR NEWMAN.
SENATOR NEWMAN HI. HELLO THAT
MEASURE HAS FOUR VOTES. THE
BILL SELF THANK YOU THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES BUT LET ME ASK- FOR.
BUT IF THERE'S ANY OBJECTION TO
THE OTHER FEW CENTERS ACROSS
IRAN TO KID THAT WE WOULD TAKE
YOUR FOR BILLS- IN SEQUENCE AND
THEN COME BACK- TO MY
PRESENTATION- SO WE WERE OUT OF
ORDER FROM THE ORIGINAL AGENDA
WE WERE GOING WITH A WHAT WOULD
BE ITEM FOUR FIVE SIX AND
SEVEN. AND THEN BACK TO THREE-
FROM THE REQUEST THAT WE- AND-
SHOP AT SO TO SPEAK TAKE ITEM
TEN SENATE BILL FOR TWENTY
SENATOR BIRDS BILL AT THIS TIME
AND THEN WE COME BACK TO
SENATOR ALSO- IN THE FALL THE
SEQUENCE OUR ALONG. SENATE-ROOM.
WE ARE PRISON BREAK YOU SAID IN
THERE ALSO COMING- I ALSO WILL
TO THANK THE CHAIR IN HIS STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS
BILL PARTICULARLY GLENN MILES.
FOR THEIR HARD WORK- IT BEFORE
U. S. BEFORE TWENTY THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
INTEGRITY ENFORCEMENT ACT IT IS
ALL OF YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD SOME.
CHALLENGES WITH EDT AND SOME
HUGE CHALLENGES WITH RESPECT TO
FRAUD COMMITTED ON THE
TAXPAYERS THE ESTIMATES ARE
BETWEEN TEN AND THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS. IN FRAUD. WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS THIS BILL LOOKS TO
SEE HOW WE CAN BOTH RECOVER
WHATEVER WE CAN RECOVER AND
ALSO A PROSECUTE THOSE WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR SOME OF THIS
AGREE JUST CONDUCT. OF IT IS A
WIDE SPREAD OF NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS LARGE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS AND COMPLEX IN
TERMS OF CERTAIN CONSPIRACIES
AND IN THE US WE NEED SOMEONE
TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
ORGANIZING THIS EFFORTS
STATEWIDE AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL PROPOSES THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAVE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL APPOINTED
TASK FORCE AND THAT THAT TASK
FORCE AND TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR OF THE RECOVERY IN
PARTICULAR BUT PROSECUTION AND
THE COLLECTION OF RESOURCES TO
BE ABLE TO FUND THAT IT'S VERY
SIMPLE BILL- I EXPECTED THE
THEY'LL BE SOME OTHER INPUT
ALONG THE WAY BUT I WOULD URGE
AN AYE VOTE. OKAY THANK YOU A-
SENATOR BYRD. WE WILL KNOW-
MOVED. TO BUT WE HAVE NO WITH
SUPPORT WORLD WITNESSES IT
CORRECT I'M SORRY IT WAS FOR
THIS WE HAVE NO WITNESSES THE
WITNESSES THANK YOU UP ON THE
WITNESS THAT'S FINE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HELLO I WOULD
ACTUALLY SAY WELCOME- AT THIS
TERM IF THAT'S NOT. OF WE WILL
THEN CALL- FOR ANY IN THE ROOM
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
WILL CALL ANYONE IN TWENTY
FORTY ROUTE TWENTY FORTY WISHES
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. C. NINE
WILL MOVE TO. THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE AGAIN WE
HAVE A MAXIMUM LIMIT ON TIME
TODAY OF FIFTEEN MINUTES
SUPPORT FIFTEEN MINUTES
OPPOSITION BY TELECONFERENCE.
UP. TO WE WILL TAKE THE WEEKEND
OFF CAN OFTEN TIME WORK TO YOUR
ADVANTAGE TO BE MUCH MORE
CONCISE THAN THAT AS A GROUP ON
THAT SAID EARNED LUMIA SMARTER
IF WE HAVE ANY SUPPORT WHEN
THIS IS UP IN THE QUEUE AND IF
SO HOW MANY. THANK YOU MISTER.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AT THIS
TIME IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR TWENTY YEAR
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO WE DO
HAVE ONE. COMMENT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME NINE FORTY NINE. YOUR
LINE IS GOING TO BE OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DELIMITER
MEMBERS IS WRANGLING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR ST
ONE. BUT BUT WE- WANT TO READ
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE
LINE NUMBER FOR THE NEXT PARTY.
THANK YOU. PINE TO EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ROBERT WITH
CHAMBER OF INTO THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU THE MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS-
LET'S JUST GO THROUGH THE SAME
PROCESS QUICKLY- IN TERMS OF
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS OR ANYONE
HERE THE COMMITTEE ROOMS WHICH
IS TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO
SENATE BILL FOR TWENTY C. NINE-
WE WERE MOVED TO. THE OVERFLOW
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. ANY
OPPOSITION SPEAKERS THERE ARE
WITNESSES SEEN NONE OF WE WILL
COME BACK TO THE MODERATOR THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE- PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. HIM PLEASE LET US
KNOW HOW MANY THERE ARE. THANK
YOU MISTER TURNER AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
TWENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. SYSTEM
IT'S NOT. AND WE DO HAVE MINE
SEVENTY FOR AND PLEASED WHETHER
YOU ARE SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
ONE MOMENT PLEASE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS MICHAEL MILLER
THE COMPANY'S DECISION GRAPE
GROWERS WE ARE ACTUALLY IN
SUPPORT I APOLOGIZE FOR MY
DELAY I THINK THE OPPOSITE.
OPPOSITION WHEN WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO COME IN Q. FOUR
OPPOSITION OF SB TWENTY. SPOKE
WELL THANK YOU TOLD THEM THOSE
WHO DID SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
OPPOSITION AND WE'RE NOW GOING
TO. BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK.
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO-
HERE SOMEONE EARLIER THE BILL.
OKAY IT AND DONE BEFORE WE ASK
YOU A- SEN ROBERT TO CLOSE I
JUST I HAVE A QUICK QUESTION I
AM IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
CENTER BERGEN I. APPLAUD YOU
FOR. BRINGING FORWARD- SOME
KIND OF SOLUTION TO THE-
PUTTING THE RESTITUTION THAT SO
MANY OF US HAVE GIVEN. UP
LOOKING FOR HOPING FOR AND
TRYING TO FIND A PATHWAY FOR
HERE- THIS IS REALLY JUST-
ASKING MAYBE FOR A LITTLE
FORESHADOWING IN TERMS OF- IN
TERMS OF THE MECHANICS THAT YOU
SPOKE ABOUT IN YOUR OPENING.
THEN IT MAY BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE INFORMATION ON THAT-
ESPECIALLY AS A MEMBER OF
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE FIVE AYE I
HAVE. THIS CURIOSITY AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE- SOME KIND OF A REQUEST
FOR. A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
AUGMENTATION. IN ORDER TO GET
TO THIS POINT WHERE- OF THIS
UNFORTUNATE MASS OF. WHAT
APPEARS TO BE A MASSIVE AMOUNT
OF FRAUD BASED ON THE AUDITOR'S
REPORT CAN ACTUALLY BE TACKLED
WITH ANY KIND OF. CAPACITY OR
SCALE AND THEN I UNDERSTAND
WITH YOUR- WITH YOUR BILL. BY
THE CONCEPT IN THE BILL EVENTS
THAT WOULD BE. COST RECOVERY-
BUT DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT
THOSE METRICS LOOK LIKE IN
TERMS OF WHAT IT'S REALLY GOING
TO TAKE A- I KNOW YOU HAVE A
BACKGROUND- YOUR SOFA IN THE
LAW AND I JUST. CURIOUS AS TO.
WHAT YOU ANTICIPATE WE MIGHT BE
LOOKING AT SOME POINT IN TERMS
OF SCALE. SO- FIRST ANY
ORGANIZED EFFORT AND THIS IS A
COMPLEX EFFORT TO ORGANIZE
NEEDS ONE PERSON OR ENTITY IN
CHARGE AND THAT'S THE FIRST
PRINCIPLE THE SECOND PRINCIPLES
IS FOR THEM TO ASSESS WHAT IS
IT WE'RE GOING TO NEED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS A VERY
LARGE ROLE TO PLAY- AND SO I
WOULD EXPECT THAT THIS TASK
FORCE WITH THE AG IN CHARGE
WOULD FIRST DO AN ASSESSMENT
WHAT DO WE THINK WE CAN
REASONABLY RECOVER I'VE HEARD
DIFFERENT ESTIMATES OF ONE
ESTIMATE IS BASED THINK WE CAN
RECOVER 10% OF THE FRAUD WELL.
IF IT'S TEN BILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
THAT'S ACTUAL MONEY- AND WHAT
RESOURCES ARE GOING TO BE
REQUIRED IN AN OLD NEED TO BE A
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS SO IF FOR
EXAMPLE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
SPEND TICKET NUMBER TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
PROSECUTORIAL INVESTIGATIVE
RESOURCES IN ORDER TO RECOVER
BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S A PRETTY
GOOD INVESTMENT- BUT WE DON'T
KNOW RIGHT NOW IN THAT AND
THAT'S REALLY THE PURPOSE OF
THE BILL SO WE CAN GET
OURSELVES ORGANIZED AND DO THE
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS. AND THEN
HOUSING CONTEMPLATED THAT THE
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS WOULD
COME BACK WITH A B. BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE OR- WHO IS A TASK
FORCE IN REPORT. SO CLEARLY IF
ANY ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE
REQUIRED. THEY WOULD HAVE TO
THE AG OR- WHATEVER ENTITY IS
CREATED WOULD HAVE TO COME BACK
TO THE TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
ASK THE THAT THAT BE FUNDED SO-
THAT WE WILL BE RELATIVELY
SHORT LEASH ON US. BUT WE NEED
IN MY VIEW WE NEED WE NEED TO
GET STARTED. FIGURING ALL THIS
OUT OF THE MONEY THAT WAS
STOLEN- IS BEING QUICKLY
DISSIPATED AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT THAT- WE TAKE TOO MUCH
TIME- WE'RE WE'RE LOSING MONEY.
AS WE SORT OF FIGURE THIS THING
OUT SO THAT THAT'S WHY I'M
ANXIOUS TO GET THIS BALL
ROLLING. VERY GOOD. POINT WELL
TAKEN THANK YOU FOR ADDRESSING
THOSE ISSUES AND- I WILL IN
FACT BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
BUT- IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE
NINETY MINUTE. I'M SORRY CENTER
NEWMAN. I'M SORRY MR IT REALLY
ONE QUICK- IF YOU YES YOU MAY
OF THE CENTER BUMMER IN THE I A
RIGHTEOUS YEAH AND OVER BUT TO
DO THAT SUCH AS AMOUNT HAS BEEN
RECOVERED FAR- AND ALSO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THAT MOST OF THE
FUNDS AS I UNDERSTAND IT THAT
HAVE BEEN FRAUDULENTLY.
DIVERTED HAVE WHERE ARE
GUARANTEED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MADE A CHOICE ARE WE
MAKING A DISTINCTION HERE
BETWEEN THOSE FUNDS THOSE TWO
INCREMENTS IN THAT THE VERY
LARGE NUMBER THAT'S GUARANTEED.
BY THE CURES ACT VERSUS THE
SMALLER UNDERSTOOD ALL FUNDS-
THAT IF CHAU AREN'T WE- LIBEL
TO RETURN THOSE FUNDS TO THE
FEDERAL. TO IS WORKING HOW DO
WE COUNT THAT- THE DANCE TO THE
IS. MOST THE FUNDS ARE FEDERAL
FUN THAT IS CORRECT THE STATE
HAS SOME. INVESTMENT IN THIS AS
WELL- IN SO WE DO NEED AS IS
PART OF THE- TASK BEFORE US IS
TO WORK OUT WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT EXACTLY HOW WE'RE
GOING TO PORTION. BOTH THE
EXPENSES AS WELL AS THE
RECOVERY IT WOULD BE MY VIEW
THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT
CALIFORNIA BEST RESOURCES AND
RECOVERS MONEY. IT WEEK WE
SHOULD. BE ABLE TO- ACCEPTED
SPEND WHATEVER REAR COVER NOW I
EXPECT THAT THERE MAY BE OTHER
POINTS OF VIEW ON THIS ON THIS.
BUT AGAIN- IN IN TO YOUR POINT
TO IN TERMS OF RECOVERY- THAT.
IF WE CAN RECOVER 10% THAT
WOULD BE GREAT. YES IT'S
GETTING HARDER AND HARDER AND
WE'VE NOT RECOVERED MUCH WE
DON'T HAVE A COORDINATED EFFORT
AT THIS POINT IN TIME. AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT THERE WERE. YOU
KNOW LARGE SCALE CONSPIRACIES
THAT WERE ENGAGED IN STEALING
THIS MONEY I EXPECT IS PROBABLY
OVERSEAS WOULD PROBABLY HAVE TO
TRACE IT TO. PLACES THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD. I APPRECIATE THAT TO
WHAT RISK TO. THE COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS. IS YOU DO YOU
ANTICIPATE ONE COST BENEFIT
ELSE JUST WORKING AND TO THE
ANALYSIS OR WOULD THERE BE. TUE
QUESTION ONES BASED ON WHAT
YOU'VE LEARNED WERE WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED IS WE'VE GONE I EXPECT
PUTTING THE AG AND CHARGED WITH
THIS TASK FORCE IN THE G. TO
REPORT BACK TO US TO SAY
HERE'S- HERE'S WHAT I THINK
IT'S GOING TO COST TO RECOVER.
X. AMOUNT OF MONEY IF THE AG
RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE ANY
TYPE OF THE AG COMES BACK AND
SAYS LOOK AT ALL THAT MONEY'S.
YOU KNOW OF OVERSEAS AND WE
CAN'T GET ANY OF IT AND SO
THERE'S NO USE IN EVEN TRYING
WELL THEN I SUPPOSE WE HAVE TO
ACCEPT THAT I HOPE THAT'S NOT
THE RESULT. OF BUT THAT'S WHAT
I WOULD EXPECT IS THAT HE OR
SHE WOULD REPORT BACK TO US AND
THEN TO THE EXTENT THAT IT'S OF
USE OF THEIR RESOURCES
NECESSARY. THAT HE OR SHE S.
FOR THOSE RESOURCES. THE SHIP
IT'S LIKE I SAID THEY WERE.
EFFORT ND I'D BE GRATEFUL AS
YOU MOVE THIS FORWARD BE
EDITORS AS A CO AUTHOR. THANK
YOU OF THE SCENE. NO REQUEST TO
BE RECOGNIZE ON THE DAIS HERE
SOONER NUMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE UP THANK VERY MUCH-
GINGIVAL. THE YOU FOR WITH
ENERGY A MOTION ON THE ITEM. WE
ARE ONE FROM CENTER EARLIER. I
WILL CALL THE ROLL CALL AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON RULES CENTER
CORTESE ALL RIGHT SENATOR
CORTEZ THE AYE SENATOR OR CHILL
A BOOK BY. SENATOR OCHO BOOK I
CENTER THE TORONTO. SENATOR HI
SENATOR LAYERED HI SENATOR
LATER I HE SAID NEWMAN ALL
RIGHT. SENATOR HIGH THANK YOU
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
SENATOR ALSO THANK YOU THAT
MEASURE HAS FIVE BOOKS. THE
BILLS OUT THANK YOU FOR. DRAW
WILL BACK TO YOU- HI YOU YOU
MAY PRESENT ON YOUR BILL SB.
THREE TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- THIS IS ABOUT CAL
OSHA PROTECTIONS FOR DOMESTIC
WORKERS OUT THERE ABOUT TWO
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS CURRENTLY
THAT WE BELIEVE DEPEND ON. THE
LABOR OF DOMESTIC WORKERS TO
CARE FOR THEIR HOMES AND
FAMILIES. THERE PRIMARILY
IMMIGRANT WOMEN- THEY'RE
ESSENTIAL TO OUR ECONOMY AND I
BELIEVE WE SHOULD GIVE THEM S.
SAME CONSIDERATION FOR HEALTH
AND SAFETY ISSUES. WE SHOULD
NOT EXCLUDE WORKERS FROM DURING
THIS HEALTH PANDEMIC NOR DURING
THE WILDFIRES THAT BURNED
THROUGH OUR STATE. AW OR JUST
THE EVERYDAY WORK THAT THEY DO-
TO PROTECT THE FAMILIES IN
THOSE HOUSEHOLDS. DURING THE
WILDFIRES THAT DEVASTATED
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLD DOMESTIC
WORKERS EMPLOYEES. WERE ASKED
TO STAY BEHIND TO FIGHT FIRES
GUARD HOMES AND PETS WORK IN
SMOKY CONDITIONS AND EVEN CLEAN
UP TOXIC ASH SOME IMPLORED
EMPLOYERS EVEN FAILED TO TELL
MANY OF THEM. THAT THE HOMES
THEY WERE WORKING THAT WERE
ORDERS. THE CURRENT CORPORATE
NINETEEN HEALTH PANDEMIC HAS
ONLY MAGNIFIED THE DANGERS- AND
THE LACK OF SAFETY THAT
DOMESTIC WORKERS AND DAY
LABORERS FACE ON A DAILY BASIS.
AS OUR WORLD AS OUR WILDFIRES
GROW IN FREQUENCY AND
INTENSITY- AND THE PANDEMIC
RAVAGES OUR LOW INCOME INCOME
COMMUNITIES IT'S TIME FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO MOVE PAST THE
LEGACY OF EXCLUSION. THAT WOMEN
OF COLOR HAVE INJURED. MY TWO
WITNESSES THE SUPPORT TODAY ARE
DAISY LOPEZ MEMBER OF THE
GRAYTON DAY. LABOR CENTER AND
MEGAN ORTIZ EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF IN DEPTH SCCA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU I WILL
GO AHEAD AND CALL UPON. FOR THE
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS COKER'S.
I'M I MEAN I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT- I DON'T FIRST OF THE
MAKING OF PIECE OF SALUTE YOU
MAY PROCEED THANK YOU TH THANK
YOU SO MUCH- MY NAME IS MEGAN
OF THE THUMB EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE INSTITUTE OF POPULAR
EDUCATION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA YOU THAT'S GONE AND
WE'RE THE LARGEST WORKERS
CENTER NONPROFIT IN THE STATE
WITH FIVE LOCATIONS SERVING
WHERE THAT ADVOCATING FOR
THOUSANDS OF DAILY BROKEN
PLASTIC WORKER WE ALSO PUT ON
THE STEERING COMMITTEE OF THE
CALIFORNIA BEST. WORKERS
COALITION. WORKERS ARE MAKING
IN THE AND WOMEN OF COLOR. I
KNOW HISTORICALLY EXT. FROM THE
MOST BASIC LABOR PROTECTIONS
EVEN WHEN USERS ARE ROOTED IN
THE LEGACY OF SLAVERY AND THE
DISENFRANCHISEMENT OF BLACK
WORKERS FROM RIGHT IN THIS
COUNTRY. IN THE LAST DECADE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE SOUGHT TO
CORRECT THESE INJUSTICES AND
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF THE OF
DOMESTIC WORK. ALONG WITH OTHER
STATES CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE
EXPANSION OF WORKPLACE
PROTECTIONS TO DEFEAT THE
FUNCTIONAL WORKFORCE AND TODAY.
WE ARE ONE OF THE LAST VESTIGES
OF SYSTEMATIC RACISM BY
REMOVING THE HOUSEHOLD DOMESTIC
SERVICE EXCLUSION FROM
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH AND SAFETY
LAW. MORE THAN EVER I THINK
WE'RE MUST BE PART. ALL OTHER
EMPLOYEES. DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND WITH ANOTHER WILDFIRE
SEASON ALWAYS APPROACHING THEY
CONTINUED TO CARE FOR OUR HOMES
AND LOVED ONES AT THE FRONT
WORK. AT HOME. MANNING AND HOW
QUICKLY. WE THAT IT IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES COLOR THAT HAVE
BEEN DEFERRED. DOESN'T BY THE
TIME. AND YET. THE GOVERNOR'S
VETO LAST YEAR THE WORKERS
REMAIN THE ONLY EMPLOYEES
EXCLUDED FROM THE RIGHT. AND
HOW WORK RIGHT. EMPLOYERS OF
HOW WORK ALREADY CLASS ADS IN.
I HAVE TO COMPLY THE AND LOCAL
AND HOUR LAWS AND OTHER
PROTECTION. THE BILL THEREFORE
IS THE PROTECTION ABOUT IMPROVE.
LOOK HOW OSHA EMPLOY WILL BE
GUIDANCE ON CREATING SAFE
WORKPLACE WITHIN THE HOME I
THEN I THINK WORKERS WILL HAVE
AN- ABOUT AFTER THAN THE. I
KNOW RIGHT PROTECT THEMSELVES
WITH ME TELL. I AM VERY LOCAL
THIS YEAR HER. IN THE FOR LINE
AND GOING TO BE IN CHARGE BY
I'M NOT. IN MY LITTLE OF THE-
THEM WORK CALLED. RELATED THE-
THREE MEMBER OF ADAM. IN OF ONE
ON THE DON'T REGULAR THEY'RE
SAYING IS THAT A HOME LOCAL AT
ABOUT HOW OF THEM YOU CAN. MY
NAME IS DAVID UPPER I DON'T
KNOW LEADER OF THE I'M NOT
GOING TO GREAT GUNS LABOR DAY.
S. OR THE INTERPRETER WE CANNOT
HEAR YOU AT THIS TIME. YEAH
AGUIAR-CURRY I CANNOT HEAR THE
SPEAKER EITHER. ONE ME WAIT
ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS JUST TO
SEE IF. IT'S A. A TECHNICAL
PROBLEM THAT WILL CLEAR UP IN
IF NOT WE'LL MOVE TO- OTHERS
SPEAKERS. LRAD ABOUT COLONIA.
PAKISTAN MENTAL HABITS THAT
THAT WASN'T LET ME IN ON THE
APPOINTMENT WHEN IT YEAH FOUR A.
THANK YOU MONICA WHERE MAX.
OKAY I AM I CAN GIVE US. TEN
SECOND UNTIL WE SETTLED THE-
NOT LOGICAL IS I KNOW CANNOT BE
AVAILABLE FROM. YES OR BY HERE
TO CLARIFY. WITH THE SPEAKER
WILL OR NOT THERE BUILD. BUT IT
WILL BE ABLE PRINT IT INTO ANY
VERY BRIEFLY- THEY'RE HAVING.
ISSUES I'M I'M GONNA- M. S. THE-
ED IS OF TAKING UP THE PRO OF
THE WERE GOING TO MOVE ON BUT
WE WILL ALLOW TO PASS WE WILL
COME BACK YOU BUT BEFORE WE
SUPPORTS. ONE MORE ATTEMPT TO
YOU TO FILL THIRD A MAX OF TIME
FIVE MINUTES- FOR A FOR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION SPEAKER- BUT ONLY
THE- LAND MASS. WITH ALL THAT
IN ON ON THAT BUT I. OKAY LET
HOME THAT HAPPEN ON A. YES I WE
CAN BE ON THE BALLOT. FROM YES
MY PLEASURE MA'AM EIGHT- WEEK
COME TO C. A. R. HUGE THEY GET
IN THE COLD FOR REPORT THAT A
FEMALE GOING OPEN TO SHOT THAT
THE EMBARGO BUT I WAS ARE
LEARNING LONGER. THERE ARE
GOING TO BE OUT. YES WELL I
DON'T REMEMBER. EIGHT EIGHT.
THANK HELLO THIS IS THANK THAT
IS THE POINT WHERE NOTHING.
OKAY GREAT BUT I'M NOT BUT I'M
NOT MORE IN A OUT OF GOING ON
DOWNLOADING ON. THE
TECHNOLOGICAL LET ME TO ON
POINT OF. FOR NOW TO ANY OF
WITNESSES AND IN THE CAN ROOM.
AT C. NINE WILL MOVE TO ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN YOUR
FULL ROOM- TWENTY FORTY SEEN
NONE WILL GO TO THE MODERATOR
OF TELECOM BUT SERVICE IN ASK A
TO QUEUE UP. ANY SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE TWENTY ONE
INCLUDES LOT OF SNOW THE NUMBER
SPEAKERS. THANK YOU MISS CHAIR
WE DO FORTY TWO. COMMENTS IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THE LET ME
JUST- IS. LET ME ADMONISH THAT
WE HAVE A FIFTY MINUTE MATCH.
TOTAL COME FIRST. THAT'S UP TO
SO. YOU'RE ENTIRE TO SAY YOU'RE
NAY. YOUR AFFILIATION. AND SUB.
OR OPPOSITION THE BILL AND I
WOULD LIKE TO THROUGH THE- IN
MUCH LESS INFILL MINUTES
APOSTLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MAY. R. FOR COMIC COMES A LINE.
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHT YOUR IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AND
LIMITED I AM THE PRO QUITE FOR
MORE THAN A I DOUBLE IN I
STRONGLY. S. B. THREE TWO ONE.
MY FIFTY YOUR IS OPEN PLEASE
AHEAD. YES MY NAME GINNY BROWN
I'M A NANNY A- IN OAKLEY
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE TODAY
TO ASK THAT YOU PLEASE SUPPORT
SB THREE TWO ONE AND REASON
SEXISM. OF DOMESTIC FROM OSHA.
THANK YOU. MY ONE. YOUR IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME NUR STYLE MAY
I KNOW OR ABSOLUTE THE FOR CHEN
IN OAKLAND AND I SB. THREE TWO
ONE. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE IS OPEN YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WILL
MOVE ON TO ONE NINETY FOUR.
NINE NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
MICHELLE GILLEN BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS ALSO ON THE LIST AND
I AM A PROGRAM MANAGER AT THE
GREAT DAY LABOR CENTER AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE TWO
ONE. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
MANY AGAIN I LIVE IN DALY CITY
CALIFORNIA A MEMBER OF HAND IN
HAND THE DOMESTIC EMPLOYER
NETWORK I FULLY SUPPORT SB.
THREE TO ONE BECAUSE I AM AN
EMPLOYER OF A HOUSE CLEANER AND
MY HOME IS THE WORK PLACE.
THANK YOU. MINE. ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE MOMENT PLEASE FIND ONE
THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MAN A YEAH
I'M FOR MANY OF THEM I. NUMBER
NINE THE NUMBER HIS. I'M FROM
GLAD OF SB. THREE ONE. NINE ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS THAT THE
SECOND SHIA IBV HERE IN OAKLAND
ALARM WORKERS- PARTICIPANT IN
OUT OF JAIL MEMBERS OF- OKAY
FOR ME THAT'S EVEN. ARE NON
QUARTER SB. TWO NINE ONE
HUNDRED IN THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
ONE THIRTY THREE YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE PLEASE GO THAT LOW AND NOT
GOING. WILLIAMS. HELLO. MY NAME.
NUMBER. WHY ARE YOU. THEN WORK
BUT IT ALSO OR LONG OF A
HOLIDAY LET YOU. KNOW WHAT I.
FOR ONE TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
YEAH. NUMBER SEVEN IN MADE
THEIR FINAL GOODNESS WHAT WE
DID SIGNED UP THE BALLOT OF THE
LEVEL MEXICO WELL FOR LIFE BUT
IN BOTH MOST AFFECTED BY THEM
UP ON THING WITH THAT YOU HAVE.
NINE ONE. AND EIGHTY EIGHT.
YOUR LINE IS A- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALL FIVE NAME IS PROTECT AND
I'M IN LAS THE GRANDMA CLEANER
EMPLOY AND A MAN OF THE END OF
END OF THE INCLUDE NETWORK. I'M
HERE TO STRONGLY BY SUPPORT FOR
A THREE ONE MY HOME THE WORK
PLACE THANK YOU. MY ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY. YOUR LINE IS A- PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHEN ABOUT. THREE
WHEN ASSEMBLY. NUMBER NEARLY
EVERYONE. YEAH BOY ALLEGEDLY IS
A VERY INTERESTING DO NOT. NINE
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE. NINE
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M NOT GOING MORE THAN NINE
REMEMBER HAND IN HAND SANTA
BARBARA I- HOUSE. CLEANER AND
I'M STRONG SUPPORTER BECAUSE MY
HOME IN THE WORKPLACE THANK YOU.
NINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO
LINE ONE I'M SORRY WILL MOVE O
TO MINE. NINETY NINE NINE
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NINETY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND WE'LL MOVE ON. TO
NINE ONE THIRTY TWO. NINE ONE
THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL OF A
SUDDEN NUMBER A LITTLE MAN BUT
IT'S NOT THAT MANY NOBODY FOR
MAC OTHER THAN A LITTLE THAT
YOU HAVE FOR YOUR LIFE THEY MAY
PUT AS WE DO NOT. NINE ONE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS DAN AND I'M MORE THAN I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT REPRESENTING
WHAT SHE LED THE MASTIC WORKERS
SUPPORTING SB THREE TO ONE
PLEASE VOTE YES. NINE ONE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
THE ENEMY AND ALSO WITH THE
THAT IT'S TIME TO DO AWAY WITH
THIS EXCEPTION I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB. THREE TWO ONE. NINE
ONE EIGHTEEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE AND ONE
EIGHTEEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THEN WE'LL
MOVE ON TO MINE TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX ONE TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX. TO
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND MOVING ON
TO LINE TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN ONE TO THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ERIN O'NEILL MULLIN
BURKE ON BEHALF OF OUR EQUITY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
TWENTY ONE. NINE TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWO
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DOMINIQUE THIS DATA- FROM
THAILAND. I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER ALL OF YOU SPEED READ
ONE I'M ON MY HOUSE CLEAN AND
REPRESENTS AND- ORGANIZER MORE.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE FORTY. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS GONNA
BE SO LOL I'M IN BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND I AM QUITE A
NANNY AND A HOUSE CLEANER- I'M
A MEMBER OF HAND IN HAND THE
DOMESTIC EMPLOYER NETWORK AND
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT. SB THIRTY
ONE BECAUSE MY HOME AT THE WORK
PLACE THANK YOU. NINE TO FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TO FORTY ONE YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OH SORRY THE
NUMBER OF MONEY ARE YOU GOING
TRAILER SO YOU'RE GOING TO THE
LOCAL. ON A PENALTY HELLO TO
AND ALL THAT. YOU HAVE FOR YOUR
AESIR THERE IS ALSO. NONSENSE.
THANK YOU. OKAY. ONE TWO
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. NINE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THE LEVEL
CONTENDER AUDIBLE CALIFORNIA I
CAN BY THE NUMBER OF WONDERFUL
SPANISH SPEAKING WOMEN HAVE
PROFITED OVER THE YEARS. I FEEL
LIKE THEY DESERVE BETTER
PROTECTION THAN ANY OTHER ONE
IS NOW GONE. THANK YOU. NINE
ONE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
JILL THOMPSON REPRESENTING
PUBLIC COUNCIL IN LOS ANGELES
IN STRONG SUPPORT AT THIS BILL
SB THREE TWENTY ONE THANK YOU.
MY NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JESSICA CENTER ON
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN OUR YOUR
SUPPORT. ONE TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AMOL
BIGELOW AND- MANTAN. A NINETY
IN NINETY FOUR DAY THREE BEAR.
SB THREE SB THREE ONE THING YOU.
NINE ONE AND FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
KATIE WATER SMITH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB. THREE TWO ONE.
NINE THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THIRTY FOUR YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
DENNIS ONYANGO THE ADDED ON
BEHALF OF LEGAL AID AT WORK IN
SUPPORT OF SB. THREE TWO ONE.
NINE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
MEMBERS CAN WHINE ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
ACROSS PROUD COLD. OF SB THREE
TWO ONE WE ARE INTERESTED THANK
YOU. MY MENTOR. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONCE
AGAIN NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT WILL
MOVE ON TO LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE. MINE TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MONICA DINNER CAN BE HALF
THE JARRING CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE SIXTY
TWO YOU MAY BE AMAZED PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
REMEMBER IF NOT I'M NOT THAT
ARE GOING TO BE IN THE GRAPH
OKAY WHEN. I'M SORRY. YOU ARE A
FOR YOUR LIFE IT'S MADE IT IS
BOTH FORMAL ABOUT THE. NINE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN. YOUR LINE
IS A- PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS YOU KNOW
CALL I LIVE IN LOS AND I'M A
POLICY COURTNEY BUT THE-
IMMIGRANT SO. A PROUD BOND AT
THREE ONE WE STRONGLY I'VE
THREE TWO ONE BECAUSE I STATE
ADDRESSED THANK YOU TO EIGHTY
AT DIFFERENT HURT WORKING WOMEN
OF COLOR AND IMMIGRANT WORKERS
AND I STATE. THANK YOU. MINE
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS MADISON
BILLIONAIRES I'M A HOUSEKEEPER
I LIVE IN HUNTINGTON PARK I AM
A MEMBER OF THE THEN I SUPPORT
THAT SB THE ONES THANK YOU. MY
IN ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY AND ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS MEGAN WE HONOR THE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION IN FRONT THE PORT AND
IT BE THREE TWO ONE THANK YOU.
NINE ONE EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS VANESSA THE HIGHER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
DOMESTIC WORKERS COALITION AND
I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB.
THREE TWO ONE. MISTER TERRY WE
HAVE REACHED OUR FIFTEEN
MINUTES WOULD YOU LIKE US TO GO
FURTHER OR- I KNOW WE HAVE TO
BE CONSISTENT- THROUGHOUT THE
HEARING- MODERATOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THAT WILL
CONCLUDE- SPEAKERS BY
TELECONFERENCE IN SUPPORT-
THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
LEAD OPPOSITION. IN RESERVE
FOR. WITH REGARD FOR LEAD
OPPOSITION SPEAKER AT THIS TIME.
ZERO POSITION ON THIS BILL. C.
NINE I WILL MOVE TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM ASSEMBLY WHEN
HERE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO THE OVERFLOW
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. I SEE NO ONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION-
WE WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE OPERATOR AND-
ASK YOU TO QUEUE UP SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. LET US KNOW HOW
MANY. AND JUST AS WE HAVE BEEN
DOING THROUGHOUT THE HEARING
THE LIMIT IS FIFTEEN MINUTES
TOTAL. THANK YOU MR AND IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE TWENTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IT LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE
TWO COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. ONE MOMENT WE ARE WAITING
FOR THE LINE NUMBERS. YOUR
OPPOSITION. YOUR OVER ONE
FORTY. THREE NORTH WE SHOULD
OPPOSITION. BUT YOU. OFFERS. SO
IS THE MODERATOR NATIONAL IS ON
THE RISE IT WAS VERY VERY LOW
VOLUME I DON'T WANT ANYONE TO
COMPLAIN LATER THAT THEY WERE
NOT HEARD EMAIL US AT SPEAKER
TO REPEAT. I DON'T KNOW WHY I
DID WAS A MAY I GO AHEAD AND
OPEN THE OPPOSITION MIND YES
PLEASE. THANK YOU. OF MINE TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YEAH OKAY. YES MY NAME IS THAT
THE IDEA I NEED TO BE LOGGED IN
YOU I WANT CA NINETY AND YET IT
IS NOT. AND I THOUGHT. HE THREE
TIMES THE. ONE THANK YOU. THIS
IS TIME FOR OPPOSITE SPEAK SOME
ARE ANYONE Q. UP TO SPEAKING
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. WE HAVE
NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU WELCOME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SO CENTER NEWMAN. THANK RICHARD
JUST A COMMENT SENATOR RISE
OVER. THERE ARE MOMENTS WHERE
YOU REALIZE THAT WHAT WE DO
HERE. HAS AN IMPACT ON REAL
PEOPLE AND CAN CHANGE PEOPLE'S
LIVES FOR THE BETTER AND RIGHT.
CERTAIN INJUSTICES AND THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE TIMES SO I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU FOR THIS BILL- I
WANT TO COMMEND EVERYBODY WHO
CALLED IN- ADELANTE- AND THANK
YOU IN A DIFF IF POSSIBLE I'D
LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
SYSTEMS FOR. THANK YOU. THANK
AND THANK- IF THERE'S NO. OTHER
COMMENT TO THEM OR QUESTIONS BY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SAID
ROSIE CAN CLOSE. AS FOR YEAH
THANK YOU- THANK YOU WAS THERE
MOTION ON THE BILL SOME OF MOVE
BY NEWMAN. A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY SENATOR
CORTEZ HIGH. COURT HAS THE I.
X. CENTER A CHOKE NO. CENTRO
CHAU BOKE NO SENATOR ALSO HI.
SENATOR REID SO I CENTER
LAYERED ON CINDER LAYERED I
CENTER NEWMAN HI CENTER NEWMAN
HIGH- THAT. VOTE IS FOUR TO
ONE. THE BILL OUT. THANK YOU
SEE TO ROSSELL WORD. ON OUR
AGENDA WOULD BE BEST SIX THIRTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESENT ON THE
BILL THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS BILL ENSURES THAT
WORKERS WITH DISABILITIES
CANNOT BE PAID LESS THAN
MINIMUM WAGE SINCE THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES THE STATE HAS BEEN
ABLE TO PAY WORKERS WITH
DISABILITIES LESS THAN MINIMUM
WAGE THROUGH THE ISSUANCE OF
WHAT'S CALLED FOURTEEN C.
CERTIFICATES. UNDER THE FAIR
LABOR STANDARDS ACT THIS
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED UNDER
THE ROOSEVELT ADMINISTRATION.
WORLD WAR TWO VETERANS WHO
DEVELOPED PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
DISABILITIES FROM COMBAT. CAME
HOME FROM ABROAD AND STRUGGLE
TO FIND EMPLOYMENT IN AMERICA'S
MANUFACTURING ECONOMY SINCE
WORKERS WITH DISABILITIES WERE
PERCEIVED TO BE LESS EFFICIENT.
IN MANUFACTURING JOBS AND THEIR
PEERS THESE FOURTEEN C.
CERTIFICATES ALLOWED EMPLOYERS
TO PAY WORKERS WITH
DISABILITIES LESS THAN ALL
OTHER WORKERS. OVER TIME
FOURTEEN SEED CERTIFICATES
OFFERED EMPLOYERS A POOL OF
CHEAP LABOUR FOR MENIAL
REDUNDANT TASKS OFTEN BY
WORKERS WITH INTELLECTUAL OR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IN
SEGREGATED SETTINGS ALSO KNOWN
AS SHELTERED WORKSHOPS. AS OF
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY THEY WERE
EIGHTY ONE FOURTEEN C.
CERTIFICATE HOLDERS IN
CALIFORNIA. FIFTY SEVEN OF THE
EIGHTY ONE HAVE VENDOR
AGREEMENTS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION TO PROVIDE
SERVICES AND SUPPORT. FOR
INDIVIDUALS SEEKING WHAT'S
CALLED COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT. FIVE YEARS AGO THEY
WERE TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WORKING IN SUB
MINIMUM WAGE ENVIRONMENT. THE
NUMBER IS NOW TWELVE THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY NINE. THE
NUMBER FOURTEEN C. CERTIFICATE
HOLDERS ALSO CONTINUES TO
DECREASE FROM ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE YEARS AGO TO EIGHTY ONE AS
OF OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY SO
EVEN AS CALIFORNIA PRIDES
ITSELF IN LEADING THE COUNTRY
WITH OUR FIFTEEN DOLLAR MINIMUM
WAGE. THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
WITH DISABILITIES ARE STILL
BEING EXPLOITED IN THE
SEGREGATED SETTINGS OFTEN FOR
LESS THAN TWO DOLLARS PER HOUR.
SEGREGATE EMPLOYMENT IS
ANTITHETICAL TO OUR VALUES AS A
STATE. AND REINFORCES THE FALSE
NOTION THAT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARE UNABLE TO BE
INTEGRATED IN SOCIETY AND ARE
INCAPABLE OF PRODUCING LABOR OF
VALUE. SB SIX THIRTY NINE
PROHIBITS THE ISSUANCE OF NEW.
CERTIFICATES BY JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND DEVELOPS A
PHASE OUT PLAN FOR CURRENT
CERTIFICATE HOLDERS. TO ENSURE
A PATH TO COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT. BY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THIS BILL
WOULD END THE PRACTICE OF
SEGREGATED SUB MINIMUM WAGE
EMPLOYMENT ENTIRELY. THIS IS
NOT A PARTISAN MEASURE IT IS A
MEASURE TO OFFER DIGNITY TO
THOSE WORKERS WITH
DISABILITIES. AND INSURERS BY
OFFERING THEM TO THE SAME UP
EARNED BY OFFERING THEM THE
SAME WAGES AND AS THEIR PEERS
IF ENACTED CALIFORNIA WILL
FOLLOW. THE STATE OF ALASKA
CONNECTICUT MARYLAND NEVADA NEW
HAMPSHIRE NEW YORK OREGON RHODE
ISLAND TEXAS AND WASHINGTON. IN
PROHIBITING SUB MINIMUM WAGE
EMPLOYMENT OR SHELTERED
WORKSHOPS. SET A MINIMUM WAGE
IS AN ARCHAIC RELIC OF THE
NINETEEN THIRTIES IT DATES TO A
TIME WHEN CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES WERE DENIED AN
EDUCATION AND BEFORE CIVIL
RIGHTS LEGISLATION SUCH AS THE-
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITY ACT.
IT IS BEYOND TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA AND THIS PRACTICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WE HAVE A- VOTE WITNESSES
TODAY GREGORY CAN'T KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. JACKIE ARMSTRONG A
FORMER SUB MINIMUM WAGE
EMPLOYEE AND ERIN CARUTHERS OF
THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. AB
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU WERE MISTER
KRAMER YOU- PREPARED TO PROCEED.
I AM YES MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU PLEASE PROCEED WITH. OKAY
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WILL PROBABLY
CO SPONSORED SENATE BILL SIX
THIRTY NINE WHAT THE STATE
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND COMMITTEE
AUTHOR FOR HER WORK TO END THE
EXPLODED A PRACTICE OF PAYING
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES LEG BY
MINIMUM WAGE. MEASURES LONG
OVERDUE FOR EIGHT DECADES OF
PRACTICE HAS REINFORCED A FALSE
ASSUMPTION THAT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARE LESS CAPABLE
OF FULL EMPLOYMENT THAN PEOPLE
WITHOUT DISABILITIES. IT IS
ALSO IN DIRECT CONFLICT WITH
THE STATE AND NATIONAL TRENDS
AT ALL POINTS IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION. IN RECENT YEARS FOR
STATES HAVE PROHIBITED THE SUB
MINIMUM WAGES ALL TOGETHER
ANOTHER FOREIGN AFFAIRS OUT
PROCESS AND MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE DONE THE SAME
THE MORE MORE PROVIDERS EVERY
DAY ARE CHOOSING TO END THEIR
RELIANCE ON THESE. OUTDATED AND
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES.
SHOULD BE NO SURPRISE DECADES
OF RESEARCH DEMONSTRATE THAT
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES CAN
WITH THE RIGHT SUPPORT. SIX
SEED AND COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT HOWEVER ALIGNING
CALIFORNIA STATE AND NATIONAL
TRENDS IS NOT ENOUGH. WE CAN DO
BETTER. THIS IS WHY SENATE BILL
SIX THIRTY NINE CALLS FOR STATE
AGENCIES COMMUNITY LEADERS AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO COME TOGETHER
TO DEVELOP A PLAN THAT NOT ONLY
PHASES OUT THE ABILITY FOR
PROVIDERS TO PAY PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHAT THE MINIMUM
WAGE. IT ALSO REQUIRES THE
IDENTIFICATION OF RESOURCES AND
FUNDING STREAMS THAT WILL
CREATE PATHWAYS TO EMPLOYMENT
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND SUB MINIMUM
WAGE SETTINGS. BUT IT'S TIME
FOR CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES EQUAL
PROTECTION UNDER THE LAW. AND
THAT'S A MINIMUM WAGE WILL CALL
IN ADVANCE THE SPIRIT OF THE
EIGHTY EIGHT. THE BILL COULD
COURTED BY A BROAD COALITION OF
DISABILITY GROUPS LABOR UNIONS
AND FORMER FOURTEEN C.
PROVIDERS. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY ABOUT. WHO YOU
MISTER CREE- THE CHECK
ARMSTRONG FOR YOU A BILL TO
TEST. YES I AM PLEASE EVERYONE
HE ME YES WE CAN PROCEED. I AM
JACKIE ARMSTRONG FROM ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND I'M ON THE
AUTISM SPECTRUM. I WORKED IN A
SHELTERED WORKSHOP FOR SEVEN
YEARS MY FIRST DANCE WORKSHOP I
WAS GOING NUTS AND BOLTS
TOGETHER I ASKED SOMEONE NEXT
TO ME WHAT ARE WE DOING AND THE
PERSONS THAT TRAINING AND I
GUESS TRAINING IS WHERE YOU
DON'T GET PAID FOR THE WHOLE
DAY BECAUSE THERE'S NO WORK.
NOW EVENTUALLY I GOT PROMOTED
TO LIKE TONICS WHERE I PUT
MEDICAL DEVICES TOGETHER AND IT
WAS A FIFTEEN STEP PROCESS AND
THEN YOU WOULD- PUT ALL THE
PARTS TOGETHER. A MEDICAL.
ALTOGETHER SURE IN THE BOARD
ALL. AND THEN. SKINNER GOAL ALL
THE IN THE ON THE CAN. NOW AT
THE TOP. MINIMUM WAGE WAS EIGHT
DOLLARS AN HOUR AND BECAUSE I
AM- ON THE SPECTRUM I'M ALSO
VERY METICULOUS DETAIL ORIENTED
I TEND TO GO SLOWER THAN MY
PEERS- AND ALL THEY READ WAS ON
THAT I WAS GOING SLOWER THAN
EVERYBODY ELSE SO. I GOT PAID
FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR FOR
BASICALLY WHAT AT WHAT MY
NONDISABLED PIERRE WAS MAKE
MAKING- ABOUT THREE TIMES AS
MUCH AS I WAS INCLUDING
BENEFITS AND VACATION PAY AND
ALL THAT. THE OTHER PIECES THAT
I WAS BULLIED QUITE A BIT FROM
BY- COWORKERS WITHOUT
DISABILITIES WHO WOULD ACTUALLY
MAKE THE OTHER DISABLED PEOPLE.
CALLING ME BECAUSE THEY WERE I
GUESS A LITTLE BIT INTIMIDATED
BY HOW. AWESOME I MIGHT BE SO I
EVENTUALLY DEVELOPED A BIT OF A
PHOBIA OF PEOPLE WITHOUT
DISABILITIES TO THE POINT WHERE
I A- STOPPED ON REACHING OUT TO
ANYBODY OUTSIDE OF MY FAMILY
AND I WAS ACTUALLY RATHER.
AFRAID OF PEOPLE AND MY I WOULD
LOOK IN THE MIRROR AND I SEE A
VERY SMALL PERSON NOT A VERY
BIG PERSON AS WELL SO. I DIDN'T
SEE MYSELF AS WORTHY OF WORKING
BASICALLY ARMS. THEN TWO
SIXTEEN I GOT INTO SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT AND I GOT A JOB
WHERE I WORK AT A MUNICIPAL
DISTRICT I MAKE ABOUT FIVE
TIMES AS MUCH AS I DO NOW OR AS
I DID WHEN I WAS AT THE
WORKSHOP. AND MY NOBODY BULLIES
ME THAT'S FOR SURE AND I LOVE.
EVERY MOMENT THAT I AM THERE
AND I. FEEL VALUED AND- I IF
THERE'S NO WORK COMING IN I
STILL GET PAID SO THAT'S THE
MOST WONDERFUL PART- THANK YOU
WHEN I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
DENIED VOTE. THREE Q. IS THERE
A FOR ME TO DO WE HAVE ANOTHER.
WITNESS ON THIS ITEM MR
CHERNOW- MISTER ERIN CARRUTHERS
WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS A TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THING THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WHO
MOVED INTO THE COMMITTEE ROOM
IS THERE ANYONE HERE PRESIDENT
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF THE BILL. C. NINE MOVE TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. IS THERE
ANYONE THERE- WISHING TO
TESTIFY SEE NONE I WILL COME
BACK TO THE TOTAL CONFERENCE
LINE. MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX THIRTY
NINE PLEASE LET US KNOW THE
NUMBER. OF WITNESSES AND AGAIN.
OF THE MAXIMUM TIME ALLOWED.
UNDER THIS PERIOD IS FIFTEEN
MINUTES. OR LESS AS MY
COLLEAGUES CONTINUE TO REMIND.
THANK YOU MISTER. AND THEY
DIDN'T ON IF YOU WERE TO SPEAK
SUPPORT S. SIX THIRTY NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND CURRENTLYWE
HAVE FIVE COMMENTS IN Q. ONE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO EXPORT. NINE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. NINE TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD THANKS.
THANK YOU CAN STONE OF STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF OPTIONS
FOR ALL IN SUPPORT. NINE FIFTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JUST WITH S. C. H.
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
NUMBER IT CAN LAND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. NINE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RICHMOND
PRESIDENT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA STATE EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPOR.
NINE ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANNO
TOPS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
CENTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THERE'S NOT A WEED
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ARE
CORRECT. THERE IS A PLEASE COME
FORWARD IF YOU'RE HERE TO SPEAK
UP IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
SIX THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAID CARL
LONDON HERE REPRESENTING TODAY.
THE ALLIANCE SUPPORTING PEOPLE
WITH I. D. D. THIS IS A
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION OF.
COMMUNITY BASED AGENCIES THAT
SERVE THE- POPULATION
CALIFORNIANS WITH IDEA ON A
DAILY BASIS. WE'RE NOT OPPOSED
TO THIS POINT WE DO HAVE SOME
DEEP CONCERNS WANT TO BRING
YOUR ATTENTION SOME VERY REAL
PRAGMATIC ISSUES THAT- WE
SHOULD ALL BE CONSIDERING OR
LOOKING AT THIS POLICY. THE
BILL AS A NUMBER OF FINE
POINTS IN IT WE SUPPORT MANY OF
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL WHAT
WE DON'T SUPPORT AND WE THINK
NEEDS TO BE REWORKED VERY
CAREFULLY. IS THE TIMELINE THE
CENTER DRAWS WAS PLACED IN THIS
BILL AND I WANT TO BACK UP FOR
SECOND EXPLAIN FOURTEEN SEE A
LITTLE BIT THE CONTEXT. OF HOW
THIS IS USED IN CALIFORNIA TO
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES EVERYONE
HERE SHOULD UNDERSTAND. THAT
NOBODY IN THIS POPULATION GETS
A NEW APPOINTMENT SITUATION
UNLESS IT GOES THROUGH THEIR
INDIVIDUALIZED PROGRAM. THAT
THEY DEVELOP IN CONCERT WITH
THE REGIONAL CENTER UNDER THE
LANHAM ACT THE STATE'S LAMIN
ACT YOU DO NOT END UP IN A
FOURTEEN C. EMPLOYMENT
SITUATION UNLESS IT'S BY YOUR
CHOICE. SO WHEN WE THINK OF
PEOPLE WHO WERE STABBED
ALLEGEDLY STUCK IN THE
SITUATIONS THEY'RE CHOOSING TO
BE AND THAT THE STATE HAS DONE
AN AWFUL LOT. TO TRY TO GET
THAT THE ISSUE OF EMPLOYMENT
FOR PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES TO
CREATE MINIMUM WAGE OR HIGHER
JOBS TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED. A PROVISION
THAT CALLED THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND EMPLOYMENT FIRST
STATE FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THEN WE DEVELOP
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT ANY PAID INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM. GUESS WHAT DURING THE
TIME OF THAT AND THAT DATES
BACK TO REPORT BY THE
DEPARTMENT WHICH AT THE TIME
SHOWED OUR STATE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE AT 86% FOR THIS POPULATION
GUESS WHAT IT IS TODAY AFTER
ALL THOSE EFFORTS OF THE LAST.
SIX YEARS STILL 86% WE ONLY
HAVE 40% WE HAVE TO DO BETTER.
THE REALITY HERE IS THE AT.
PEOPLE TO THIS BECAUSE IT
CREATES AN A FOR THEM TO GET
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY AND TO
WORK AND BEGIN TO JOIN THE
WORKFORCE IF YOU'RE A PERSON
WITH A DISABILITY INTERNAL HOME
OR MOM GOES TO WORK DAD GOES TO
WORK YOU ALSO THINK ABOUT GOING
TO WORK AND SO AS YOU DEVELOP
YOUR PLAN YOU LOOK AT WORTH
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGHOUT ALL OF
YOUR DISTRICTS THERE ARE
PROGRAMS TODAY THAT SERVE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE A SENATOR
BRONSON CORRECTLY NOTED IF THIS
BILL GOES THROUGH IN TWO YEARS.
EVERY ONE OF THOSE FOURTEEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE WERE EMPLOYED
WE'LL HAVE TO FIND A MINIMUM
WAGE OR HIGHER JOB OR BE OUT OF
WORK AND OUT OF THE WORK THAT
THEY CHOSE THAT'S NOT AN
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE WELL WE'VE
GOT A LOOK AT AND WHAT IS
CORRECT IN THIS BILL OR
DEVELOPING STRATEGIES HAVING
THE DISCUSSIONS AND WE OUGHT TO
BE DOING THINGS LIKE REACHING
OUT TO THE EMPLOYER COMMUNITY
TO ASK THEM WHAT IT IS THAT
THEY CAN DO TO HELP WITH THIS
POPULATION. LET'S HAVE A SUMMIT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER THE
GROCERS THE RESTAURANTS THE
RETAILERS THE MANUFACTURERS AND
ASKED THEM TO JOIN US IN THIS
EFFORT BEFORE WE JUST SHUT DOWN
THE EXISTING WORKING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT PEOPLE OUT
TODAY HI I URGE YOU I KNOW THIS
BILLS PROBABLY GONNA PASSED
TODAY THIS CONVERSATIONS GOTTA
GO A LOT DEEPER THAN THE SLOGAN
OF WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE ARE
MAKING MINIMUM WAGE OR HIGHER
IN THE STATE THERE IS MUCH MORE
COMPLEXITY TO IT THAT IS BEING
REPRESENTED AND I URGE YOU TO
TAKE A VERY CLOSE LOOK AT THIS
I KNOW IT'S GOING TO GO TO THE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE. WILL
HAVE A MORE FULLER DISCUSSION
THERE BUT THIS BILL IS NOT
EXACTLY WHAT'S BEING
REPRESENTED TODAY NOBODY ENDS
UP IN THESE JOBS UNLESS IT'S BY
THEIR CHOICE IT IS DEVELOPED
THROUGH AN IPP THAT GOES TO THE
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM SO EVERY
PERSON THAT IS IN THAT
SITUATION TODAY HASN'T APPROVED
PROGRAM FOR EXACTLY THAT
SITUATION AND THAT'S WHAT THE
REGIONAL CENTER HAS GONE OUT TO
HELP THEM BY WE'VE GOT A LOOK
AT THAT MUCH. MORE CAREFULLY
THAN WHAT'S BEING REPRESENTED
AT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE-
THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS OF
ANYONE ELSE N THE CAN ROOM
WISHES. OP TO SB SIX NINE. THE
C. NINE GONNA GO BACK TO THE-
OVERFLOW ROOM AND ASK- ONCE
AGAIN IS IN A ANYONE WHO WAS
TO. IN CASE IN OPPOSITION. I
WILL GO TO THE- CONFERENCE
MODERATOR IN AS IF THEY WERE-
ASK THE MODERATOR TO QUEUE UP
ANYONE THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB SIX THIRTY NINE
AND PLEASE LET US KNOW NUMBER
SPEAKERS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX THIRTY
NINE. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
THREE COMMENTS IN Q. OUR FIRST
COMMENT COMES FROM LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ABOUT WHO'S GOING. HI MY
NAME IS SAM AND I'M TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT I'M SORRY FOR THE
WRONG TIME. AND NINE THREE
HUNDRED NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THERESA
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE ARC
IN UCPE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION ARE BOARDED NOT
HAD A CHANCE TO TAKE A-
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL
YET BUT WE HAVE MET WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSOR TO VOICE OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL OUR
OUR CONCERNS REALLY DO CENTER
ONLY. OUR HI TO THE ELIMINATE
SO WE FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS OF THE BILL TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS THANK YOU.
MODERATORS ONE REMINDER ANYONE
WHO'S LISTENING IN THE IN THE
SEGMENT THEY CAN INDICATE THEIR
NAME THEIR AFFILIATION IN THE
POSITION PERIOD. FULL STOP.
THANK YOU IN LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SERVICES ASSOCIATION- LIKE
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AT THIS
TIME BUT WE HAS SOME
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS AROUND THE
TIMELINE- THAT DEVELOPMENT OF
ALTERNATIVE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND A LOT.
FUNDING STRUCTURE THAT.
DISABILITIES DO NOT LOSE THEIR
EMPLOYMENT- OPPORTUNITIES
RESULT IN THE CELL THANK YOU.
MOTOR IS THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO
WISHES TIME WE HAVE NO OF NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME OKAY- THANK YOU
MODERATOR- AGAIN THOUGH WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE WITNESSES-
HERE PRESENT- ONLINE THROUGH
THE TOLL CONVERT SYSTEM- AND WE
AGAIN. S. PEOPLE ESPECIALLY
WITH SEVERE TIME CONSTRAINTS ON
THE COMMITTEE ROOM UNDER CALL
THE PROTOCOL WE HAVE THIS ROOM
UNTIL SEVEN PM IT'S CRITICAL
THAT PEOPLE. ABIDE BY THE RULES
SO LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS
ESPECIALLY ON THE
TELECONFERENCE. WANTING TO YOUR
NAME. AFFILIATION POSITION
THANK YOU BACK TO. THE DAIS
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK ON SB SIX
THIRTY NINE FROM THE DAIS.
CENTER NEWMAN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I WAS ACTUALLY QUITE
MOVED BY THE FOR BY THE COLLAR
FOR THE WITNESS IN SUPPORT BUT-
IT SHOULD TO RUSSIA IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND RESPONDING TO THE
CONCERN WHICH WAS ARTICULATED
WELL BY MR LONDON AND OTHERS
ABOUT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE CONSEQUENCES
POTENTIALLY OF THIS LEGISLATION
PARTICULAR TIMELINE
IMPLICATIONS- AND THE POSSIBLE
THAT WE MIGHT. B. CLOSING
PATHWAYS- IN SOME WAYS FOR
DISABLED PEOPLE INSTEAD OF
EXPANDING THEM. THANK YOU
MISTER SENATOR- I THINK RATHER
ME MAYBE I'LL HAVE- MISTER
CARRUTHERS OF THE STATE COUNCIL
ON DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
ANSWERED THAT WITH MORE
EXPERTISE. THIS RECRUITERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU OUT THERE- THERE. FOLLOW
CHALLENGES TO THIS BILL
UNFORTUNATELY THE CHALLENGES
DON'T SPEAK PLUS FAVORABLY OF
CHARTER WORKSHOPS SO THE
ECONOMIC IMPLICATIONS OF THAT
THE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THEIR
COUNTER INDICATIVE. OF ACTUALLY
GETTING EMPLOYMENT SO THERE ONE
WAY TRAPS YOU GO WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY DON'T GET THE TRAINING
YOU NEED YOU DON'T GET THE
SKILLS YOU NEED YOU'RE LESS
LIKELY TO GET A JOB OUTSIDE OF
IT I'M BECAUSE THEY ARE PAYING
RATES THAT ARE LOWER THEY'RE
KEEPING PEOPLE IN POVERTY. WE
HAVE A LOT OF COMPASSION FOR
THE LEGACY SERVICES- WE HAVE
MUCH MORE COMPASSIONATE PEOPLE
RECEIVED. AT LEAST MINIMUM WAGE.
FOR THE DIGNITY OF THEIR WORK.
SO IT SHOULD I HAVE TO ASK HIM
IS THE A SCENARIO WHERE WE
CONSIDERED ONE WHERE- A
FOURTEEN C. WORKER WOULD BE
ASSURED OF MINIMUM WAGE AND
BETTER AND WE COULD STILL
PROVIDE THOSE PATHWAYS. THE
STATE OF THE A LOT OF
INVESTMENT- TOWARDS THOSE
PATHWAYS. FOR THE LAST FEW
YEARS THEY HAVE WORKED ON THE
BLUEPRINT FOR COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT THAT'S A
COLLABORATIVE PROJECT BETWEEN
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. WE
HAVE AN DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
ADDITIONALLY THE STATE HAS
ISSUED. SINCE FISCAL YEAR
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN. FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANTS. THIS
IS AN ONGOING A CORPORATION.
FOR A SERVICES THAT ARE SERVING
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES TO. MODERNIZE TO
UPDATE. THIS GRANT SOURCE
CONTINUES ON IN THE NEWS
ACCORDING TO PROVIDERS CAN.
PRODUCE GRANTS TO UPDATE. THEIR
THEIR SERVICES. THANK YOU IN
TERMS ICE MISTER LONDON IS A
BIT COULD WE GET A QUICK WRIST
FROM HIM AS WELL IF YOU WOULD
LIKE A TWO TWO DIRECT A
QUESTION TO HIM COOL IT OUR
MISSION ON IF YOU WOULD NOT
RECEIVE. ST YEAH- THANK YOU
MISTER- CENTER NEW AND THE TO
USE THAT IN OF THE FUNDING THAT
MR CROTHERS A SIGHTING WE STILL
HAVE RECEIVED NO BUMP IN THE
STATE OF ALL. INCREASE IN THE
NUMBERS. OF PEOPLE IN THE
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE. GETTING
MINIMUM WAGE HIGHER OF. IT JUST
DEMONSTRATES WHAT A CHALLENGE
IT IS TO GET TO THAT LEVEL. NOW
WE HAVE PROPOSED SOME THINGS.
CREATIVELY IN THE PAST FOR
EXAMPLE AN IDEA YOU COULD DO.
IS LET THE IMPORT EMPLOYER PAY.
FOR THE FOURTEEN C. PORTION OF
THE PERSON'S WAGE. THAT YOU
WOULD OTHERWISE MEASURE AND
STILL GO THROUGH THE PROCESS
ALLOWED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND THEN SUBSIDIZE
THE REST SOMEHOW. WE PROPOSED A
TAX CREDIT TO PASS WITHOUT IT
WAS REJECTED BY THE LEGISLATURE
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO LOWER.
THE PROP NINETY BASE FUNDING WE
GET SCORED. SO ORGANIZED LABOR
OPPOSES THAT- YOU'D HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT A MASSIVE
SUBSIDIZATION IN ORDER TO JUMP
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE. BASED ON
THEIR PRODUCTIVITY. INTO A
MINIMUM WAGE OR HIGHER JOB OR-
YOU'RE SENDING THE MESSAGE
UNDER THIS BILL. THAT THEY
SIMPLY CANNOT WORK IN THE
WORKPLACE THAT. BECAUSE THEY
DON'T MEET. MINIMUM WAGE
PRODUCTIVITY WHICH EMPLOYERS.
USUALLY WANT AS PART OF THEIR
BOTTOM LINE. UNLESS YOU
SUBSIDIZE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
LOSE OUT. AND THE DATA MR
CROWTHER'S REFERS TO OVER OVER
AGAIN. WHAT THEY ARE TELLING
YOU ARE DEMONSTRATING AT THAT
DATA. IS HOW MANY OF THOSE
PEOPLE THAT WE SUBSIDIZE IN
THOSE PROGRAMS. CONTINUE ON IN
THE JOB THAT THEY HAVE INTO THE
FUTURE UNTIL WE KNOW THAT. IT'S
VERY PREMATURE. TO SLAM THE
DOOR ON PEOPLE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING. CHOSEN TO DO
THAT AND HAVE NO HOPE TO GET
INTO THE OTHER. STYLE JOB THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE. ALL
WE'RE SAYING IS THAT SHE'S
SHE'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT ON THAT.
ROAD IS RUBBISH AMENDMENTS BUT
THE TIMELINE BROUGH WE NORMALLY
ALLOW FIVE MINUTES TOTAL FOR A
WITNESS WE ARE NEW- A SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME TO RESPOND TO A
QUESTION DIRECTLY. IF YOU'RE
STARTING OFF ON A TANGENT SO.
YEAH PLEASE WRAP UP THANK YOU
ALL I'D SAY IS THAT THE
TIMELINE IN THIS BILL IS JUST
COMPLETELY UNREALISTIC GIVEN
THE GOALS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER PATIENT THANK YOU
MISTER PRIME AND I GUESS I
WOULD HOPE THAT THESE TWO
GOALS. ARE NOT MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE AND THE AUTHOR AND I
KNOW THE AUTHOR- IS MORE THAN
WILLING. TO LOOK AT SCENARIOS
THAT MIGHT ALLOW FOR A MORE
GRAYSON. TODAY YOU. ANYTHING-
ALSO FROM OF CENTER ALERT I- I
WAS GOING TO GO ASSUME PATH
THIS THE IS SENT NEWMAN AND
IT'S JUST AND I TALKED TO THE-
AUTHORED VERY BRIEFLY AND
INFORMALLY BEFORE THE HEARING
JUST BECAUSE- I HAD EXPERIENCE
WITH THESE PROGRAMS IN JURASSIC
TIMES AHEAD AND IT WAS ALWAYS
AN ISSUE OF. IF YOU MOVE TO
MINIMUM WAGE YOU HAD TO HAVE
SOME EXTRA MONEY. TO DO IT AND
THURSDAY'S ANCILLARY ISSUES
THAT OUR MONETARY IS THE AMOUNT
OF TIME PEOPLE SPENDING IS ON
AMOUNT OF TIME OF
SOCIALIZATION. AND THE
SOCIALIZATION HAS VALUE IN
ADDITION TO THE WAGE. AND F.
AND I KNOW THAT MISTER LONDON.
AHA BOB JUST AS A PERSONAL
CONNECTION TO THIS HE ISN'T
NECESSARILY STANDING UP FOR
CLIENT IT'S PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
AND SO I'M PREPARED BECAUSE I
THINK THAT THE AUTHOR IS IN THE
RIGHT PLACE FOR FORCING THE
ISSUE DECISION NEEDS TO BE
ENFORCED AND IT'S THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT I THINK THERE ARE
STILL SOME CONVERSATIONS TO BE
HAD BECAUSE FOR TURNS OUT THAT
WE NEED TO BUDGETARY WE ADD
SOME MONEY TO MAKE SURE THIS
WORKS OR NOT. I JUST KNOW THAT.
OUR WHEN I WAS RESOURCES
SECRETARY WE HAD CONSERVATION
CORPS MEMBERS AT WORK MAKING
MINIMUM WAGE AND- THERE WAS A
PERIOD OF TIME WHERE THE
ADMINISTRATION MIGHT OWN
ADMINISTRATION WAS NOT GOING TO
GIVE US EXTRA MONEY SO. IN
ORDER TO INCREASE THE WAGE
WE'RE GOING TO CUT HOURS OF THE
NUMBER FOR THE NUMBER OF CORPS
MEMBERS AND IN THE END. SOME OF
US BLUDGEONED TO THEM INTO
PUTTING THE RIGHT AMOUNT OF
MONEY AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE GOT THE MINIMUM WAGE
THEY DESERVED. AND IT DIDN'T
DISADVANTAGED THEM IT WASN'T A
FALSE RIGHTS- TO GET IT AND SO
I DON'T KNOW WHEN ENOUGH TO
KNOW IF THERE'S A SIMILAR
QUESTION HERE BUT IF THERE IS-
I WOULD SUPPORT PASSING THE
BILL I'M TRYING TO ADDRESS THAT
QUESTION. AND M. R. WOULD JUST
HOPE THAT THERE'S CONVERSATIONS
IF THE TIME ON JUST TWO SHORT
BECAUSE SOME OF THESE ISSUES
AREN'T ADDRESSED AT THAT. YOU
KNOW BE TALKED ABOUT THE DEATH
OUR DAHLE IS A PERSON OF GOOD
FAITH. AND INCREDIBLE
INTELLIGENCE I'M GOING TO VOTE
TO MOVE THE BILL ALONG AND
JUST. I THINK WE JUST NEED TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE TESTIMONY
THAT WAS GIVEN TO. THE MOTION
SENATOR THE BILL. SOON ARE ALSO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. M. YOU
KNOW I AM I KNOW THAT WE MYSELF
AND OUR ADVOCATES OF COURSE
WOULD LISTEN TO ANYTHING
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT ABOUT PUTTING
PEOPLE OUT OF WORK- BUT WE DO
KNOW THAT- WE BELIEVE THAT THE
LENGTH OF TIME THAT'S BEEN
INCORPORATED HERE. YOU KNOW
CLOSE TO THREE YEARS THAT THAT
SHOULD BE ENOUGH TO FIGURE OUT
THE PHASING OUT BUT WILL BE
GLAD TO GO BACK AND REVISIT THE
REVISIT THE ISSUE SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RELIABLE. OKAY
SO WE OVER A MOTION BY SENATOR
LAYERED- AND WILL FIRST ROLL
CALL VOTE THIS TIME. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HUMAN SERVICES SENATOR CORTESE
HI AND THE COURT HAS THE
HIGHEST SENATOR- CHOKE.
PASSENGER OCHO BOOK NOT VOTE IN
SENATOR ALSO. SENATOR DRAWS- ON
SENATOR LAYERED CENTER LAYERED
HI SENATOR NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
SENATOR NEWMAN HI- THAT MEASURE
IS FOUR TO ONE. THE THANK YOU
BILLS OF. WELL FOUR ZERO FOUR
EXCUSE ME FOUR ZERO. THANK YOU
FOR CLARIFYING MATH. SENATOR
DRAWS A WILL MOVE NOW TO YOUR
BILL SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY
FOUR- YOU MAY PRESENT AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR M. I. A. PROMISE IT.
WHERE DID THE- WITH I REALLY
YOUR PATIENCE IN TIME AND-
HELLO ME TO GO FORWARD WITH
THIS- AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON ON
THIS BILL OR YOUR STAFF HAS
BEEN. VERY THOUGHTFUL AND
DETAILED IN THEIR ANALYSIS AND-
WE'VE LOOKED AT THE
CONSIDERATIONS AND THEN
ANALYSIS I WILL WORK HARD TO
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS EACH OF
THOSE POINTS. AND ALSO TO
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS- SB SIX SEVENTY
FOUR WILL ENSURE THAT THE
BENEFITS OF THE TRANSITION TO
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION. WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA'S MOST MARGINALIZED
PEOPLE AND ALL WORKING
FAMILIES. THIS BILL FOCUSES ON
CREATING QUALITY CLIMATE
RESILIENT JOBS WITH OUR
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS. THERE
WAS A REPORT AB THREE NINETY
EIGHT UP AB THREE NINETY A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE-
CALLED PUTTING CALIFORNIA ON
THE HIGH ROAD A JOBS JOBS AND
CLIMATE ACTION PLAN. AND IS
PART OF IT SAID IF I MAY MISTER
CHAIR- IT SAID QUOTE
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR IS THE STATE'S LARGEST
SOURCE OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS ACCOUNTING 439% OF
THE STATEWIDE TOTAL. IS ALSO
THE LARGEST SOURCE OF CRITERIA
AIR POLLUTANTS AND TOXIC DIESEL
PARTICULATE MATTER EMISSIONS IN
THE STATE. AND AT THE SAME TIME
IT THE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
UNDERPINS OUR ECONOMY-
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF GOODS
ARE MOVED EACH YEAR- AND-
SUPPORT MORE THAN FIVE MILLION
JOBS AND OF COURSE WE HAVE OUR
PASSENGER VEHICLES UP
PARTNERSHIPS WITH BUSINESS CAN
LEAD TO PROSPERITY FOR
EVERYONE. AND THIS BILL WOULD
ENACT THE CALIFORNIA JOBS PLAN
ACT TO CREATE A CLEAR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE GUM
BENEFIT THE COMPANIES WHO ARE
BENEFITING FROM OUR PUBLICLY
FUNDED TRANSPORTATION CONTRACTS
AND SUBSIDIES AND MAKE IT A
TRANSPARENT TO THE TAXPAYERS.
OF THE JOBS PLAN REFERS TO A
COMPONENT OF AN APPLICATION AN
APPLICANT SUBMITS IT FOR
COVERED PUBLIC CONTRACTS
SPECIFIES THE MINIMUM NUMBER OF
JOBS PROPOSED WAGES BENEFITS
INVESTMENT IN TRAINING AND
TARGETED HIRING PLANS
ESPECIALLY FOR DISPLACED
WORKERS AND INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
HISTORICALLY BEEN EXCLUDED. BUT
OUR JOBS PLAN COMPONENT WILL
NOT REQUIRE ANY NEW COMMITMENTS
OTHER THAN THOSE ALREADY
REQUIRED BY RELEVANT FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL LAWS. THE- THEY
SHALLOW- ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATION TO APPLICANTS NOT
THAT THE PLAN WILL BE WEIGHTED
HIGHER THAN OTHER SECTIONS.
REQUIRED INFORMATION INCLUDES
AGAIN THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES
THE NUMBER OF JOBS FOR
DISPLACED WORKERS- PROPOSED
WAGES AND BENEFITS OF THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION FEDERAL
MINISTRATION HAS BEEN CLEAR
THAT PUBLIC DOLLARS SHOULD
CREATE COMMUNITY BENEFITS. AND
HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER PRESIDENT
BY HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER ON KIND
CLIMATE IMPLEMENTS IMPLEMENTS
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN FEDERAL
POLICY A PAIRING OF URGENT
ISSUES OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. THE CREATION OF NEW
GOOD JOBS AND OF COURSE- PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN HAVE BEEN HEAVILY
POLLUTED FIVE COMMUNITIES- WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
TOGETHER TO REALIZE THE GOALS
OF OUR OWN CALIFORNIA FUTURE
WORK COMMISSION. WHICH CALLS
FOR A NEW SOCIAL COMPACT FOR
WORK AND WORKERS- WE NEED CLEAR
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR COMMITMENTS
TO JOB CREATE A CREATION AND
ACCESS TO THAT INFORMATION FROM
THE PUBLIC- SO THIS ACT WILL
MOVE STATE TRIBES PROTECTION
FUNDS. TO GOOD JOBS AND SURE
PROACTIVE EFFORT TO GIVE THOSE
JOBS TO WHEN MEN AND WOMEN WHO
HAVE HAD BEEN. EXCLUDED
HISTORICALLY- TODAY WE HAVE
MELANIE TO MELA PRASAD FROM
JOBS TO MOVE AMERICA AS A
WITNESS TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCH PRASAD OR YOU
PREPARED TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME.
THE CANON MCAFEE PLEASE
RECEIVED. PARENTS MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE NEGATIVE NOMINAL
PROFOUND AND I IN THE
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR AND JOHN
MERICA NATIONAL STRATEGIC
RESEARCH AND POLICY CENTER
DEDICATED TO ENSURING THAT
PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE SPENT IN A
WAY THAT. THE PUBLIC AT. I'M
HERE TO INVOICE STRONG SUPPORT
FOR AT SEVEN POINT BUT- JOB.
EACH YEAR IN AND ON. MOMENT OF
CONVERGING. FIVE GETTING ON.
SYMPATHETIC AS CLIMATE CHANGE.
OR TO START OURSELVES OUT OF
THE- YOU NEED STOCKHOLM
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS THAT FINAL
PAYMENT A CLASS MULTIPLE ISSUES
AB ONE. I THINK SIX SEVEN BORN
IS ONE ACTUALLY. BY BEING PART
ABOUT HOW WE INVEST THE HARD
EARNED TAX DOLLARS IN TRAFFIC.
I THINK HERE BY THE PEOPLE OF
THIS STATE WE CAN IN BACK IN
CLIMATE EIGHT TRANSPORTATION
WHILE CREATING GOOD MIDDLE
CLASS CAREER PATHWAYS FOR
PEOPLE WHO AND I'M OUT. I
SENATOR TORONTO ALREADY DONE A
VERY GOOD JOB OF EXPLAINING
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA JOBS AND
THAT. I'D LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA JOB DOES NOT DEAL.
THE CALIFORNIA JOB TRAINING IS
NOT PLACE AN UNDUE BURDEN ON.
IT DOES NOT TAKE PRIORITY OVER
AT CENTRAL ELEMENT LIKE
ASPHERIC. NOT QUITE LIKE THE
PRICE OF BAD ARCHETYPAL
COMPETITION AND IT DOES NOT
REQUIRE ANY MINIMUM COMMITMENT.
THE CALIFORNIA DOT. BORN THE
ONLY REQUIREMENT IS THAT IT BE
SOLD OUT AND THAT YOU ARE QUITE
ON IT ONLY. BACKSET IT
RECOGNIZING THAT WHEN COMPANIES
PAY FAMILY SUSTAINING WAGES AND
CREATE MIDDLE CLASS CAREER PATH
FOR INDIVIDUAL IN BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT IT HAS A VERY REAL
POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE ECONOMY
AND THAT NEEDS TO BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION. THE CALIFORNIA
BAD PLAN DOES NOT VALUE THAT
THE FACT OVER BUT THE CLOCK THE
BED BY THE QUALITY OF THE
PRODUCT. ALL IT DOES IS
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE IN
INVESTING IN THE CURRENT SYSTEM
AWARDING CONTRACTS. INHERENTLY
REWARD BAD ACTOR I AM ONLY
TAKING QUALITY AND COST INTO
CONSIDERATION THE GOVERNMENT
ISN'T AN EXACT THING WE WILL
TAKE THEM BACK TO THE MAIN
PRODUCT. NO MATTER WHAT. WHEN
COMPANIES CAN'T COMBINE QUALITY
IF YOU CAN BY LABOR COSTS DOWN.
AND WHEN THEY DO THAT REAL
PEOPLE BUT VERY PEOPLE WHO TAX
DOLLARS ARE BEING USED TO FUND
THE CONTRACT. I DON'T WANT TO
GET HURT. I THINK SIX SEVEN FOR
IT HOW WE SHIP FRAMEWORK I'M
READY FOR THE BOTTOM. OF THE
TOP. IF YOU CAN YOU CARE ABOUT
COST HE CARE ABOUT QUALITY AND-
ABOUT THE PEOPLE. AND JOB
MEREKA WE HAVE SEEN JUST HOW
MUCH POLICIES LIKE THAT CAN
TRANSFORM COMMUNITIES. THE
CALIFORNIA JOB PLAN ABSOLUTION
OF A POLICY CALLED THE U. S.
EMPLOYMENT PLAN OR USD JPY FOR
SHORT WHICH HAD BEEN USED
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
ANY- ANY AMTRAK USED TO BE LIKE
PPL ON A- AWARDED ALL THEM THAT
WOULD CREATE THIRTEEN HUNDRED
JOBS IN MORE THAN NINETY CITIES
ACROSS. YEAH I'M A CONTRACTOR
THEY ARE. WHICH RESULTED IN ANY
FACTOR ON THE SOUTHEAST OF
CHICAGO. READING OF TWO HUNDRED
JOBS CONSTRUCTION AT LEAST A
HUNDRED SEVENTY. PRODUCTION AND
RIGHT HEARING HEALTH FOR. OUR
METRO APPLIED BIELECKI ON A
CONTRACT WITH THE SHARIA THAT
RESULTED IN A NEW FAD AND
LOOKING COUNTY AND THE CREATION
FOR HER AND FOUR HI. JOB. THE
COMPANY MAKE REAL COMMAND
TWENTY IN CAN. IMMUNITY TRêN.
YEAH MAYBE WHY WE TO CAL JOHN
IF THERE ARE ALREADY AND PRIOR
HI PAUL JOBS AND JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INTO THE IN
VARIOUS EMPLOYMENT OR PROGRAM
THAT DIRECTLY ON ENHANCE. AND
THE ANSWER. TO TAKE ACTION.
MILLION OF PEOPLE ARE ON A AND
NOT IS THIS QUITE CARRIED BY
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND OTHER IN
THE ANYTHING. CHANGE EFFECTIVE
ARE ALREADY. CARRIED BY PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES COULD HURT THE LACK
OF ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND
TYPICALLY LIVING WITH HIGHER
AND WE- AND OTHER APPLE. THANK.
WE HAVE PROOF THAT POLICY WORK.
YOU DON'T HAVE TIME TO WAIT
WAITING FOR POST ACROSS THE
STATE TO A DOT THEIR OWN POLICY
WITH THE VARYING. AND. ACTION
NOW. STRONG LEADER OVER THERE
FOR A BI TOMORROW HELLO HAS
ALWAYS BEEN THAT GREAT IN A-
SHOWING STRONG LEADERSHIP IN.
AND ENERGY. AND TODAY I CALLED
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU WHO
SHALL AIM. AND FIGHT FOR ALL
THE VOICES IN OUR. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. YEAH. SEEING NO ONE
THERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SIX SEVENTY FOUR WE WILL MOVE
TO THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
WELL AS THE MODERATOR TO QUEUE
UP ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES. ON SB
SIX SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
INDICATE THE NUMBER OF
WITNESSES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE FIVE
IN Q. NINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THERE ARE
LOCKS ON BEHALF OF THE
TRANSPORT WORKERS UNION AFL-CIO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SCHERING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DISAGREE SHALL DEAL ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RESEARCHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
LOUIS COSTA WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SHEET METAL AIR RAIL AND
TRANSPORTATION WORKERS
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR MEMBERS PRESS FORGET ALL
FROM HOUSES FROM OPPORTUNITIES
AND THANK YOU. NINE ONE THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CARE MEMBERS MIKE MY
NUMBER THE STATUS OF ELECTOR
WORKERS. AND THE CALIFORNIA'S I
CAL STRONG SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU- I HAVE
NOT SEEN A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS. THERE ANYONE TO SPEAK
AS LEADER. C. NINE IS THERE A
IN THE COMMITTEE TO SPEAK AN OP
AS SIX OF FOUR. THE SINGING NUN-%
WILL ANYONE IN ROOM TO FOUR TO
SPEAK UP. SEEN NONE WILL COME.
TO THE CAR CALL CAN MODERATOR-
PLEASE Q. ANY OP. SPEECH ON B.
C. SEVENTY FOR INCLUDE LET US
KNOW THE NUMBER SPEAKERS. THANK
YOU MISTER. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF THE
SIX SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO COMMENTS
IN Q. MINE THREE HUNDRED AND
TWELVE. I'M SORRY WE HAVE ONE
COMMON IN Q. ONE THREE TWELVE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JOB OFFERED ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL OF
ENGINEERING COMPANIES TO
CALIFORNIA- WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS TIME IN
SPEAKING WITH US ABOUT THE
BILL- WE YOU KNOW WE DID. OUR
OUR LETTER TO THE- AND I THINK
WE HAVE SOME CAN. LOOK FORWARD
TO DISCUSS THIS AS A MOVES FOR-
YOU KNOW QUITE A DISCONNECTION
ME INTEREST- THE AND- OF AUTHOR
AND THE SPA. OF THE BILL- WE
KNOW THAT YOU KNOW A SOMERS WE
THINK ARE. APPLES AND ORANGES
HERE A LITTLE BIT YOU KNOW WITH
RESPECT TO JOBS TO MOVE AMERICA
AS US EMPLOYMENT PLAN. HOW WAS
USED IN LA CHICAGO AND BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS IN A
ACTUALLY IN THE PURCHASE OF
PRODUCTS IN THE PURCHASE OF
GOODS WITH RESPECT TO ACTUAL
RAIL AND PASSENGER CARS- AND
YOU KNOW IN SOME RESPECTS WE
UNDERSTAND- HOW A SYSTEM LIKE
THIS MIGHT WORK IN THAT CONTEXT
WHEN. YOU ARE NEGOTIATING WITH
A PRODUCT PROVIDER AND YOU
DON'T SEE ALL THE THINGS GO ON
THAT IF ALL YOU'RE SEEING IS.
HERE'S A REAL CAR IS THE
PERFECT FOR- AND SETTLE A YOU
KNOW SUMMER WITH IT MAKES SENSE
THAT. WE'RE NOT SURE IT SENSE.
GIVEN THE LIMITED APPLE SO FAR
THERE TAKE THIS ENTIRE. AND
SPREAD ACROSS ALL CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS IN. SERVICE CON.
ACROSS PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE-
CAL- MORE WE'RE NOT BE ABLE.
JUST WANT TO MAKE CLEAR- HUNT
IS ANY OPPOSITION ON THE
FILIATION IMPOSITION PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND WE DO HAVE LINE.
SEVENTY ONE SEVENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREG
GARNER WITH CARPENTER SAVERS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASPHALT PAVEMENT ASSOCIATION
LIKE TO THINK THAT YOU'RE GONNA
COMMITTEE FOR THE FANTASTIC
ANALYSIS. AND WE HAVE REACHED
OUT TO THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE- TO
TRY AND RESOLVE SOME OF HER
CONCERNS WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF
ALL THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE ON
AS HE WANTED TO RECALL READY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
UNDER THAT. MAJOR BUT WE ARE
CLOSE ENOUGH INTENDED. WE'RE
ANY OTHER SPEAKER THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS. BORDER THERE ANY
OTHER SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF A COMPACT THE
COMMITTEE- FOR ANY DISCUSSION.
SIXTY NINE FOR MY COLLEAGUES. A
SENATOR ALSO APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS THE SPORT IT'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A COMPLEX TOPIC
BUT- ONE THAT I'VE HAD SOME
SIGNIFICANT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
EXPERIENCE WITH IN TERMS OF- IN
BEDDING- THIS KIND OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND WORKFORCE-
STANDARDS. INTO THE
CONTRACTING- ROSS THE
CONTRACTING PROCESS AND I'D
LIKE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH YOU
IN THE FUTURE ON THE ON THE
BILL TO THE EXTENT HE WILLING
TO DO THAT- WITH THAT YOU MAY
CLOSE ABSOLUTELY I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR OFFER OF
ASSISTANCE AND WE'LL I'LL TAKE
YOU UP ON IT AND I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU. THREE OF THEM.
TO EXERCISE THE JURORS
PROVOCATIVE IN MOVE THE BILL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION CENTER COURTESY
HI. CORTESE HI SENATOR JOE BOOK.
SENATOR CHAU BUG NO SENATOR
ALSO. SENATOR REID SO HI
SENATOR LAYERED CENTER LAYARD
AVE SENATOR NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
SENATOR NEWMAN AYE THE VOTE IS
FOUR TO ONE. THE BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU. JUST TO CLARIFY
WHERE WE ARE ON THE AGENDA AT
SO- I DEFERRED TO CENTER DRAWS
SO ON ITEM THREE. UP FOR THE
ROOM A RULE SO I WILL BE
TURNING THE GAVEL OVER TO- TWO
METAL BY SHARE- JEWEL BOOK- TO-
PRESIDE- SO THAT- SHE SOLOS FOR
ME PRESENT ON SENATE BILL. TWO
THIRTEEN- JUST TO NOTE WE STILL
DO HAVE SENATE BILLSIX OH SIX
CONSOLES AND SENATE BILL SIX
EIGHTY FIVE MCGUIRE- STILL TO
BE HEARD. IN CENTER REQUIRE HAS
US THAT- THAT I PRESENT ON SB
SIXTY FIVE SO I'M HOPING THAT
WE GET THERE BEFORE WE LOSE THE
ROOM- LET ME. THE MEDIA
FORMALLY PASS. THE GAVEL OVER
HOPEFULLY IT WILL BE NECESSARY
TO USE BUT YOU NEVER KNOW. IN
THE REST. WELCOME SENATOR
CORTESE YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL SB TWO THIRTEEN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU. BUSHER
WITH MADAM CHAIR CURRENTLY- IN
SANDERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTEEN WHICH-
WE'LL CREATE A WORKERS
COMPENSATION REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION FOR HOSPITAL PLEASE
PROVIDE DIRECT PATIENT CARE IN
ACUTE HOSPITAL SETTING. FOR
ISSUES SUCH AS INFECTIOUS
DISEASE CANCER. A MONTH MUSCO
SKELETAL INJURY POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER AND RESPIRATORY
ILLNESS INCLUDING KOBE NINETEEN
WORKERS COMPENSATION
PRESUMPTIONS EXISTS FOR CERTAIN
FRONTLINE PROFESSIONS SUCH AS
FIREFIGHTERS BECAUSE THEY'RE IN
A BIT INEVITABLY EXPOSED DOZENS
OF POTENTIAL ILLNESSES AS A
CONDITION OF THEIR WORK. MANY
OF WHICH LEAD TO HEALTH ISSUES
SUCH AS INFECTIOUS DISEASES
RESPIRATORY ILLNESSES AND
CANCER. PRESUMPTIONS ARE WAY TO
SCREAM ON TREATMENT FOR WORKERS
BY REDUCING THE BURDEN OF PROOF
THAT THEIR INJURY ILLNESS WAS
CAUSED. BY THE NATURE OF THE
EMPLOYMENT. THESE ILLNESSES AND
INJURIES ARE SIMPLY PRESUME TO
BECAUSE BY THE NATURE THE
EMPLOYEES WORK. THIS PROTECTS
THE EMPLOYEE FROM HOSPITAL OR
SURGICAL COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
A HEALTH ISSUE. ONLY CERTAIN
TYPES OF FRONTLINE
PROFESSIONALS ARE CURRENTLY
ELIGIBLE FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION PRESUMPTIONS.
PLEASE INCLUDE PROFESSIONS SUCH
AS EMTS PARAMEDICS FIREFIGHTERS
AND POLICE OFFICERS. HOLD WHICH
HAPPEN TO BE MALE DOMINATED
FIELDS. MEANWHILE FRONTLINE
WORKERS WHO WORK IN HEALTH CARE
SETTING SUCH AS NURSES ARE NOT
ENTITLED TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION PRESUMPTIONS. THEN
I SHOULD NOTE. THAT PROFESSION
IS STILL A FEMALE DOMINATED.
THE FIELD BY GENDER THIS IS
DESPITE THE FACT. THAT NURSES
TREAT THE SAME PATIENTS IN
HOSPITALS. LAKE CITY OPTIONS
FOR TREATING IN THE FIELD. THIS
BILL RECOGNIZES AND ADDRESSES A
WORKERS COMPENSATION
PRESUMPTION SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
FOR ALL FRONTLINE PROFESSIONS
WERE RISK OF THE SAME ILLNESSES
AND INJURIES TO THE NATURE OF
THE WORK. AND I SHOULD SAY THAT.
BUT WE VIEWS EXPRESSION OFTEN
THAT THE PANDEMIC HAS LAID BARE.
A CERTAIN INEQUITIES AND I
WOULD SUBMIT. THAT THIS IS ONE
OF THOSE INEQUITIES THAT IS
BEEN LAID BARE BY THE PANDEMIC.
SB TWO THIRTEEN RECOGNIZES THAT
HEALTH CARE WORKERS SUCH AS
NURSES ARE ON THE FRONT LINES
AND FEES MANY OF THE SAME
HEALTH SERVICES PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
CREATES A WORKERS COMPENSATION
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION FOR
HOSPITAL PLEASE PROVIDE DIRECT
PATIENT CARE IN THOSE AREAS I
MENTIONED EARLIER- IN- THE
QUEUE HOSPITAL SETTINGS. AND
AGAIN SUCH AS INFECTIOUS
DISEASE CANCER MOSKAL
MUSCULOSKELETAL INJURY
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
AND RESPIRATORY ILLNESS
INCLUDING COVERT. IT WILL
MODERNIZE. THE BILL OF
MODERNIZE OUTDATED CALIFORNIA
LAWS TO MAKE IT. EASIER FOR
REGISTERED NURSES TO ACCESS THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM
JUST LIKE THE LAW CURRENTLY.
PROVIDES. ACCESS FOR OTHER
FRONTLINE WORKERS. THIS WILL
ENSURE FIRST RESPONDER WORKERS.
HAVE ACCESS TO THE SAME WORKERS
COMPENSATION PRESUMPTIONS IS A
VITAL STEP IN ACHIEVING
ECONOMIC AND GENDER EQUALITY.
WHAT IS TODAY IS KERN SLANG FOR
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT- AND CATHERINE DONOHUE
CONNECT REGISTERED NURSE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT AND ABOUT HER OWN
LIVED EXPERIENCE ACCESSING.
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM.
THANK YOU MEMBERS SURE. THANK
YOU SENATOR CORTESE. WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO ANYONE ONE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND YOU HAVE
A LEAD AUTHOR AUTHOR FOR LEAD
SUPPORTER ON THE LINE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE YES GOOD EVENING.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M CHRIS LANG OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
OUT ONTO THE PASSED BETWEEN.
ONE THREE WE THANK US SENATOR
CORTES IGOR'S LEADERSHIP NOT
TRUSTING THIS IMPORTANT MATTER
FOR MEMBERS. ALSO RECORD
CHAMPIONS INDICATED S. B. TWO
ONE THREE IS MUCH NEEDED
LEGISLATION THAT PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL PROTECTION. BUT WE
HAVE WORKERS COMPENSATION
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY FOR
HEALTHCARE WORKERS ON THE
FRONTLINE. AND SEEK TO ACHIEVE
PARITY BETWEEN PREDOMINATELY
FEMALE ARE AND- AND HOSPITAL
WORKERS ASSEMBLY MALE
FIREFIGHTER. FIREFIGHTERS
POLICE OFFICERS AND OTHER FIRST.
RESPONDERS FOR FRONT LINE
WORKERS. I THE CENTER HAS NO
THE LEAD. HAS TO DO PARTS.
REQUIRED BY AND POSE OFFICERS
VEHICLE ON TO BUILD. WHILE
NURSES AND HEALTHCARE WERE OVER
WELL WENT. IN OUR TREATING THE
SAME PATIENT ARE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR PRESUMPTION. BY THE NATURE
OF THEIR PROFESSION NURSES AND
HEALTHCARE WORKERS ARE IN
CONSTANT DANGER OF BEING
DIRECTLY EXPOSED THE SAME
HAZARDS AS FIREFIGHTERS AND
POLICE OFFICERS INCLUDING
IMPRESSES DISEASES AND
RESPIRATORY DISEASES SUCH AS
COVER NINETEEN. CARCINOGENS ARE
BENAMI HAZARDS INFORMATIK YOU
DANCE. IN FACT REGISTERED
NURSES EXPERIENCE WORK MORE
WORK RELATED INJURIES AND
ILLNESSES AND WORKERS OVERALL
IN NINE STATES INCLUDING OVER
10% MORE INJURIES AND ILLNSSES
OF ALL KIND. 3% MORE
MUSCULOSKELETAL DISORDERS 22%
HAVE SYMPTOMS OF POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER. ONE HUNDRED
AND 31% MORE INTEREST FROM
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE IN TWENTY
FOUR U. S. STATES FOUND
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED.
MORTALITY AMONG NURSES TO
CANCER. THE NURSES CAN HELP
THERE'S A ALREADY STATED AND
HEALTH WORKERS TREAT SAME NOT
TO. THAT ARE FROM. WORKERS
TREATING THE STILL. NURSES
ACTUALLY SPEND MORE TIME WITH
THESE PATIENT IN KOSOVO IN
IMPOSSIBILITIES. NURSING THEM
BACK TO HELP DESK INCREASING
THEIR RISK AND EXPOSURE TO
HAZARDS IN HOMES. THESE HEROES
NEED THE SAME PROTECTION THE
COURT TO PUT ON THE MAIL-
FIREFIGHT AND POLICE OFFICERS.
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
INDICATES THAT HOSPITALS ARE
CONTROLLED ENVIRONMENT AND THUS
THERE'S NO NEED FOR PRESUMPTION
FOR WORKERS IN THE HOSPITAL
ENVIRONMENT OR SETTING I OVER
DATA DO NOT SUPPORT THIS
ARGUMENT AS OF YESTERDAY
CALIFORNIA LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS HAVE REPORTED A
HUNDRED THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR CONFIRMED POSITIVE
NOVEL CORONAVIRUS TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN CASES AND FOUR HUNDRED
AND THIRTY NINE DEATHS IN
NURSES AND HEALTHCARE WORKERS
IN THIS BIGGER INCLUDES. ON THE
JOB EXPOSURES. ADDITIONALLY
MANY WHO OPPOSE THIS MEASURE
STATE THAT THERE'S A COMPLETE
LACK OF EVIDENCE THAT THE
CURRENT PROCESS IS NOT WORKING.
AND THERE'S NO DATA TO SUGGEST
TO DEMONSTRATE THAT WORKERS
COMP CLAIMS HAVE BEEN DENIED.
NEVERTHELESS OUR MEMBERS REPORT
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES WITH ACCESS
TO THE WORKERS COMPENSATION
SYSTEM. DATA FROM WORKERS
COMPENSATION CARRIERS DO NOT
CAPTURE MANY INSTANCES WHERE
NURSES DO NOT EVEN FILE REPORTS
COMPLAINTS. BECAUSE THE SYSTEM
IS SO BURDENSOME OR WHEN
EMPLOYER TELLS A NURSE THAT
THEIR INJURY WAS NOT
SUFFICIENTLY WORK RELATED AND
THEREFORE DO NOT FILE.
EMPLOYERS OFTEN TELL NURSES TO
YOU THE ONLY PAID SICK LEAVE
AND OTHER TIME INSTEAD OF
APPROVAL USING. THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM. ENCLOSING
IT IS EVIDENT THAT HEALTHCARE
WORKERS SUCH AS NURSES ARE
INDEED ON THE FRONT LINES AND
MANY OF THE SAME RISK PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICERS. IT'S NOT
ENOUGH JUST TO COOK PROCLAIM
THAT NURSES ARE HEROES LET'S
PUT ACTION TO WORDS TODAY BY
MODERNIZING. OUTDATED
CALIFORNIA LAW. EASIER FOR NOW
IN HEALTH CARE WORKERS TO THE
WORKERS COMP YOU JUST.
ACCORDING THEY RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON S. B. TWO
ONE THREE TODAY AND I'M
AVAILABLE FOR TEN THE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AND AS MENTIONED ALSO
WE HAVE A REGISTERED NURSE
CATHERINE DONOHUE YOU'RE ON THE
LINE TO TESTIFY OR EXPERIENCE
WITH EXCEPTIONAL WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER LANG
WILL MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT
MISS CATHERINE DONOHUE. YES I'M
HERE PLEASE GO AHEAD MA'AM
HELLO THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU-
SENATORS- THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING ME WITH THE TIME
SHARE MY EXPERIENCE AS AN
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT NURSE A
LONG TIME IN BECOMING INFECTED
WITH METHICILLIN RESISTANT
STAPH AUREUS BETTER BETTER
KNOWN AS MRSA INFECTION. AT
WORK AND HOW THIS EXPERIENCE
INTERFACED WITH THE WORK PART
WORKERS COMPENSATION INSURANCE
AGENT WHO DECIDED MY
ELIGIBILITY BY WORKED TWELVE TO
FOURTEEN HOUR SHIFTS IN SAINT
JOSEPH HOSPITAL I SEE YOU. TEN
HOURS INTO A SHIFT FOR THE
UMPTEENTH TIME I WASHED MY
HANDS NOTICING THE STINGING
BURNING SENSATION IN ONE OF MY
FINGERS CUTICLE. PACKAGE MY
SHIFT WENT HOME HAD DINNER AND
PAIN IN MY FINGER WOKE ME UP IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT AND
BEFORE MORNING MY FINGER WAS
VERY TIGHT SWOLLEN TO TWICE ITS
NORMAL SIZE EXTREMELY PAINFUL
AND OBVIOUSLY IN TROUBLE WITH
THE FAST EVOLVING INFECTION.
PRESENTED EARLY IN THE MORNING
THE NEXT MORNING TO THE SAINT
JOSEPH HOSPITAL URGENT CARE FOR
IMMEDIATE TREATMENT LANSING OF
THE WOUND AND ANTIBIOTICS WITH
GOOD RESULTS OVER THE NEXT
WEEK. I FILED A WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIM NEXT I
RECEIVED A PHONE CALL FOR
INTERVIEW WITH THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION INSURANCE EGYPT
ALONG WITH THE PERSONAL
QUESTIONS WERE ASKED ABOUT MY
PERSONAL LIFE WHICH INCLUDED
ASKING IF I HAD THAT. PERHAPS
DOGS. I HAVE A DOG THAT LIVED
OUT. NOT IN HOUSE. RESULTS OF
THIS INNER RETURN TO THE I
PRESUME. GO INSTRUCTION FROM
DOG. AND MY WORKMAN COMP AND
CLAIM MEDINA. NURSE AND HEALTH
AND- WHO TO PATIENT CARE A
HOSPITAL SETTING OUR FRONTLINE
PROFESSIONALS. WHO RISK THEIR
LIVES DAILY AS IT IS BEING
SHOWN DURING THIS CALL BUT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. RATE IN
CARRYING WORKERS DESERVE THE
PROTECTION OF PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY FOR WORKER'S
COMPENSATION WITHOUT THE NEED
TO BATTLE IN INSURANCE INDUSTRY
THAT CHOOSING TO LEAVE FEMALE
DOMINATED PROFESSIONS. WITHOUT
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY WORKERS
COMPENSATION COVERAGE. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND
CONSIDERATION IN THIS IMPORTANT
MATTER AND ENCOURAGE A YES VOTE
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM. THERE WILL
BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. HAVE ANY HELP. LIVING ON
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
THIRTEEN. C. NINE. THANK YOU
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WANTING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICES
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
THIRTEEN WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
THIRTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE FOUR QUEUED UP.
NINE THREE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE MOMENT PLEASE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MITCH STRIKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO EXPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE THREE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. VENTURE
MEMBERS CHRISTY VALVE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE THREE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS PAT
WHALEN HELLO SMALL STEP TO SEE
ON BEHALF OF UNITED NURSES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA YOU
KNACK IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE ONE HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING CHEN MEMBERS
JACQUI GRAHAM ALL WITH GST W.
WESTERN STATE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AND ACUTE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
KEY PLACE CHECK THE LINES ONE
MORE TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL THE- M.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
THIRTEEN PLEASE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
THIRTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WILL
NOT FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION. LET'S
MOVE TO ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO OH THREE.
FOURTEEN NINE OUR THIRTY
WITNESSES INTO IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION UP SB TWO THIRTEEN.
SEEN ON. THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFIED YET THE
TELECONFERENCE ARTISTS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION SB TWO
THIRTEEN. PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MODERATOR
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY ONE THING
I DO HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION-
WITNESS BY THE NAME OF RUNNING
VERDUGO IS RUNNING FOR TO GO ON
THE LINE. OR RICH REYNOLDS.
RICH REYNOLDS IS ON THE LINE.
CAN RUN A DIRTY GROUPS ON THE
LINE. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON CAN
YOU HEAR ME THIS IS RON VERTIGO
YES SIR PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
OKAY THANK YOU GOOD GOOD ACTING
MANAGER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RUNNING PRETTY GOOD
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. I'LL BE TURNING
OVER THE REMAINDER OF MY TIME
GEORGE REYNOLDS WITH PROMINENT.
WHO WILL BE ARGUING THIS- SO
WITH THAT REGISTER ONLINE
OPPORTUNITY YOU I THINK YOU ARE
CHAIR MEMBERS. CALLING PEOPLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YES HELLO
YES GOOD EVENING MA'AM CURRENT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON SB
TWO THIRTEEN MY NAME IS RICK
ROMANO FOR DIRECTOR OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION INJURY PREVENTION
AND ERGONOMICS FOR THE PROBLEM
ABOUT THE- FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE TO ALL
FRONTLINE CAREGIVERS. AND
COMPASSIONATE CARE TO PATIENTS
DURING THE CALL WITH NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. PROBLEMS HAVE A RICH
HISTORY OF SERVING COMMUNITY
THE NEED FOR A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE YEARS AND STILL
SERVES THE MISSION AND TENS OF
OUR FOUNDING SISTERS. TO ANSWER
CALL TO SERVE THE SAFETY AND
WELL BEING OF OUR VALUE CARE
GIVERS IS ALWAYS OF THE UTMOST
IMPORTANCE. WE HAVE ABOUT
SYSTEMS IMPROPER COOPER TRAIN
AND PROVIDE NECESSARY EQUIPMENT
FOR BOTH SAFETY OF OUR CARE
GIVERS. AND PATIENTS THAT WE
SERVE EVERY DAY. THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ANOTHER
JURISDICTIONS. IN THE NO FAULT
SYSTEM OF ALREADY DESIGNED AND
WELL EQUIPPED TO PROVIDE
COVERAGE FOR AND MANAGE
WORKPLACE INJURIES. ILLNESSES
AND EXPOSURES THAT ARE INDEED
WALKWAY THAT. CANCEL THERE IS A
HIGH ACCEPTANCE RATE FOR MANY
OF THE INJURIES AND ALMOST OF
THE CORRECT AN F. B. TWO
THIRTEEN. AND OTHERS AWARE
WE'LL EVER CLAIMED. AT SOME
POINT RELATED. OUR EMPLOYMENT.
PROBLEMS HAVE 90% OF CLAIMS.
REMARKABLE SKILL INTO HAVE
ACCEPTED ALL CLAIM FOR WHAT AND
DISEASE. AN APPEALS PROCESS
COMPUTER ASSEMBLY DIFFERENT
WITH A CO BECAUSE THEN I DON'T
COMP CLAIM AND THAT PROPERTY
HEARD AND ULTIMATELY RULED UPON
BY THE CALIFORNIA DIVISION OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION. 75% OF
THE HOSPITALS IN THE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA RECALL CREATURE. I'M
PRESUMPTION LAWS THAT UNDERMINE
THE CONTENT AND THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION FROM OPEN ONLY
INCREASES COSTS FOR SELF
INSURED EMPLOYERS. THANK RECALL.
ACTOR ABILITY TO SERVE AND
PROVIDE NECESSARY HEALTHCARE
CALL COMMUNITIES IN THE ANIMAL
COLMOBIL IN OUR SOCIETY. THE
PROPOSAL LANGUAGE CONTAINED
WITHIN A FEW KEY THIRTEEN THE
CUSTOMER UNNECESSARY AND
UNDERMINES THE PREMISE AND THE
WINNING A MEDICAL CONDITIONS
PROBABLY RELATED TO EMPLOYMENT
AND WORK RELATED BROWN'S WITHIN
THE SCOPE OF THE LAW.
RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE SB. TWO
THIRTEEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THAT I BELIEVE
CONCLUDES BOTH OF THE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION- WE WILL DOWN
MORE I'M SORRY. FOR MORE SORRY
FOR THE SATE COMMANDER SECOND
TESTIMONY ON THE BILL. OKAY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
STATE CALMLY WITH LOS ANGELES
COUNTY THE COUNTY OPERATES FIVE
PUBLIC HOSPITALS THE EMPLOYEE
ABOUT SEVENTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
IN THE HOSPITAL. WE 54% OF
THOSE EMPLOYEES PROVIDE DIRECT
PATIENT CARE. AND LOWER
COMPULSIVELY TO FULLY REALIZE
THE EXACT COST TO THE COUNTY
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PRESUMPTION
THAT WOULD BE ESTABLISHED BY SB
TWO THIRTEEN. WE CONSERVATIVELY
PROJECTED COSTS ARE MADE BY
USING DATA FROM POPULATION TO
WHICH SOME OF THESE
PRESUMPTIONS ALREADY APPLY IN
OUR- IN OUR COUNTY SUCH
INSPIRING SURE DEPARTMENT. WELL
AS WE CAN CLAIMS DATA FROM OUR
OWN ACTUARIAL STUDIES.
ACCORDINGLY ARE CONSIDERED AN
ESTIMATED TO THE COUNTY FOR
CANCER PRESUMPTION FOR THIS
POPULATION EMPLOYEES WOULD BE
ABOUT EIGHT MILLION TO TEN
MILLION PER YEAR. AND INCREASE
OVERALL WORKERS COMP UNFUNDED
LIABILITY BY ABOUT FORTY EIGHT
MILLION TO SIXTY MILLION PER
YEAR. HE MUST IF IT WAS A
LITTLE PRESUMPTION WILL
CONSERVATIVELY INCREASED COST
TO THE COUNTY BY THE MILLION A
YEAR AND INCREASE OUR OVERALL
UNFUNDED LIABILITY BY THIRTY
EIGHT POINT FOUR MILLION. AND
THEN THE ADDITIONAL
PRESUMPTIONS THAT ARE INCLUDED
IN THE BILL WILL INCREASE OUR
ANNUAL WORK COMP COSTS BY A ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION PER YEAR.
AND INCREASE UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES BY NINE MILLION PER
YEAR. OUR COUNTY LOS ANGELES
COUNTY HAS BEEN COMMITTED TO
THE FAIR EQUITABLE AND
EXPEDITIOUS RESOLUTION OF WORK
COMP CLAIMS ISSUES. ARE BUT WE
BELIEVE SB TWO THIRTEEN WOULD
EXPOSE. THE COUNTY AND ALL
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
EXPENSES. ARE PROVIDING CARE
FOR THE INCLUDED CONDITIONS
WHEN THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT
THE EMPLOYEES WORK IT'S LIKELY
COSTS. SO PLEASE ENTER THE WORD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR.
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO THIRTEEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS HOLLY
AND DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
CALLERS MODERATOR IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. TWO THIRTEEN. WE DO
HAVE. TEN IN THE COMMENT QUEUE
WAITING TO COMMENT. I BELIEVE
RIGHT NOW WE'VE COMPLETED THE
LEAD OPPOSITION AT KEY WITNESS
SAYS WE ARE NOT GOING TO
PROCEED WITH THAT- MEMBERS IN
THE QUEUE- WITH JUST THEIR NAME
THEIR AFFILIATION THEIR AGENCY
AND THEIR- THEIR OPPOSITION.
NINE THREE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING JOHNSON CLAIRE ABOUT-THE SCRIPT HELD IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWENTY NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THEY PARTED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITIES BECAUSE
MINOR COMMENTS WITHOUT THE NEXT.
RESPECTFULLY ABOUT. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE THREE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MELISSA HI DO
ON BEHALF OF MEMORIALCARE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. TWENTY THREE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MEGAN LOPER ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED HOSPITALIZATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE NUMBER TO COMPLEMENT
ON BEHALF OF CEDAR SINAI
MEDICAL CENTER IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AT J. WALTER ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION ON
WORKERS COMPENSATION AND PUBLIC
RISK INNOVATION SOLUTIONS AND
MANAGEMENT IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EIGHTEEN GIVEN THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE THREE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
I AM WORKING WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE FIFTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING RAIN TO THE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES THEN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. PINE TO FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING THIS IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND OPPOSITION TO SDG
THIRTEEN WHICH WE HAVE TAG AS A
JOB KILLER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE THREE THIRTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS YOUR MARTIN WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE THREE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ERAKAT ON
BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
THREE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. DO YOU
NAME YOUR MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q. WATER IT
WOULD YOU MIND CHECKING THE
LINES ONE MORE TIME TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE. HEARD FROM
ALL THE I WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO THIRTEEN
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWO THIRTEEN. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR. THANK YOU TO ALL OUR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL NOT BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO OUR MEMBERS. ANY
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS BY OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I GUESS I
JUST WANT TO- ADD TO CREATE
WHOSE COMMENTS IT WAS MAYBE IT
WAS- THE REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
CNA BUT I DO THINK THIS IS A-
GENDER PARITY THE ISSUE. OF
THERE ARE NUMEROUS OTHER-
SECTORS OF CAREERS WERE- THAT
ARE PREDOMINATELY MEN AND- I
BLESSED BECAUSE THEY SHOULD
HAVE ALL THOSE KINDS OF
PROTECTIONS BUT I REALLY DO
THINK WE GOTTA FIGURE OUT. EVEN
WITH ALL THE ECONOMICS AT STAKE
WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT- THESE- HOSPITAL
WORKERS PRIMARILY WOMEN- GET
THE- PROTECTION THAT THEY NEED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. WITH THAT- SENATOR
PER TRACY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I WANNA THANK
EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED
TESTIFIED TODAY AND FOR THE
TENSION- TO SOME OF THE ISSUES
HERE CLEANEQUITY BUT I THINK I
THINK ALTERNATELY S. B.
THIRTEEN IS VERY SIMPLE. BUT
WORKERS COMPENSATION WAS
CREATED. FOR ONE PURPOSE TO
ENSURE THAT WORKERS WHO ARE
INJURED OR BECOME ILL TO WORK
PROPERLY AND FULLY CARED FOR.
AND THAT EMPLOYERS ARE HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR MAINTAINING A
SAFE AND HEALTHY WORK
ENVIRONMENT. THIS BILL. DOESN'T
GUARANTEE ANYONE A CLAIM IT
JUST SHOWS THE PRESUMPTION. OF
IN THE SAME MANNER. AS OTHER OF
FRONTLINE WORKERS- AND- I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU CENTER CORTESE DO YOU HAVE
A MOTION ON SB TWO THIRTEEN. I
MOVED. OVER THE MOTION WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR TORONTO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT BEFORE BEING RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
CORTEZ HI CENTER CORTESE II
CENTER OCHO BOOK. SENDER OCHO
BOGUE NO SENATOR DORADO.
SENATOR DORADO HI SENATOR LAYER
TO OUR SENATOR LAYERED HI
SENATOR NEWMAN AYE SENATOR
NEWMAN AYE THE COUNT IS FOUR TO
ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
BILL IS OUT WITH A. FOUR TO
ONE. LARA PASSED THE GAVEL BACK
TO SENATOR CORTEZ THE. THANK
YOU MARY BYE SURE FOR PRESIDING
ALSO- ADDITIONALLY FREE SHOULD
VERY MUCH AND- UP LITERALLY UP
AGAINST THE CLOCK HERE WE'RE
GOING TO TRY TO. FINISH OUR
AGENDA TODAY EQUALLY AS
OFFICIALLY. MAYBE ACTUALLY GIRL
WITH YOU- THE- THANK CENTER
CONSOLE IS. TO PROVE TO AN S.
B. SIX OH SO SEVEN SALAS YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK REST CHAIR
AND MEMBER- AND LABOR COMMITTEE
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL SIX OH SIX WHICH
CODIFIES PARTS OF THE FEDERAL
OSHA'S POLICY FOR GREGIS
EMPLOYERS GIVING CAL OSHA THE
AUTHORITY TO IMPLODE IMPOSE
ADDITIONAL PENALTIES ON
EMPLOYERS FOR WILLFUL
VIOLATIONS WERE WORKERS HAVE
BEEN KNOWINGLY HARMED. BY
FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH HEALTH
AND SAFETY LAWS SB SIX OH SIX
BUILD OFF OF FEDERAL OSHA'S
CORPORATE WIDE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT POLICY BY PROVIDING
CAL OSHA WITH THE AUTHORITY TO
ISSUE A SUSPENSION OR TEMPORARY
RESTRAINING ORDER AT ALL
LOCATIONS UNDER COMMON
OWNERSHIP WANTED EMPLOYERS
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
DIRECTLY VIOLATE LABOR AND
HEALTH AND SAFETY SAFETY
STANDARDS. AS A FORMER CHAIR OF
THE SENATE SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY RESPONSE I
HELD AN OVERSIGHT MEETING LAST
YEAR ON WORKPLACE SAFETY HEALTH
AND SAFETY ISSUES DURING THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC
SPECIFICALLY LOOKING AT. THE
ROLE OF ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHAT
WE LEARNED THAT CAL OSHA HAS
BEEN INUNDATED WITH MORE
COMPLAINTS AND THERE CAN
INSPECTORS CAN HANDLE. LEADING
STAFF TO INCREASINGLY RELY ON
LETTER ONLY INVESTIGATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN INSUFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVELY. PROTECTING FRONT
LINE WORKERS. SB SIX OF SIX
PROVIDES HELLO SHE WITH THE
NECESSARY TOOLS TO MAXIMIZE THE
USE OF THEIR LIMITED RESOURCES
SO THEY'RE ABLE TO RESPOND MORE
EFFECTIVELY. FOR THE MORE IT
ESTABLISHES A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION FOR RETALIATION
THAT WILL PROTECT WORKERS WHO
COME FORWARD WITH A POSITIVE
COVER NINETEEN TEST. WORKERS
WHO REQUESTED TESTER PP AND
THOSE WHO REPORT UNSAFE
CONDITIONS IF WORKERS ARE NOT
CONFIDENT THEY WILL BE
PROTECTED FROM RETALIATION THEY
WILL BE LESS LIKELY TO COME
FORWARD AND REPORT VIOLATIONS.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY I
HAVE THE JAZZY GREAT WALL
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR U. OF
C. W. WESTERN STATES COUNCIL
AND MITCH TIGER POLICY ADVOCATE
FOR CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
WILL- ATTEMPT CALL MR GREENWALD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GAZI GRAY
WHAT LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR WOULD
UFCW WESTERN STATE COUNCIL YES
HE W. REPRESENT OVER A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA AN AGRICULTURE MEAT
PACKING FOOD PROCESSING GROCERY
STORES GROCERY DELIVERY
PHARMACEUTICAL AND RETAIL. ALL
OF THEM HAVE BEEN DEEMED
FRONTLINE ASSEMBLY WORKERS
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC YOUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE MEMBERS ROSE
TO THE OCCASION AND PUT THEIR
AND THEIR FAMILIES HEALTH AND
SAFETY ON THE LINE.
CALIFORNIANS ARE MEMBERS HAVE
SUFFERED IMMEASURABLE LOSS IN
TERMS OF THE NINETEEN THEY
WALKED FAMILY MEMBERS CO
WORKERS AND FRIENDS THEY WATCH
FRIENDS STILL SUFFERING DAY IN
AND DAY OUT FROM LINGERING
SOMETIMES. A HARVARD UNIVERSITY
STUDY FOUND THAT ONE IN FIVE
GROCERY WORKERS TESTED POSITIVE
FOR CO THE NINETEENTH AND
WORKERS WHO INTERACT WITH
CUSTOMERS ARE FIVE TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO TEST POSITIVE. I
BELIEVE FORTINET PANDEMIC AND
LOOK BACK AT WHAT COULD HAVE
BEEN DONE BETTER YOU RECOGNIZE
THAT COALITION IS SEVERELY
UNDERSTAFFED AND UNDER REPORT
AND LACK THE NECESSARY TOOLS TO
HOLD LARGE EMPLOYERS AND TRAIN
EMPLOYERS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
KEEPING WORKERS SAFE ON THE
JOB. CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
PERMIT COLORS RIGHT TO LEVY
FINES OR OTHER REMEDIES AT THE
VISION. FIVE OR CONSEQUENCE-
DEADLY CONDUCT LOGICAL. MAKING
FORCE BUT NEEDLESS DUPLICATE
EVIDENCE. AND SHALL NOT THE
CREDIT ROLE COMP PLAY AND THE
APPS TRIED THAT. AND PRIORITIZE
WORKERS BY. THIS IS WHY WE NEED
A SIX SIX. THANK YOU CENTER
GUMBALL FOR ALL LOCAL AND- SB
SIX SIX SEVEN ASSEMBLY JUST
RAISE CAO SEX. DID FOR THE
PLAYERS. I THINK THE TARGETED A
PRO TO RAISE PENALTY FOR LARGE
EMPLOYERS. SERVING AS A REAL
INCENTIVE EMPLOYERS TO
VOLUNTARILY COMPLY WITH. HEALTH
AND SAFETY STANDARDS. I HAVE
SEEN RECORD BREAK PROFITS DROP
THE DOWN THE- AND THE CURRENT
PENALTY STRUCTURE KNOCKED OF AS
A- FOR BEING. BUT RATHER THE
CALL OF DOING. I DID KALLUS NOT
HAS TOLD EXISTS LOCAL TRAIN
ACCOUNTABLE. WHEN EMPLOYERS IN
PART OF- CHRIS. ARE INTO
VIOLATION OF HEALTH AND BEAT
YOUR- AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC COLORS TO ISSUE
INDUSTRY GUIDANCE THAT
PROHIBITED WORKERS. FROM
HANDLING REUSABLE BACK. ARCHING
GROCERY EMPLOYER AND ADDRESS
POLICY AFTER TO HANDLE REDUCE
CLASS. AND DRAG CONTRADICTION
OF THE OR- READ MORE ANOTHER
LARGE CHAIN DRUG RETAILING. IT
SHOULD WRITTEN POLICY THAT THEY-
WORKERS ARE WORKING SIDE BY
SIDE AN INDIVIDUAL WHO TESTED
POSITIVE FOR CARBON NINETEEN
ANYTHING YOU WORK CAN CONTINUE
WORKING BACK. NOT WHAT THE NINE
NINETY FIVE MASK BUT A CALL
BACK INDIRECT VIOLATION OF
QUARANTINING REQUIREMENTS. IF
POLICY RESULTED IN WORKERS
COMING TO WORK ALL POSITIVE
WITH KEVIN NINETEEN AND
INFECTING OTHER WORKERS. HELLO
NEED TOOLS LIKE COMPANYWIDE
ABATEMENT TO THE STAND BY TO
WEAR POLICIES ALTERNATELY
STATING WORKERS AND THE PUBLIC
Y. WE WORK WITH THE DETAILS
THEY'VE BEEN COMING FORWARD
WITH HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUES
RELATED TO COVER NINETEEN.
WITHOUT FEAR OF RETALIATION
ANOTHER LARGE GROCERY CHAIN WE
RECEIVED REPORTS THAT WORKERS
ARE REPORTING POSITIVE THANK
YOUNG TECH TO THE EMPLOYERS.
WHO THEN ASKED THE WORKERS TO
TAKE TWO WEEKS TO QUARANTINE
UPON THE WORKERS ARE TRYING TO
TRACE THE CHAIN TOLD WORKERS
THEY WERE GONE FROM THEIR JOBS
FOR TOO LONG AND FIRED THEM
WITHOUT PAY DURING THE
QUARANTINE. SB SIX SX WILL
ENSURE THAT WORKERS ARE SCARED
TO REPORT POSITIVE BECAUSE THE
NINETEEN TAX OUR HEALTH AND
SAFETY VIOLATIONS TO THEIR
EMPLOYER. OUT OF FEAR OF
RETALIATION. ALI ASIAN FOR
LOWER WORKERS BUT AND THERE.
GOING HUNGRY. THEY AND BEING
ACOSTA. OR THE THREAT OF HOW
BUT ANY. SB SIX DECKS OF CARDS
TO OUR ARE. YOU MUST LOVE
SPREAD AND ADDITIONAL OUTBREAK
IF WE HAVE HOPE OF RETURNING
NORMAL FOR THESE REASONS YOU'RE
RESPECTING REQUEST YOUR IPHONE
ON ANY CASES. THANK YOU
GREENWALD MISTER. BILLABLE WE
SERVE ENCOURAGE GRAVITY AND
REMARKS THANK YOU. CERTAINLY
THANK YOU MISTER BURKE IMAGE SO
WITH THE CAL LABOR FOR PRODUCT
SPONSOR THE BILL ALONG WITH YOU
YOU TO BE IN SAFE WATER BRIEFLY
TOUCH SOME OF THE THAT WERE
TAKE THE WAYS THAT THOSE
ADDRESS SOME OF THE OPPOSITION.
THE FIRST IS THAT THE OPPOSITE
THAT STATED THAT THERE WERE A
THAT NOTHING IN THE BILL IS
COVERED SPECIFIC WE ARE RESPOND
BY SPECIAL THAT REPORT
PRESUMPTION OVERTIME. IS
COVERED NINETEEN SPECIFIC THE
OPPOSITION HAS ALSO ARGUED THAT
THE AGREE JUST EMPLOYER SECTION
IS EXCESSIVE AND WILL SHUT DOWN
BUSINESSES WE ARE TAKING A
MYSTIC CLARIFY THAT SECTION
ONLY APPLIES TO CERTAIN TYPES
OF WILLFUL VIOLATIONS WHICH ARE
THEMSELVES INCREDIBLY RARE
BECAUSE QALISYA HAS TO PROVE
INTENT WHICH IS ALMOST ALWAYS
SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN'T DO SO
IT SHOULD BE A VERY TINY NUMBER
NUMBER OF EMPLOYERS THAT THIS
ACTUALLY APPLIES TO. WERE ALSO
TAKEN MOMENTS THAT WILL CLARIFY
THE SECTION THAT ALLOWS CAL
OSHA THE SITE THE STATUTE ONLY
APPLIES TO LABOR CODE DIVISION
FIVE AND A CERTAIN HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE RELATED TO WORKER
HEALTH AND SAFETY BECAUSE-
RIGHT NOW QALISYA CAN ONLY
ENFORCE TITLE EIGHT REGULATIONS
SO. FLANK WHICH WILL ALLOW
LEGISLATION IS APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE ENFORCED
RIGHT NOW WITH BILLS BECOME
STATUTE MAY RELATE TO WORKER
HEALTH AND SAFETY THERE'S
REALLY NO ONE THERE TO ENFORCE
THEM IT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT
TOOL FOR YOU ALL TO HAVE. IN
THE FINAL POINT IS THAT THE
OPPOSITION IS ARGUED THAT
CITATION SHOULDN'T BE ALLOWED
TO WEAR IN PERSON INSPECTIONS
HAVEN'T HAPPENED. THEY ARE THEY
ALREADY ARE BUT WHAT THE BILL
DOES IS CODIFY THE PRACTICE
WHILE THE AMENDMENTS WILL
CLARIFY THE DUE PROCESS THE
COLLEGE A HOUSE TO ENGAGE AND
BEFORE FINALIZING A CITATION
THINGS LIKE SUBPOENAING WERE-
WRITTEN RECORDS GETTING
DECLARATIONS FROM WORKERS
THINGS LIKE THAT SO. HOPEFULLY
THOSE HELP DEAL WITH SOME OF
THEIR CONCERNS BUT OVERALL IT'S
AN INCREDIBLY. IMPORTANT BILL
AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT. YOU
WERE EXPECTED TO HEAR ANOTHER-
LEAD WITNESS ON THE BILL NOW MR
CHIU. THAT OF THEM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT. WE
WILL- IMPROVE TO COMMITTEE IN
OUR IF THERE ARE ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON THE BILL HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHICH LIKE
WHO'D LIKE TO COME FORWARD. THE
SCENE NINE WAS THE SAME FOR
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. C. NINE WILL
GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE
MODERATOR. IN ASKING TO QUEUE
UP ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES ON SB
SIX OH SIX- WE WILL BE HAPPY TO
HEAR THEIR NAME THEIR
AFFILIATION. AND THEIR SUPPORT
POSITION IF THAT'S THE CASE.
AND PLEASE LET US KNOW HOW MANY
THERE ARE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX OH SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE NINE IN THE-
COMING Q. WITH A FEW MORE
JOINING. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
CLICK WE DO HAVE ELEVEN. OUR
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM NINE
THREE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS LOUIS
CUSTOM OF THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SHEET METAL AIR
RAIL AND TRANSPORTATION WORKERS
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX OH SIX
THANK YOU. NINE TO SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS-
JUSTIN ROWS- ON BEHALF OF ROUTE
TO CHANGE AS WELL AS ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIX OH SIX THANK YOU. MY
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHEN MEMBERS
WHO SHALL GO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS TERAFLOPS ON
BEHALF OF THE TRANSPORT WORKERS
UNION AFL-CIO IN SUPPORT. NINE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BETTER HEARING
MEMBERS KILLER JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. BY NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE TERM EMBERS JESSICA
CENTER ON BEHALF OF EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANYWAY BUT THIS YEAR YOU
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. NINE THREE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEP OF THE AND WITH
THE ADDED ON BEHALF OF LEGAL
AID AT WORK IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THAT VEHICLE. NINE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THIRTY YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BERMAN BONTA NINE
THREE FOURTEEN POINT THREE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO DEAR
MEMBERS MINUS CALL QUERY WITH
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL SIX OH SIX. NINE
THREE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS EVER MENTION WITH PLACES FOR
PROGRESS CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS IMPORTANT BILL. NINE THREE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI DAISY
GONZALEZ WITH THE GARMENT THE
CENTRE IMPOSSIBLE. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE WILL-
MOVE OVER TO THE OPPOSITION
SIDE ANDERSON AS A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS SO I'M FROM
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IF YOU'RE THERE YOU MAY PROCEED.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR CAN
YOU HEAR ME ALRIGHT YES VERY
WELL YOU MAY PROCEED- PUTS
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. YES OF
COURSE ROBERT MCCREE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE- AND WE ARE
OPPOSED TO SB ACOUSTICS AS A
JOB KILLER APOLOGIES FOR THE
JUGULAR TECH NOT BEING OUR
PARLIAMENT COMMITTEE WE
TERMINATIONS WERE MADE THIS
WEEKEND SO WE WANT TO BE CLEAR
AND SHOULD BE RELEASED EARLIER
TAX- I SHOULD ALSO NOTE THAT I
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF A COALITION
OF MORE THAN. FORTY EMPLOYER
GROUPS TO CHOOSE MEASURES BUT
THE FINISH THE LETTER WHICH I'M
GLAD IT COMPLAIN POOR- THEY'RE
NOT REFLECTED IN OUT THAT BUT
I'D LIKE TO MAKE CLEAR WE ARE
IN BY NO MEANS ALONE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT SB SIX OF SIX
IS TAXED- I LOOK AT THANK STAFF
FOR THEIR ANALYSIS- I DON'T
LIKE TO THANK THE- THANK. A
SPONSOR MAKING. THAT THEY ARE
HEADED NOT. IF YOU- I WANT TO.
THAT THE PRESENT. WHAT ARE JOB.
I GET THE- WE HAVE. BEEN CHAU
AMENDMENT- IT IN NO WAY TO COLD
AND THE- IT. TO JUST A- BY THE
BONTRAGER WOMEN IT. THREE OF
THE BILL IN THE WHAT THE WHAT.
ONE AND TWO WHICH ARE QUESTIONS.
WITH BE ANYWAY TIED TO COPE IT.
SO MOVING FOR- I WOULD BE GREAT
CLEAR WE'RE NOT IN NO WAY. KOBE
DAY YOU WE- ACT. TO DO. THE
CALL NINETY ETF. AND WITH
TELEVISION THAT FRONT PUBLIC.
IT GERMAN. AND IS DURING THE
STAY THE ARE UP HERE IN. ABOUT
COULD NINETEEN SIXTY ABOUT THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL-
TURNING TO THE STRUGGLED
MENTIONED BY- ENGINE BY U. S.
P. W. CHATTY- AWANA ONE POINT
THERE OUT CORRECTLY THE THEY
NOTED THAT THE COALITION
STRUGGLED OF COURSE BEEN HERE
BEEN HAVE BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED BY
CALLOUS ADD MEETING AS RELATED
TO. STAFFING ISSUES WHICH
FRANKLY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ALREADY ADDRESSES CALLAGY IS
ALREADY RECEIVING MORE MONEY
AND ARE JUST BUILT ON THOSE
LONG TERM STAFFING ISSUES THIS
BILL WOULD NOT CHANGE THAT THEY
SHOULD THE BILL WILL NOT FIX
THE STAFFING ISSUES AND NOTHING
TO DO WITH THEM IS WHAT MAKES
YOUR SEPARATE ON WHAT WE'RE.
ACTUALLY DEALING WITH YOUR- TO
GET TO THE D. SPECS ONE WITH.
FIND ON. WILL BE. BY NORWEGIAN
TO AND- AS YOU A HUNDRED TIMES.
EVEN THAT THE SCALE CAL. OR HAS
MODIFIERS FOR THE CAR HIT THE
VIOLATION WHICH EXCEED OTHER
STATES. INCLUDING A FIVE TIMES
MULTIPLIER FOR WILLFUL
VIOLATIONS UP TO TEN TIMES
MULTIPLIER FOR. VALIDATION AND
OTHERS WE ALSO HAVE CRIMINAL
CODE THAT I WOULD DIRECT THE
ATTENTION HERE TO- LABOR CODE
SIXTY FOUR TWENTY THREE AND
FIFTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL FINES AND JAIL TIME.
FOR WILLFUL VIOLATOR SO.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY LEADING THE
WAY HERE WE DON'T SEE. A
MULTIPLIER ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
TIMES TO BE. TO BE A PRO GIVEN
OR ALREADY ON TOP OF THAT. IN
ADDITION I'D LIKE TO DEAL WITH
THE ISSUE THAT THE MENTION THAT
THIS IS TARGETED TO LARGER
EMPLOYERS. WE'RE NOT BE ANY
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL WHICH IN
ANY WAY LIMITED APPLICATIONS.
AND ARE READ ALL THREE OF THE
PARISIAN REPLIED TO ACCEPT
MAYBE SECTION TWO WHICH MIGHT
NOT BUT IT TWO EMPLOYEES. OF A
BUSINESS OR FIND EMPLOYEE
BUSINESS WOULD BE COVERED HERE
THERE'S NO LIMITATION BY
THOUGHT. AFTER THE PRESUMPTIONS
OVER THE MULTIPLIER- I WILL
PEOPLE PROTECTION TWO BECAUSE
THE- I APPRECIATE THE COMMENT
REGARDING LIMITING THAT USED
CERTAIN AREAS OF THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE LABOR CODE. BUT I
WILL SAY THAT THE IDEA THAT THE
REGULATORY PROCESS. IS NOT
HELPFUL IN COMING TO THE
DETAILS THAT ARE HELPFUL IN
TAKING. WE THINK THAT BEEN
CORRECT GETTING. EXPERT HELLO
CHAU LABOR AND BUSINESS IN A
ROMAN. BY HAMMERING OUT TERMS
THAT ARE APPLICABLE TO
WORKPLACES WEEDING IS AN
IMPORTANT PROCESS AND THIS BILL
WOULD CHORE AT THAT WHICH IS
CONCERNING TO US. ACTION THREE
AND THIRD RETALIATION
PROVISIONS TRY TO BE QUICK I
KNOW WE'RE TIGHT ON TIME- EVEN
ON WE NEED MAYBE. EVEN IF THEY
TO COPE AT NINETEEN. I
DUPLICATED OF EXISTING
PROTECTIONS PARTICULARLY. AT
THE LIGHT IF OUR A AND-
PROTECTIONS FOR WORKERS THAT
THINK WE WORKERS ALREADY HAVE.
FULL REPORTING VIOLATIONS
EXISTING LAW OR REGULATION SO
FOR EXAMPLE EMPLOYER VIOLATE
THE CODE IN NINETEEN EDS- AND
REPORTS THAT THEY ARE ALREADY
PROTECTED FROM PUNISHMENT THERE
SO EVERY EMPLOYER IS NOT
PROVIDING THAT. THAT PP. AN
AIRPORT THAT THERE'S THE
PROTECTION THERE SO THAT'S
ALREADY IN PLACE. WHAT WE SEE
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS LANGUAGE
IS REPEATED BACK ENOUGH. THAT
IT WILL CATCH EVEN GOOD PAID
EMPLOYERS TRYING TO TERMINATE
EMPLOYEE TO. BE TERMINATED OR
BOARD TO LET EMPLOYEES GO
BECAUSE THEY'RE HAVING
FINANCIAL DIFFICULTY DUE TO
CALL THE NINETEEN. WE SEE
PRODUCTION CONSIDERING
MITIGATION THOSE CANARIAS- SO I
WILL WRAP UP THERE THANK YOU TO
GET YOU TO BE- AND I. YEAH
THANK YOU FOR THAT- AND WE ARE
CLOSED UNTIL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TENNIS TO- WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE. ON TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO
SB SIX OH SEX. SCENE NO ONE
COME FORWARD WILL GO TO TWENTY
FORTY THAT ROOM. HAS NO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. WHO MOVED
TO THE TELECONFERENCE OPERATOR
THE MODERATORS. AND ASK. YOU TO
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION.
PHYLLIS NO HAN THERE ARE. IN A
REMINDER WE TO HEAR A NAY.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER TURNER
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMAN YOU
WISH COME IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
EUROS PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IF YOU HAVE SIX
IN THE INCOMING QUEUE AT THIS
TIME AND A FEW MORE HAVE JOINED
HOME THANK YOU READ ABOUT.
TWELVE AND OUR FIRST COMMENT
COMES FROM LINE THREE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MEMBERS OF
THE MILLION THE MONEY CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRAVEL ASSOCIATION WE ARE
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MY NINETY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHT
BORDERS ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES RESPECTFULLY ABOUT.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU I AM WORKING WITH THE
EDUCATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. NINE THREE FORTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THREE FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
KIDDING HAMPTON WITH A
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. NINE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO BRIAN
ALLAIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE TO
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
BY LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. NINE THREE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BLOOMBERG WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH FACILITIES AND
OPPOSITION. NINE THREE FORTY
ONE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING COUNTY
BOILED THE NEW STATE FARMERS
LEAGUE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
TWENTY THREE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS JAMIE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATED
GENERAL CONTRACTORS IN
OPPOSITION. NINE THREE TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MELISSA HI DO ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILY WINEMAKERS
CALIFORNIA AND THE WEST DURING
CAR WASHES THE ASIAN IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE
THREE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING WHAT YOU FIGURE HERE
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. NINE
THREE ZERO ONE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS MICHAEL MILLER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF WINE GRAPE GROWERS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NINE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE GORE CARE I WOULDN'T
YOU FOR SUPPORT NOT OPPOSITION
BY A STAFF ATTORNEY WOULD WORK
PHASE- AND WE ARE CLOSED THE
PORT OF THE BILL AND AGAIN
APOLOGIZED FOR THE MISHAP BUT I
JUST. DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
THERE. THANK YOU AND NINE THREE
FORTY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MATTER ALONG WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
ALSO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
THE BILL. AND NINE SIXTY EIGHT.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD EVENING THIS GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
COMMITTEE CHRIS WALKER. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SHEET
METAL AND AIR CONDITIONING
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR ANNA THANK YOU TO ALL
OF THE WITNESSES HAVE TESTIFIED
THE MONTH ON EITHER SIDE OF THE
BILL WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS BILL FOR
MEMBERS COMMITTEE CENTER NEWMAN.
THANK M. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
SO I WILL BE VOTING FOR THIS
BILL TODAY OUT OF DIFFERENCE.
TO THE AUTHOR BUT I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT. PLEASE PUT ON THE
RECORD DATE SEVEN PM- THIS BILL
IS CLEARLY IMPORTANT WE HAVEN'T
GIVEN IT NEARLY ENOUGH- OF THE
ROOM THE ATTENTION INJECTED ITS
DESIRES THIS IS NOBODY'S FAULT
PROBABLY TO FUNCTION THE
PANDEMIC AND ALL RIGHT THANKS.
AND SO I'M HOPEFUL AS THIS
MOVES FOR WE CAN HAVE A DEEPER
SET OF CONVERSATIONS WITH IN
THIS BODY THAT PARTICULAR
AROUND THE OBJECTIONS OF A VERY
LARGE NUMBER OF BUSINESSES- AND
FIND SOMETHING THAT IS CLOSER
TO ACCEPTABLE TO BOTH PARTIES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
AND- MANBIJ SYRIA. I AGREE WITH
AS SENATOR NEWMAN NEXT WEEK
JUST HAVEN'T HAD TIME AND IT'S
KIND OF A CRUNCH BUT JUST A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS ON ON THE
BILL- RIGHT NOW WE ARE
UNDERSTANDING THAT- KELLEHER
RIGHT AS UNDERSTAFFED AND IT
THERE IS A CONCERN THAT RIGHT
NOW WITH THIS BILL THAT WOULD
GIVE IT A NEW AUTHORITY IN
CREATE NEW PENALTIES- AND I'M
JUST KIND OF CURIOUS AS TO HOW
LONG. THIS IS GOING TO MANIFEST
ITSELF- WITH THE REALITY OF
HAVING IN A DEPARTMENT THAT
ALREADY IS UNDERSTAFFED WITH
THAT IN MIND THERE IS ALSO A
HUGE CONCERN ON MY BEHALF AS
FAR AS THE- PENALTIES GO
POTENTIALLY BEING ONE HUNDRED
TIMES HIGHER THAN WHAT IS
CURRENTLY PRESIDENT- AND THE
RISK THAT THIS POSES ON
EMPLOYERS IN GENERAL. SO NOT
ONLY ARE WE HAVING A- YOU KNOW
NEAR THIRTY INCREASE IN
PENALTIES IT'S ALSO INCREDIBLY-
PUNITIVE TOWARDS AGENCIES- IN
THAT RESPECT BT I'LL JUST
LEAVE IT AT THAT END AND JUST
KIND OF CURIOUS IF THE AUTHOR
HAS CONSIDERED WORKING WITH-
ORGANISED THE ORGANIZATIONS ARE
A CONCERN OPPOSITION. TO MAKE
IT. MUCH MORE FRIENDS TO OUR
BUSINESS. IN LIGHT OF COVER
NINETY AND WHAT ARE BUSINESSES
GOING THROUGH RIGHT ASKING
FORWARD IN TRYING TO RESTART
ARE ARE EIGHT NIGHT OUR ECONOMY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU I'M SENATOR- CHOI BOGUE.
YES AND AS AS STATED BY-
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF LABOR
MISTER STRYKER WE ARE GOING TO
BE LOOKING AT TAKING SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT HE INCLUDED.
CLARIFYING THE CRITERIA THAT
WOULD ALLOW CULTURE TO PROPOSE
PROPOSED PENALTIES FOR WILLFUL
CITATIONS. AGAIN A WILLFUL
CITATION IS WHEN YOU'VE GONE TO
THE FARTHEST EXTENT TO BE
NEGLIGENT AND SO THERE'S ONLY A
HANDFUL OF CAL OSHA A WILLFUL
CITATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN. SOLD
OUT IF YOU WILL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO YOU'VE GOT TO BE
PRETTY AGREE JUST TO BE ABLE
TO. GET TO THAT THRESHOLD.
SECONDLY CLARIFYING CAL OSHA'S
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY IS
LIMITED TO THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE A CERTAIN SECTION.
AND DIVISION FIVE OF THE LABOR
CODE SO NOT ALL OF THE LABOR
CODE. WE WOULD ALSO BE
CLARIFYING. THE REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION FOR RETALIATION
WHICH WOULD BE SPECIFIC TO COPE
IT. OKAY I'M GONNA MISS AB NOT
GOOD FOR IT NOT SUPPORT THIS
BILL RIGHT NOW BUT I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THE
AMENDMENTS AND SEEN HOW YOU
WORK WITH THE- THE CONCERNS
WHICH ARE BUSINESS ENVIRONMENT
RIGHT NOW IN LIGHT OF WHAT WE
ARE. BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING HOW EVEN IN THIS BILL
AND THAT HOPEFULLY SUPPORTING
IT AND LATER ON. THANK YOU.
ANYTHING ALSO REMEMBERS. THE
SENATE ROTH. AYE- I REALLY WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR. MEAN WE
ARE IN THE COLD WITH THE
PANDEMIC HERE. AND FOR MEN AND
WOMEN WHO TAKE THE RISK OF
GOING TO WORK. THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO RELY ON THE MOST. THE
STRONGEST PROTECTIONS FOR THEM
THE STRONGEST PROTECTIONS FOR
THEM AND- I JUST THINK THAT-
FOR US. COMPLETELY WRONG
BECAUSE IT'S PRO WORKING MEN
AND WOMEN WHO TAKE THOSE RISK
OF GOING TO WORK EVERY DAY AND
THEY'RE GETTING SICK AND IF WE
HAVE EMPLOYERS WHO SEE WHO SEEM
TO THINK THAT THEY COULD IGNORE
THAT AND- COMMIT REALLY
EGREGIOUS VIOLATIONS OF HEALTH
AND SAFETY DURING A PANDEMIC. I
THINK IT'S SHAMEFUL I JUST
THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY SHAMEFUL
AND TO SAY SOMEHOW. THAT BY-
HOLDEN THESE ARE THE EMPLOYERS
TO COMMIT THESE ACTIONS IN A
VERY NARROW WAY THAT SOMEHOW
WE'RE ANTI BUSINESS I THINK IS.
IS REALLY TWISTING THE WHOLE
NOTION THAT YOU CAN BE PRO
BUSINESS BUT PRO BOWL HEALTH
AND SAFETY ON THE JOB OF THESE
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN JUST PUT
YOURSELF IN THAT SITUATION WE
HAVE TO GO TO WORK AND WE DON'T
HAVE ALL THESE PROTECTIONS WE
DON'T HAVE ALL THESE TESTS WE
DON'T HAVE ALL THESE THINGS
THAT ALLOW US TO COME IN. AND
FEEL SAFE WE DON'T HAVE ANY OF
THAT AND I READ STORY AFTER
STORY OF OUR BUSINESSES AND
EMPLOYERS WHO WORK.
DELIBERATELY IGNORING THE
HEALTH PROTOCOLS- SHUTTING DOWN
ORDERS BY THE COUNTY'S IRAN TO
SHUT DOWN I MEAN THERE'S SOME
REALLY. TERRIBLE THINGS THAT
ARE GOING ON OUT THERE I THINK
WE HAVE TO BE CONSCIOUS AND
PROTECT THOSE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
ARE TAKING THE RISKS ON OUR
BEHALF SO I'M REALLY GLAD THAT
YOU'RE. THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO
IN CENTER CONSOLES WOULD LIKE
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS FOR
ASKING QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
WE CERTAINLY WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS BILL- I JUST WANT
TO GIVE YOU A SNAPSHOT THE
BETWEEN THE AGGREGATE- BOTH THE
IN THE AGGREGATE FOR THE WHOLE
COMMITTEE. IN JUST ONE MONTH
LAST YEAR NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CITATIONS ARE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
CITATIONS WERE DOLED OUT THAT
AFFECTED OVER THREE HUNDRED
PEOPLE JUSTINUS COMMITTEE ALONE
IN PLACES LIKE SAN JOSE SAN
BERNARD DINO. BASELWORLD IS
EAST LA BREA AND IN MY HOME
TOWN SOUTHEAST L. IN LONG BEACH
WE'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING FOR
THESE WORKERS- WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK THROUGH THE PROCESS BUT
AGAIN THIS IS NOT A JOB KILLER
LOOK AT IT IS A LIFE SAVER FOR
MANY YOU KNOW FOLKS THAT WE
REPRESENT. SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE I WANT TO THANK OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS WHO CALLED IN AS
WELL. THE MOTIONS HUNDRED ROWS
OF. SO MOVE. OKAY WE DO HAVE A
MOTION. WILL CALL THE PLEASE.
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY SENATOR
CORTEZ HE- SENATOR CORTEZ III
SENATOR- CHOKE NO. CENTER OCHO
FOLK NOW SENATOR RUSSELL.
SENATOR DORADO AYE SENATOR
LAYERED SENATOR LAYERED ICE
SENATOR NEWMAN SENATOR NEWMAN
AYE. THAT MEASURE IS FOUR TO
ONE. THANK YOU- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN NOTIFIED-
FLAVOR FOR WONDERFUL TEAM HERE
THAT- WE HAVE THE ROOM JUST
LONG ENOUGH I THINK TO HEAR THE
LAST BILL ON OUR AGENDA CENTER
REQUIRES A BILL WHICH IF I- IF
I MAY SAY AS AS A JUROR- IS- A
PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD
PRESENTATION HE ASKED ME TO DO
THAT BUT- OF THE- TEST OF BOYS
CHAIR. TO PRESIDE. IN I THINK
WE COULD MOVE THROUGH FAIRLY
QUICKLY. SENATE. THANK YOU
SENATOR CORTESE I BELIEVE YOUR
TAKING- SB SIX EIGHTY FIVE IS
THAT CORRECT THIS CORRECT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LOOSER ANNOUNCED
THIS MORNING ON THE FOR THAT
CENTER REQUIRES SHOWED AND HIS
WIFE ERICA OR THE PROUD NEW
PARENTS OF A BABY BOY- SO. LET
ME EXPLAIN FOR THOSE LISTENING
AND WHY WE'RE DOING THIS THIS
WAY AND- SO LET ME PRESENT TO
NEARLY A QUARTER OF ALL
CALIFORNIA CLEARS SHIPPED TO
THE FRESH MARKET COME FROM THE
COUNTY OF LAKE. LOCATED NEAR
THE CALIFORNIA LAKE COUNTY
PAIRS ARE KNOWN AS SOME OF THE
BEST IN THE WORLD FOR
GENERATIONS LAKE COUNTY
RESIDENTS HAVE WORKED THE
HARDEST TO ENSURE. THAT THOSE
DELICACIES CAN BE DELIVERED TO
STORE SHELVES RUMINATION WORLD.
BACK IN SEASON LASTS ONLY FOUR
TO SEVEN WEEKS AROUND AUGUST OF
EACH YEAR. THIS IS ONE HARVEST
IS AT ITS PEAK CAN COMPETE WITH
THE OTHER TOP INDUSTRY IN THE
COUNTY TOURISM. MAKING LABOR IN
THE COUNTY VERY LIMITED. TO
THOSE LABOR SHORTAGES SB SIXTY
FIVE EXTEND THE STATE LAW. THAT
ALLOWS SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLDS TO WORK OVERTIME WHEN
CRACKING OCCURS IN AUGUST. WHEN
SCHOOL'S NOT IN SESSION TO LEVY
THE SUMMER LABOR SHORTAGE ALL
WORK PERMITS A PROCESS RIDLEY
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. IS
DIRECTLY SUPERVISED BY THE
COUNTY SCHOOL SUPERINTENDENT HE
SUPPORTS THE PROGRAM. PROGRAM
IS ALSO OVERSEEN AT THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL BY THE OFFICE
OF THE LABOR COMMISSIONER. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THESE WORK
PERMITS CANNOT BE ISSUED DURING
THE SCHOOL YEAR WHICH MEANS
STUDENTS CANNOT WORK WITH
SCHOOLS IN SESSION. ONLY DURING
SUMMER MONTHS. THE ORIGINAL LAW
PASSED IN NINETEEN HUNDRED AND
NINETY SIX. IN EVERY EXTENSION
SYSTEM HAS RECEIVED BROAD
SUPPORT FROM BOTH HOUSES OF THE
LEGISLATURE. SB SIXTY FIVE
WOULD EXTEND THE SUNSET UNTIL
JANUARY TWENTY THIRTY TWO. ALSO
REQUIRES A LABOR COMMISSIONER
THE FOLLOWING NEW REPORTS FOR
TWENTY THIRTY MAINTAINED ALL OF
THE STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS. FOR
EMPLOYERS TO USE THE LAW. WE
WITH US TODAY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY SUPER LEE COUNTY
SCHOOLS BROUGHT FALKENBERG- AND
ALSO LOU BROWN LET'S SEE
RELATIVELY CALIFORNIA FRESH
FRUIT ASSOCIATION. THE MAIL BY
FEAR THE COMPLETE STILL
REPRESENTATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR CORTESE WE WILL
NOW MOVE INTO OUR LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. TRYING TO
FIND THEIR NAMES. I GREW UP IN.
THE WATERS THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION ON THAT ITEM-
CARE WHEN IS IT APPROPRIATE TO
MAKE A MARK. ON THE LINE IS IT
APPROPRIATE TO MAKE A MOTION BY
HIS MANAGER- I WILL I WILL I
MOTION TO BE ARE PUT ON THE
TABLE. YES I'D MOVE THIS BILL.
OKAY AND WHAT'S AHEAD TO THE
SPEECH. BUT IS A HINT THE SPEAK.
WE DO HAVE TO LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON Q. THAT WE HAVE
LOUIS BROWN AND BROCK
FALKENBERG AND I'LL LET YOU
FOLKS DECIDE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
GO FIRST DISAPPOINTED BORDER-
AND I'M NOT TO CHAIR THE MOMENT.
OUR OF STEAM PUBLISHERS TAKEN
OVER SOMEONE TO MAKE I WANT TO
DEFER TO IN ALL SERIOUSNESS IN
TERMS OF THE MOTION ON THE
TABLE WITH- THAT'S YOUR
PREROGATIVE NOT MINE. LAST YEAR
I THOUGHT YOU WERE BUT- I OPEN
MY MOUTH AND LOOKING AT YOUR
LOCATION. I JUST MAKE SURE I'M-
TO THE CHURCH THANK YOU YEAH.
HOURS AT. AFTER THAT THE
PROCESS RGHT. OKAY JUST MAKING
SURE- DO WE HAVE LOUIS BROWN ON
THE ON Q. MATTER- MODERATOR.
I'M SURE THIS IS LOUIS BROWN
I'M PREPARED TO GIVE A VERY
BRIEF STATEMENT IF YOU'RE
READING VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM SURE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LOU
BROWN ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
FRESH FRUIT ASSOCIATION IT'S A
DIFFICULT PERSON REQUIRE THAT
PRETTY TIRED COMMUNITY I'M HERE
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE THEM BUT
AFTER BIRTH REPORT. AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M
MISERABLE WE HAVE NEXTEL BROCK
FALKENBERG ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
I AM IN AND GOOD EVENING. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE I AM
BROCK FALKENBERG EMILY COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS AND
I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF LAKE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. THIS BILL WILL
EXTEND THE OPPORTUNITY AND
TRADITION FOURTEENS IN LAKE
COUNTY. AGES SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN TO GAIN MEANINGFUL
SUMMERTIME EMPLOYMENT. INITIAL
PRESENTATION WAS QUITE THOROUGH
SO I'M GONNA CUT TO A FEW KEY
POINTS HERE IN MY PRESENTATION
HENCE PRESS THAT THE LAKE
COUNTY ECONOMY TRADITIONALLY-
LAGS BEHIND CALIFORNIA AS A
WHOLE SO THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK IN THE SUMMER. PROVIDES A
GREAT SENSE OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
OUR TEAMS TO- HELP SUPPORT
THEIR FAMILIES FINANCIALLY.
STUDIES INDICATE THAT TEENS AT
WORK ARE MORE LIKELY TO BECOME
PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS AS ADULTS
THEY LEARN HOW TO APPLY FOR AND
KEEP A JOB THEY DEVELOP A SENSE
OF RESPONSIBILITY AND A STRONG
WORK ETHIC THEY LEARNED THE
IMPORTANCE OF BEING LIFELONG
LEARNERS COMPLETING THEIR
EDUCATION AND SETTING GOALS TO
ATTAIN THEIR VISION. FOR
THEMSELVES- I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO STRESS THAT THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. I'M WILL
NOT LET THIS EMPLOYMENT
SITUATION AND NEGATIVELY IMPACT
LEARNING ACCELERATION
STRATEGIES THAT MAY BE
IMPLEMENTED AS A RESULT THE
RESULT OF THE CURRENT PANDEMIC-
SO I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE ON S. B. SIX EIGHTY
FIVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER FALCON BURKE NOW LET'S
BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE SEEN
NONE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
AND ROOM TWENTY FORTY WE SHOULD
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB SIX
EIGHTY FIVE. SEE NON. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE WITNESSES WANTING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
YSIS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WHEN
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
THIRTY FIVE WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
EIGHTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NINE TO EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BELIEVING THIS IS BRIAN LITTLE
WITH CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK AND HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT MODERATOR WOULD YOU
MIND CHECKING THE Q. ONE MORE
TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL THE THAT
WOULD ASSIST IN SUPPORT OF. SB
SIXTY FIVE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX EIGHTY FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS
WILL FOLLOW NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. LET'S MOVE ON TO
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE- ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO IT SB SIX EIGHTY
FIVE. SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WAS TESTIFYING OPPOSITION
TO SB SIX EIGHTY FIVE. C. NINE.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE WITNESSES WILLING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
THIS. FEDERATED YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT THEY INDIVIDUALS
WHEN TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SIXTY FIVE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SIX EIGHTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NINE THREE FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
JUST TO CLARIFY WE ARE NOT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WE ARE
ALSO NOT IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE TO ADDRESS SOME
CONCERNS WHICH I THINK COULD
BE. QUICKLY SUMMARIZED AS WE
ARE SOMEWHAT CONCERNED ABOUT
EXTENDING THE SUNSET FOR TEN
YEARS IN THE ABSENCE OF THE
RECORDS FROM THE I. R. THAT
OUTLINES HOW WELL THE PROGRAM
HAS BEEN WORKING FOR THESE
AFFECTED WORKERS WE HAVE GONE
NEUTRAL NEEDS EXTENSIONS IN THE
PAST BUT WE ARE. SLIGHTLY
CONCERNED ABOUT OFFENSE
EXTENSION THAT FAR WITHOUT THAT
INFORMATION FROM DR AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE OFFICE
OFFICE TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE CONCERNS ARE ADDRESSED.
THANKS FOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIRTY OF KNOWINGFURTHER
COMMENTS IN Q. THANK YOU MATTER
IF YOU'LL PLEASE CHECK A LOT
THANK YOU ONE MORE TIME JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HEARD FROM
ALL WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
S. B. SIX THIRTY FIVE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
EIGHTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE THANK YOU MODERATOR.
THANK YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DO
ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. WE
ALREADY HAVE A MOTION CORRECT
CORRECT. I JUST LIKE TO MAKE
ONE COMMENT ON JUST REALLY
QUICK IS- I WISH WE COULD HAVE
THIS EXTENDED TO ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA NOT JUST TO ONE AT
ONE AREA I THINK COULD BE VERY
HELPFUL TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA-
AS- YOUNG KIDS TO BE ABLE TO
WORK IN THEIR RESPECTIVE AREAS-
JUST NOT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE IN SENATOR
CORTESE YES IS THE ANSWER AS
ONE OF THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE MANY
MANY YEARS AGO WHO SPENT
AUGUST- IN THE PARAFIELD SORT.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY US FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE IN THE HOPE THAT
SOME OF THEM MAY EVEN BECOME
SENATOR SUNDAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SO WE HAVE A MOTION- ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR LAYERED TO
MOVE- SB. SIX EIGHTY FIVE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS. BUT RICK BUT
B. FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR CORTESE HI FENDER
CORTEZ THE I. X. CENTER- CHOKE
HI AND- OCHO POKE HI SENATOR
DORADO. SENATOR DORADO HI
CENTER LAYERED HI SENATOR
LAYERED HI SENATOR NEWMAN ALL
RIGHT SENATOR NEWMAN HI THE
BILL HAS FIVE VOTES. THE BILL
IS OUTWITH FIVE FIVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED
TODAY. WE'RE ABLE. PRESIDING
TODAY NATALIE SURE THANK YOU TO
REFER YOUR PATIENTS- YEAH WE
ARE NOW INSURANCE FACT. MEMBERS
OF THE. VERY VERY.